r is a widely used programming language
for data science
hello everyone welcome to this video on
r4 data science full course
today we have our experienced
instructors richard aj
and pete ferrari who will help us learn
everything from basics to advanced
and master data science in r
we will start by learning data science
from an animated video
you will then learn the essential
concepts in data science and understand
the important packages in r
for data science such as dplyr and idr
you will look at some of the widely used
data science algorithms such as linear
regression
logistic regression decision trees
random forests
including time series analysis finally
you will get an idea about the salary
structure
skills jobs and resume of a data
scientist
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist
keep watching this video if you're
passionate about data science because we
will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
emma is a data scientist
let's see how a day in her life goes
while she's working on data science
project
well it is very important to understand
the business problem first
in our meeting with the clients emma
asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled
she is a curious soul who asks a lot of
eyes one of the many traits of a good
data scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from multiple
sources like web servers
logs databases apis and online
repositories
oh it seems like finding the right data
takes both
time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation
this step involves data cleaning and
data transformation
data cleaning is the most time consuming
process as it involves handling
many complex scenarios here emma deals
with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values
and what not then in data transformation
she modifies the data
based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica
are used to perform complex
transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial
for that emma does exploratory data
analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but
what if emma skips this step she might
end up choosing the wrong variables
which will produce an inaccurate model
thus exploratory data analysis becomes
the most
important step now she proceeds to the
core activity of a data science project
which is data modeling she
repetitively applies diverse machine
learning techniques like knn
decision tree knife base to the data to
identify the model
that best fits the business requirement
she trains the models on the training
data set and test them
to select the best performing model emma
prefers
python for modeling the data however it
can also be done using
r and sas well the trickiest part is not
yet
over visualization and communication
emma meets the clients
again to communicate the business
findings in a simple and effective
manner to convince the stakeholders
she uses tools like tableau power bi and
clickview that can help her in creating
powerful reports and dashboards and then
finally she deploys and maintains the
model
she tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment
before deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports
and dashboards to get real-time
analytics
further she also monitors and maintains
the project's performance
well that's how emma completes the data
science project
we have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun
has a lot of interesting aspects and
comes with its own share of challenges
now let's see how data science is
changing the world
data science techniques along with
genomic data provides a
deeper understanding of genetic issues
in reaction to particular drugs
and diseases logistic companies like dhl
fedex have discovered the best rules to
ship the best suited time to deliver
the best mode of transport to choose
thus leading to cost efficiency
with data science it is possible to not
only predict
employee attrition but to also
understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover also the
airline companies can now easily predict
flight delay and notify the passengers
beforehand to enhance their travel
experience
well if you're wondering there are
various roles offered to a data
scientist
like data analyst machine learning
engineer
deep learning engineer data engineer and
of course data scientist
the median base salaries of a data
scientist can range from
95 000 to 165 000
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist
if yes then start today the world of
data
needs you that's all from my side today
thank you for watching
comment below the next topic that you
want to learn and subscribe to simply
learn to get the latest updates on more
such interesting videos data science
with
r sponsored by simply learn that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead my name is
richard kirschner and i'm with the
simply learn team
what's in it for you we're going to go
through an introduction to our
yr cran comprehensive r
archive network and cover installing r
then we'll get into
simple linear regression using r line of
best fit using error summation
correlation analysis in r and then we'll
get into classification using r
use case predict the class of a flower
let's start with an introduction to r
first it's an open source r is
completely free and open source with
active community members
extensible it offers various statistical
and graphical techniques
compatible r is compatible across all
platforms linux windows and mac
library r has an extensive library of
packages
for machine learning easy integration it
can
be easily integrated with popular
software's like tableau sql server etc
this only touches a little bit on these
different aspects of
r the fact that it's a free it's very
extensive it probably has one of the
most extensive set
of data analysis packages currently out
it has a compatibility is continually
growing so it's integrated with
everything from
cluster computing to python integration
which is now coming out
and its extensive libraries allows you
to import the different libraries to use
for whatever your needs are makes it a
very diverse and easy to use
coding source for analyzing data r is
more than just a programming language
as i just touched upon it it has a
worldwide repository system
comprehensive r archive network and it
can be accessed at
https colon slash cran.rproject.org
it provides up-to-date versions of code
and documentation for r
cran hosts around 10 000
packages of r that is a huge repository
focused on
just data analytics let's install r to
get started
you can easily download the executable
file for r and install it from
cran website if you go under the
downloads
in this case since i'm on a windows
machine we'll walk through it from the
r 3.5 version for windows so
here we are at https colon slash
cran.r project.org
and you can see down here we have the
different options for the downloads
if we go under windows which is i'm on a
windows machine if you're on a mac
machine you do the mac
or linux there's install r for the first
time just click on that and
open and run it the installation is
pretty simple
follow the default options to finish the
installation after the installation is
complete you'll see the r
icon on your desktop alternatively there
are mirror sites
and so we can go into our studio let's
just take a quick look at that
if you're on the rstudio website that's
www.rstudio.com
you can go down under products and r
studio download
you'll see a number of options here the
first one is the rstudio desktop
open source license that's the same
thing you just downloaded so if you
download that that's what you're getting
there's also an open source server setup
which is also free you can download from
here
and then rstudio offers a number of paid
packages which includes all kinds of
different supports for a company and
individual level
setup whether you go through the cran
site or the rstudio site the
installation is pretty simple
just a quick note if you're a debian
distribution including ubuntu you can
install
r using as regular package management
tools and when you're using a linux
system that is preferred because it
registers it properly on the setup
system
let's go ahead and open up our r studio
and take a look
here we are and i've opened this up in
the r studio version
which automatically opens up some extra
windows which is nice let's go and take
a look at that we have our console on
the left
this is your main workspace so if i go
in here and i do
click the mouse and i do a four plus
four
i'll come up and say the answer is eight
and you have some environmental
information
and over on the right you have plots
usually when you're working in here
let's do a script we'll go up here into
the plus sign in the upper left hand
corner and just add some script
in here in this case it showed up on the
top but you can move these windows
around
unless i do y equals 3
plus 4 x equals y
plus two and then i'm going to do just x
and let's do a
plot and throw a plot in there c
sees a notation that these are going to
be cartesian points so we got one
comma two comma three i'd be like your x
and then y three comma four comma five
for just a standard
call scatter plot um we don't have to
memorize this we'll go into some of this
later on
and then i can take all of this if i go
under code since i'm working in the code
console
and i go down to run region and just run
all it takes this code and just runs it
through my console
and you can see down here it's executed
y equals three plus four
x equals x plus two and if you add three
plus four plus two you get nine that's
what the x does and then i did a plot i
threw the plot in there i'm plotting one
two
three three four five and if you use
just a straight plot it's a scatter plot
and you can see that this appears on the
bottom right where you have your plots
coming in
so it's a very quick way to show data
this one the wonderful things about r
is it's very easy and quick to go
through
and do different functions on the data
and analyze it
so it's a very popular package before
you start programming an r
you should install packages and its
dependencies
packages provide pre-assembled
collections of functions and objects
each package is hosted on the cran
repository
not all packages are loaded by default
but they can be installed on demand
remember earlier we're talking about all
the different packages available
you don't want to install everything
from r it would just
be a huge waste of space you want to
just install those packages you need so
to install packages in rstudio you go
under tools
and install packages when you click on
the install packages you'll get a dialog
box
you'll see where as a repository cran
because there's other repositories and
you can even download and install your
own packages you can build
and then you'll pick out the packages
you want and separate multiple
spaces or commas so you can install
numerous packages at the same time
in this case we've installing the
forecast forecast package and you can
see down here i just type in forecast
all the install all the dependencies
uses other packages to build on it has
those then just click on install and
it's done
before we cover the basic linear
regression model let's just take a quick
look
at some of the different parts of our or
parts of
programming you'll need or scripting
first you know there are various
data structures in r we have vectors we
have
matrixes we have arrays data frames
and lists vectors is the most basic
data structure if you remember vectors
are a
location and a direction it's how
they're generally defined
although a vectors you're talking about
scripting can contain
numerous different values you could have
vectors with four five six seven eight
different values in it
for example a picture on the computer
might have
the location of the pixel and the number
for the red queue
and the green hue and the blue hue so
now you have something with five
different numbers in it consisting of
that vector
matrixes allow you to move stuff around
so you might have a two by three matrix
that you switch
to a three by two we looked at an xy
plot earlier
it might be that you have everything uh
is you have 10 different numbers and
each one has two values x y
and you need to switch that matrix so
then you have two arrays of five numbers
arrays are just at a collection and you
can have arrays of arrays of arrays
data frames have labels on them which
makes them easier to use so usually we
use a lot of data frames when we're
working with data
because they're just easy you can have a
column and you can have a row so think
of rows and columns when you see the
term data frames
and then lists are usually homogeneous
groups
so in our you're usually looking at
similar data that's connected in the
list
so the first thing we do is before we
even importing the data
you should have the data ready so we
need to look at the data and see what's
going on
you can import data from various sources
including excel
minitab csv table text files
csv is usually a text file comma
separated variables tabs separated
variables there's all kinds of different
options here
and importing the table is very simple
we have table
read table file equals data table enter
equals true
and let's just take a closer look at
what we're talking about here scratch
the closer look
i didn't realize it was just for example
so importing a table file is pretty
simple you read dot
table file equals data dot table so
whatever the name of the file is
comma header equals true so if there's a
header to it in this quick flash they
have
name age gender we'll actually do this
in r with another data set in just a
minute but you can see it's very easy to
read
a lot of people use are even in other
programming languages so they can
quickly look at the data before they
even start analyzing it
csev file same thing read.csv file
equals data csv
header equals true separation equals
space so in this case even though
csv stands for comma separated variable
this one is
separated by spaces and they have the
header name age gender
so it's the same file saved as a csv
file and there's also
excel um excel has its own issues
as far as making sure you know what the
tables are and the headers are but you
can see that each one of these is easy
to import
so and just like it's easy to import the
data
you can also export tables in r so you
can see here uh
right dot table my file see my file dot
text comma separated and the scoop t
just means it's tab separated so if
you're using tabbed files on there
example excel so you can write a dot xls
to my file in this case it is a text
separation equals scoop t so it's a tab
separated for excel file
csv same thing very easy to write a csv
file to
your computer once you've changed the
data or alternate depending on what
you're doing with it
and once we have our data imported and
we can save it afterwards and export it
graphing visualization in r is very
powerful
and it's quick love doing this before
even exploring the data sometimes you
just want to graph it to see what it is
there so you have an idea of what you're
looking for
so graphics and r cover a huge amount of
different things
r includes powerful package of graphics
that help in data visualization
these graphics can be viewed on screen
saved in various formats including pdf
png
jpeg wmf and ps can be customized
according to very graphic needs you can
copy and paste in word or powerpoint
files
r supports various types of graphics
including bar chart
pie chart histogram kernel density plots
line chart box plot heat map word cloud
there's even some more obscure ones but
these are the main ones that most people
use
i know i use a lot of heat maps but word
clouds are a lot of fun if you're doing
websites and
data and word analysis and histogram is
very popular all of these are very
widely used
let's look at the box plots also known
as
whisker diagrams box plots display the
distribution of data based on
minimum first quartile medium third
quartile
and maximum so right off the bat we can
use a box plot to explore our data with
very little work
to create a box plot we simply give box
plot and the data very straightforward
so we might have passenger numbers in
the thousands i guess this is
exploring data dealing with airplanes
and you can see here they just have a
simple
plot if you break it down you have your
if we go back one you'll notice we have
like a minimum a maximum
our medium first quartile and third
quartile let's just break that apart
you can see the line on the bottom is
your minimum your line on the top is the
maximum you have your medium
and your first quartile right there
first quartile and third chordal
and the way a lot of times you read this
is things that are above the box are
outliers and things below the box or
outliers
and what's in the middle of the box is
use the data you're looking at
let's learn about data manipulation in r
and here we will
learn about d player package
and when we talk about this d player
package it is
much faster and much easier to read than
base r so d player package is used to
transform
and summarize tabular data with rows and
columns
you might be working on a data frame or
you might be getting in a
inbuilt r data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get
this package deployer by just
calling in library function and this can
be used for grouping by data
summarizing the data adding new
variables
selecting different set of columns
filtering our data sets sorting it
selecting it arranging it or even
mutating
that is basically creating new columns
using functions
on existing variables so let's see how
we work with dplyer
now here i can basically get
the package here so i can just say
install
dot packages d plier now we already see
the
the package here which is showing up so
i will just select this one i can do a
control
enter and that will basically set up the
package
package deep player successfully
unpacked so that is done
now you can start using this package by
just doing a library d plier
and this was built it shows me my
version of r
so let's also use a inbuilt data set
that is new york flights 13 so we can do
install dot packages
and that will search and get that
relevant data set
i can again call it by using library
function
now once that is done we can look at
some sample data here
by just doing view flights and that
shows me the data in a
neat and a tabular format which shows me
year
month day departure time schedule
departure time and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data
which can help us in understanding the
data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here
it shows me how many variables we have
so this is fine
now we can start using the player and
in that we can use say filter function
if we would want to look in for
specific value now here we have the
column as
month so i will do a filter
now i'm creating a variable f1 i'm using
the filter function
on flights which we already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically
look at the month where the month value
is 0
7 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on
f1 which shows me the data wherein you
have filtered out
all the data based on month being 7. so
this is a simple usage of filter we can
take some other example we
may want to include multiple columns so
we can say
f2 filter flights and here we will say
month is equal to 7 day is 3
and then look at the value of f2 if you
are interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month is 7 and
days 3
you could also look into a more readable
format by using
view on f2 and that gives me my selected
result so we are just extracting in
some specific value we can keep
extending this
so here we can say flights is what we
would want to work on
i'm using the filter function so i can
straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view
i can also do a view in this way i can
just pass in my
filter within the view and within this i
am saying filter
i would want to look at the flights
month being 0 9
day being 2 and origin being lga
and then that shows me the value here
and
obviously you can scroll and look at
all the columns and if you see the
origin column it shows the selected
value so now
we have filtered out our data based on
values
in three different columns now
what we can also do is we can use and
or we can use or operators so
i could have done this in a a little
different way so i could have said
head which shows me initial result
i will do a flight so within my head
function i am passing in this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights
and in this flights data set you would
want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we given a value
and i'll say and and i'll again say
flights
wherein i will select the day being 2
and and and remember when you talk about
and
it is going to check if all the values
are met
true so then you say flights origin
lgea and you look at the value so
in this way i can filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now
we could have done it in this way we
could have created a view or we could
have assigned this to a
variable and then done a view on that
where we could have selected
month being day and origin or
you can be more specific
in specifying all the columns it makes
the code more readable
so let's look at the values and here you
are looking at head
which shows me based on month day
and then you can look for further
columns for other variables that is
origin being lga now what we can also do
is we can do some slicing here
to select rows by particular position
so i can say slice and i would want to
look at
rows one two five and i can do this
so you can always assign or look at the
view
of this i can just do here
so when i did a slide one is to five
it shows me my entries
for one to five now similarly
we can do is slice five to 10
and now you are looking at 5 to 10
values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to
apply some variable on a particular data
set
and then you would want to add it to
your existing data frame or you would
want to add
a new column so this is where you use
mutate which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate
so it's pretty simple so you create a
variable over delay
now i would want to do a mutate so that
it adds a new column
so i'm selecting my data which is flight
i will call the new column as
overall delay and then basically
i can look at overall delay being
arrival delay minus departure delay so
let's create this
and let's look at view of this which
shows me
or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay
which was not in my original data set so
you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare
the value so this one shows me arrival
delay and then there are many other
variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view
and you could have just look at flights
if you would want to compare
so you can look at the flights and this
one would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here and if you
do a view on overall delay
then that basically shows me 20 columns
so we know that the new column has been
added
to this overall delay so if you would
want to work with 20 columns you will
use overall delay
if you would want to work with your
original data set you will use flights
now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show
only the new column so we can do an
overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay
the computation remains same but at this
time
if i look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute
result based on two variables or two
columns and just look at the new value
and then we can decide if we would want
to add it to our existing structure
now you can also use summarize and
summarize basically helps us
in getting a summary based on
certain criteria so we can always do a
summarize and what we can do
is we can look at our data and we can
say
on what basis we would want to summarize
this particular data
so we can do a summarize function now
summarize on flights
i will say average a time and i would
want to calculate
an average so for that i am using
inbuilt function called mean
i will do that on airtime column
so let's look at flights once again
and here we can see there is arrival
time not a time sorry arrival time
and we would want to do some average on
this particular
data we would want to summarize this so
what i'll do
is i will use the summarize function
i will say average airtime and this one
i will look at mean of a time so let's
see if there is a
airtime column i might be let's look at
this one
and i will delay and yes we have an
airtime so we were actually looking at
summarizing based on airtime not the
arrival time
so air time is how much time it takes in
air for this particular flight
and we will want to use the trans
summarize
function not the transmute so summarize
flights
average a time and this one we will
calculate the mean
of average a time and i will also do a
any removal which is i'm saying true so
let's do this
and that basically shows me the average
a time is 151
i can also do a total airtime where i am
doing a summation
of values or i can get the standard
deviation
or i can basically get multiple values
such as mean
i can say total airtime where i am doing
a summation
and then i can look at other values
which is
if you would want to put in standard
deviation here you could do that
so let's look at the result of this
summarize and this basically
allows me to get some useful information
which is
summarized based on a particular
function such as mean
sum standard deviation or
all three of them now let's look at
grouping by so sometimes we may be
interested in
summarizing the data by groups and
that's where we use the group by
function so we can always
use the group by clause
now here we are taking a different data
set
so we will say for example let's look at
head of mt cars
and that is basically my data set on
empty cars
now that shows me the model of the car
it shows me my lathe
cylinder power this and your horsepower
and various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set
so here we can say let's do a grouping
by
gear so there is a column called gear so
i will
call it by gear i will look at my data
set
and then what i am using here which you
see with these percentage and greater
symbol
is called piping so that basically
feeds your previous data frame into next
one so this is sometimes useful
and you can get this by just saying
control shift and
m and you can then use this so we are
going to
have piping so i am saying empty cars
now this is my original data set
where i did a head or i could have done
a view
on this one if you would want to see it
in a more
readable format and that basically shows
me the data
so we are using a different data set so
i want to group it by
the gear column so i'm going to call it
by gear
and this one takes my data that is empty
cars
i'm using the piping and then i'm saying
group the data based on gear column
that's done now let's look at the value
of by gear
or you can always do a view
so remember whenever you're doing a
group by it is giving you
a internal object where your data is
grouped based
on a particular column so we can look at
the values here
you can do a view that shows you your
data grouped based on
a particular column now i can again use
the summarize function
where i would want to now work on the
new one
where it was grouped based on gear so i
am doing a summarize
and here i am going to say gear 1
which will be having the value of
summation
on the gear column and then i am saying
gear
2 which is mean well you could give some
meaningful names to this
and let's look at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is
sum and mean values based on
the gear similarly we can use look at
different example
so we can say by gear and i am again
using piping
but earlier we had taken gear
we had grouped the data and we called it
by gear so we took our original data set
empty cars but now
within this particular data which was
grouped by gear
i will take this data set i will use the
piping
and i will summarize it where i am
saying
within this particular data set i would
want to get the sum
or i would want to get the mean and then
you can look at the values
so what you are doing is you are
either looking at your original data set
or you're looking at the data which was
already grouped and then you can look at
the values
now here what we can do is we can group
by cylinder
say might be you are interested in
looking at data which is summarized
based on the cylinder column
you can do that and then for this
by cylinder i am doing a piping where i
am
using the summarize function and
summarizing
will then be done based on the mean
values of the gear column
or the horsepower so let's do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point
you may want to look at the data set
again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and by cylinder or by gear
and do a head and it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping
in these ways now here we
are going to use sample underscore n
function
and sample underscore fraction
for creating samples so for this
let's take the flights data set again
and we would want to get 15 random
values
now that is done and it shows me 15 rows
with some random values from the data
what you can also do is you can do a
portion of data by
using sample underscore fraction
and here i'll say flights i'll say 0.4
which will return 40 percent of the
total data
so this can be useful when you are
building your machine learning
where you would want to split your data
into training and test might be you are
interested in some portion of the data
so you can do this which is very useful
function
and then you can look at the value of
that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function
so like we were doing a grouping by or
we were
trying to pull out a particular column
so in the same way
we can use a range which is a convenient
way of sorting
than your base are sorting so for a
range function
let's do a view based on a range
so we will work on the flights data set
which we have
and here what we would want to do is we
would want to arrange the flights data
set
which is based on year and departure
time
and we are doing a view out of it so
that basically
gives me the data which is arranged
based on your year and departure time
now i can do a head to give me some
highlighting of that data now
the piping operator what we are using
can be used in these ways also
so here i will say df i will
just assign the data set empty cars to
it
let's look at the df which has basically
your different models
you can obviously look at the head or
view of it to look at useful information
we can also go for nesting options which
can be useful
so we are creating a variable called
result here
now that has the arrange function so
what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange
to sort the data so i would want to sort
the data
but what data would i sort so i will use
sample n
which will give me some portion of the
data or some sample data now what is
that sample data so here we are using
nesting
that is earlier when we did a sample
we just said data and how many random
samples we want
but instead of giving that what we are
going to do is we are going to use
filter here
now this filter will work on df
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20
i will say size is 5 and i would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so i'm using the des
on this particular mileage column by
default it is always ascending
so let's get the result out of this
which will
basically show me the mileage details in
a descending order
so this is my data frame and now
we can look at the result what we have
created
so just do a view or do a head
and look at the view so here you see
mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values
in a random sample so that's why when
you did a view
it shows your five values and it shows
in a descending order based on mileage
so we have
not only used an inbuilt function we
have not only arranged the data that is
we have sorted the data
but we have sorted the data based on a
descending order
on a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20
and we have also said we just need five
random samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi-assignment
so i can say filter wherein i am going
to use
df which was assigned empty cars i am
going to say
mileage should be greater than 20 then
i say b which is going to get a sample
out of a and i just want 5
random values so let's look at that so
we have b
which is going to get a
set of 5 values from a now i will create
a result variable
which will arrange b which is sample
data
in a descending order now let's look at
the result of this
and that basically shows me what we were
seeing earlier
so you can do a multi assignment where
you can create a variable
get a sample out of it and then
basically whatever is that result you
can
arrange that or sort that in a
descending or
by default ascending order so same thing
we can do it using pipe operator so
piping
so here i will say result i'm passing in
my
df that's the data set i'm using piping
and which basically tells what you need
to do on this particular data set so i'm
going to filter out
the data based on mileage 50 sorry
mileage 20
then i'm going to push that or forward
it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it
and then basically you can look at the
result so these are some simple examples
where you can use your d plier
with multiple assignments or using your
nesting to filter out the data
you can also do a arrange which is to
sort the data you can get some random
samples out of it
you can summarize the data you can also
summarize the data based on one
or two or multiple columns and you can
use some inbuilt functions to summarize
the data based on some
functions which are applied on the
variables or on the columns
you can transmute it where you would be
interested in only looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it and you can
give the conditions where you can say
and on or
to filter out the data so what we can
also do
is on this particular data set which we
have say for example df
where i have my data let's look at this
one
and if i just do a df at this point it
shows me
my data set and if you would be
interested
only in particular column then your d
player also allows you to either we can
do a filter
or we can simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
uh our data so for example i'll say df
underscore i'm interested in mileage i'm
interested in horsepower
might be i am interested in your
cylinders
in this and for this one what i can do
is
when i would want to do a select i can
basically say
selected df let's call it some name
i can say control shift
m which is for piping and then basically
what you can do is you can do a select
and you can choose your columns so i was
interested in mileage
i was interested in horsepower
i was interested in cylinder and here
what i'm doing is i'm using a select
where i can look at the new data frame
so let's do this and
i'm sorry here we will have to give it
df
this is where you are passing in your
data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one
by just doing a df or
head on df
underscore mileage horsepower cylinder
and look at the selected result so you
can be looking at selective columns
i could have done this filter but filter
will always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be
your cylinders are more than 4 or
something else
but when you do a select you are
selecting specific columns
so view always gives you all the columns
head
gives you highlight but then select can
be useful when we are interested in
looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use dplyer
for manipulation for your data
transformation
for basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular data
and then working on it so similarly
there is one more package called
tidr and we'll see how we can use data
manipulation
done using your tidr package let's
uh learn about that idr package
which makes it easy to tidy your data
and this basically helps you creating a
more cleaner data
so which is easy to visualize and
model now this comes with mainly four
functions
so you have gather which makes your data
wide or it makes white data longer so
that is basically used to stack
up multiple columns you have spread
function
which makes long data wider that is
stacking the data together or stack
if you would want to unstack the data to
data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes
and then your spread can spread the data
across multiple columns
you have separate which is function
which splits
single column into multiple columns and
to complement that you have one more
function which is unite and that
combines multiple columns into
single columns so these are four main
functions which are used
in your idr package so let's look how we
work with this
so let me bring up my r studio here now
for this
first is let me just clean up my screen
here doing a control
l so i will install the package it is
already installed but we can just do a
control
enter and then i can say do you want to
restart
r prior to reinstall install i'll say
okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package tid tidy r the rest
idrs
has been successfully unpacked let's use
that package
using our library function
and that was built under our version 3.6
now i can basically start using these
functions so for example here we are
creating a data frame so let's say
n is 10 and then we basically would say
we will call it white now that's the
variable name
i'm using the data.frame function i'm
saying id
which will be 1 to n so that will take
the values from 1 to 10
and then these are the values which have
ten entries so this is a vector phase
one phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it
now that's done we can have a look at
our data frame
by just doing a view wide and that shows
me the id column
and it has face dot one face dot two and
face dot
three now we can use our function so for
example we can work with
gather that is reshaping the data from
wide
format to long format and basically you
can say stacking up multiple
columns so let's see how we do that here
i'll call it long
i'm working on white i'm using the
piping
functionality and then i'm using gather
so this one
i will say what will be the data which i
will use
so we are using wide as a data frame
then i am saying response time so that
will be
basically one more column and then you
have your columns which you would want
to
basically stack so i'm saying from phase
one to phase three
so let's do this and once this is done
let's have a look
at our variable long so this one shows
me that i have an id column
i have the response time column and i
have the
face column which we mentioned and that
basically has
all the values stacked in so you have
face dot one face dot two
and face dot three so if all the columns
are being stacked here
so all my data so now i have totally 30
entries in this one
so this is basically using your gather
function now sometimes we may want to
use a separate function now separate
function is basically splitting
a single column into multiple columns
so which we would want to use when
multiple variables are captured
in a single variable column okay so
let's look at an example of this one
so let's say long separate that's what
we will call we will work on this long
which has
all the data stacked in as the columns
we
selected then i am saying separate i
want the face column
and then i would say when i separate the
columns what are my column names now i
could also give a separator
by giving a comma and then mentioning
the separator if that is required
so let's do this now once this is done
let's have
a look at our long separate so what we
see
here is the column which we used
so we were doing a face column and that
was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
target
and number so that's what we see here so
you have
face being split into target and number
and then you have the
response time so this is how you use the
separate function
now there is also something called as
unite function which is
basically a complementing of separate
function so
it takes multiple columns and combines
the elements to a single column
so for example here we will
call it long unite and we will take long
separate which was separating the data
we want to unite so we will take phase
target
number and we want to have a separator
between them
so let's basically do this and now let's
look at the result
of this unite so you see
you have the face and target merged
together so you have face dot one
the separator is dot as we have
mentioned and we have united multiple
columns
so this is one more function
of your ti dr which helps you basically
tidy up your data or put it in a
particular way
now then you have your spread function
and this is basically for unstacking so
that is
if you have if you would want to convert
a stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is
of same attributes spread can be used so
that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so
it will take two columns say key and
value and spread it into multiple
columns
so it makes long data wider so we can
look at this one
we will say long unite i'm using the
piping
i will use the spread function i'll work
on the face column
and response time and let's do this and
then let's do a view on this so
it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning
so these are four functions which
are very helpful when we work with tidr
package so let's learn about
visualization and here
we will learn about r which can be used
for
your visualization now one thing which
we need to understand
is because of our ability to see
patterns
which is highly developed we can
understand the data better if we can
visualize it
so the efficient way or effective way to
understand
what is in our data or what we have
understood
in our data we should or we can use
graphical displays that is your data
visualization so there are
actually two types of data
visualizations so you have
exploratory data visualization which
helps us to understand
the data and then you have explanatory
visualization which helps us to share
our understanding with
others so when you talk about r r
provides various tools and packages to
create data visualizations and which can
be used for
both kind of data analysis or both kind
of visualizations
so when you talk about exploratory data
and
visualization the key is to keep all the
potentially relevant
details together now the objective when
we talk about exploratory data analysis
is to help you see what is in your data
and the main question is how much
details can
we interpret now when you talk about
different functions which we see here
such as plot which is more for a generic
plotting you have bar plot which is used
to plot
data using rectangular bars so you can
say creating bar
charts you have histogram or hist
function to create histograms where you
look at the
frequency of the data
are basically used to look at the
central tendency of the data
you have box plot which is used to
represent data in the form of quartiles
you have gg plot which is a package
which enables the user to create
sophisticated visualizations with the
little code using the grammar of
graphics and then you have plot lee or
plot ly it creates
interactive web-based graphs via the
open source javascript graphing library
now before we see some examples here
let's also talk about
when you talk about plotting let's also
try to understand
what kind of plots you can have and
what kind of techniques you have so let
me open up my r studio here
now for example i can pull out a
particular data set and let's look at
this one
so here i can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information
now what i can do is i can install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then i
can simply do
a plot wherein i am doing a plot
on cheque data set so let's see what
does that show
it summarizes the relationship between
four variables in chick-weight
data frame which is in our's built-in
data set package now from these plots we
can see
for example weight varies systematically
over time you can also see
that chicks were assigned to four
different diets
now when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some
editorial decisions what features we
would want to highlight for emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated
right so there are different ways of
doing it now when you talk about your
graphics or visualizations you have
i would say three different types or you
can say four
so you have the base graphics which is
easiest to learn
now here we are having an example of
base graphics
where i can use the base graphics i can
get a
data set using library then i can simply
create
using plot function to a generate a
simple scatter plot
of calories with sugar from u.s serial
data frame
in the mass package and then i can give
it a title
so this is basically a simple example of
base graphics
now you also have what we call as grid
graphics which is powerful set of
modules for building other tools
now you also have latest graphics which
is
general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your gg plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and
is based on grid graphics so you have
different ways now here
since i already have used library and i
have the data set
i can just do a x so i can assign the
sugar related values to x and calories
related value to y
then i can use one more which is
library function and calling in grid now
i can
basically use functions such as push
view port
if i would want to create a plot using
your grid graphics
to create the similar kind of plot which
we created using base graphics but this
will
give you much more power than base
graphics
it will have a steep learning curve
but it is usually useful so i can
do this where i'm saying push view port
then i can
basically say i would want to have a
data viewport
i would say different functions of your
grid package
so i'm saying rectangle you have x-axis
y-axis
given some points here and then
basically
you can add details to the graph by
giving the names to the columns
and you can basically create a simple
grid graphics based
plot here now there are different other
options which we can use to create plots
now before we go into understanding how
you create plots let me
just give you a brief on what are the
different kind of plots
and how they can be used so here
we will look at these different plots
now for example
we have a bar chart which is a graph
which shows comparisons across discrete
categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared
and y-axis which represents a measured
value
and height of the bars are proportional
to measured values
now to create different kind of charts
you can use ggplot which is a package
for creating graphs in
r it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits and that is a part
of tidy works ecosystem
so it takes each component of graph
accesses
you can give scales you can give colors
you can give the objects
and you can build graphs on particular
data
you can modify each of those components
in a way that's more flexible and user
friendly
you can if you are not providing details
for the components then ggplot will use
sensible defaults
and this basically makes it a powerful
and flexible tool
now here are different options when you
use your ggplot
such as you can use geom or what we call
as geometric objects
to form the basis of different type of
graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have scatter plots
that is underscore point you have
underscore box plot for box plots
you have quartile for continuous x
violin for richer display of
distribution
and jitter for small data so here is
some
simple example where i would not go into
too many details here but you can just
have a look at this one
where we are using library function to
get the ggplot2 package
then basically we would want to look
into the mileage data
we would want to look at the structure
of it and then
we can basically get the tidy words
package
finally we can create a bar chart
using geo underscore bar and
we can basically also mention what would
be in x-axis
now you can also give different colors
to basically add more meaning to your
data
you could also go for stacked bar charts
so
here we are actually telling ggplot
to map the data in the drive column
to fill the aesthetic so here i am
giving
aesthetic access class and i am saying
what is the data we need to have
and then we are using geom underscore
bar
so you can also have dodged bar
in your gg plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but
next to each other and you can create
that by using
your position as position underscore
dodge okay
now you can obviously use your different
packages which are inbuilt and you can
create your bar charts
and you have other kind of graphs such
as line graph
which is basically a type of graph that
displays information
as a series of data points connected by
straight line segments such as this one
and for this one we are using if you see
geom underscore line
now you can also create a scatter plot
which is a two dimensional data
visualization that uses
points to graph the values of two
different variables one in
an x axis one on y axis like what we saw
in base graphics example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship
or lack of relationship between two
variables
and you also have histogram which i
mentioned
is mainly to look at the distribution of
a data to look at the central tendency
of the data
basically looking at your
large amount of data or for a single
variable you would be
interested in saying where is more
data found in terms of frequency whereas
lesser data found in the graph
how close the data is towards its
mid point or what we call as mean median
mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins
so these are some basics on different
kind of graphs now we can look at some
examples
and see how that works so what we were
seeing
is some quick examples of base graphics
or grid
graphics now here let's do
an example of pie chart for different
products and units sold
so you want to create a graph for this
first let's create a vector and pass in
the value here
now i can also create labels which i
would want to assign to these values
and then basically i can plot the chart
by saying
pi so that's the kind of chart which i
would want to create
and i would say the data would be x and
labels
so let's do this and that shows me a
simple pie chart
now i can also give main details here so
instead of just doing a pi
x comma labels i can say what is the
main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a simple
plot now i can also find out what is the
percentage
and then basically i would be
interested in plotting the pie chart
which takes
x which takes the labels which will be
the percentage which we are calculating
here by doing a round function
and then you can basically give details
to your
graph you can say what color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it
needs to be in your chart
what are the values and then basically
fill up the colors
so let's run this one and that shows me
the percentage which was calculated and
it gives me the details
and we can always have a look at our
plot
now if you would want to go for a 3d pie
chart
then you can get the package which is
plotrix let's use that by calling in the
library function
let's pass in some data to x and let's
give some values or labels which will
make more meaning to the data and then
let's plot the 3d graph
so i'm saying pi 3d here where i'm using
x in labels
then i'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like
and basically give the values so it also
takes the title when you say main
and by chart of countries now let's
create
data for graph so again we are having a
variable here
we are create using the c function
creating a vector
and then let's create a histogram for
this one
where i would say x lab what would be
your
data around x axis what is the color
what is the border
and here i am creating a simple
histogram
which as i discussed earlier will always
show
your values on the x-axis and y-axis is
more of frequency
and then you can look at the set of
values and what is their frequency
and we can basically use this histogram
for
exploratory data analysis look at the
data try to understand what is the
central tendency of your data values
now we can also give some limits by
using the x
limb and y limb and then i can also
specify
what is the limit so we have given some
values here
wherein we have said your x limit is 0
to 40
and y limit is 0 to 5. now if you
compare this with the previous one
which we had created this one based on
the frequency
had taken the limits but we can assign
limits
explicitly by giving this and then
create a histogram which makes more
meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality let's view this to see what
does that data contain so you have
ozone solar wind temperature month
and the day so this is the kind of
information we have in the air quality
now let's use the plot function to draw
a scatter plot
where as i mentioned you would be
interested in
analyzing variables and see
what is the relationship between them so
to plot
a graph between ozone and wind values
so we will say plot we will say the data
which is
air quality from that i would be
interested in the ozone column or ozone
field
and the wind field i can create a plot
based on this
now i can also be saying what should be
the color
what is the type of the data which you
would want to create
and you can look at the info information
so you can create a histogram you can
create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better
and then infer some information from
that data
so let's take the air quality data set
itself
without specifying any particular column
and you can create a plot which shows me
all the different values which you have
in the data
and it basically shows you the
difference this is
more of an example like what we did for
chickweight where we
did a base graphics now you can assign
labels to the plot
so that is when you are creating a plot
you can say air quality
you will say ozone and then that's your
ozone concentration
you have your y lab which is the number
of instances
you have what is the title ozone levels
in new york city
what is the color so these are the
details what we have given
with our plot function and let's look at
the data so it just
tells me that this is the ozone
concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and
you are looking at the data now we could
also create a histogram
by picking up a particular column that
is such as solar
from your air quality and that basically
shows me the frequency
of solar values and we can then
try to find out what is the mid what is
the mean
what is the standard deviation and so on
you can also look at your histogram and
try to understand if it is left skewed
and right
skewed so we can do that now here
let's get the temperature out from this
particular data set
let's create a histogram on temperature
and that basically shows me
the frequency of the temperature values
and what values have the most frequency
or most occurrence now you can create a
histogram
with labels so let's do that with the
limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which
also takes the values and for each
set of frequency or each set of values
it gives me the labels
now you can have a histogram with
non-uniform width
so you could do that by doing a hist
function
and then passing in your temperature you
can say what will be the main
what is the title what will be your x
lab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color
what is the border what are the breaks
you would want to have
for your bars and you can simply create
a histogram using this
so this basically takes the breaks which
we have given
such as 55 to 60 60 to 70
70 to 75 and so on so this is basically
creating a histogram with non-uniform
width
and it purely depends on the kind of
values what you have
now you can also create a box plot which
sometimes helps us in
understanding the the data quartiles
also understanding our outliers so you
can create multiple box plots
based on the data from air quality so
we'll select all the data
and then we'll do some slicing on the
data so let's create a box plot which
tells me the values and if you look at
these points here
like single dots these are basically
your outliers
we can learn about that more in later
sections
so you can use your gg plot
2 library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install dot packages and get
ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart r and
i can say yes
so let it get the package i think the
package was already there
and now let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that i have the
library function
and let's do a attach where i'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then i will create a variable p1
i will use ggplot i will pass in my data
i'll give the aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot
to basically create a plot which gives
me
the box plot for the values here and
this is based on
the cylinders which is there in your
data so we can always look at what does
our data contain
and what kind of values or features
are available in the data now let's
create a box plot
we will also use the coordinate function
and that basically gives me
based on the data so i've changed the
coordinates
now if you look at the previous one
where we created a plot
we had mileage on the y y-axis and
cylinders
on the x-axis now i did a coordinate
flip
and that's like your transpose function
so you have created the box plot but you
have just flipped the coordinates
you can create a box plot and then say
fill which is the factor of cylinder
so that can be used to fill up the
values in your box plot
now what we can also do is we can
create factors so we have learned about
factors earlier
which is usually used to work on
categorical variables
so here let's create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have
am you have cylinder and if you look at
the factors which we have created we
have passed our data
what is the field or the column we are
interested in what is the level
of values there and what are the labels
for those values
right so we have learnt about factors
you can always look into the previous
section
and learn more about factors now let's
create
a scatter plot by using the ggplot
function
again we will use the data as empty cars
i will go for
mapping option and then i will give my
aesthetics
that is what would be x what would be
your y
and you also would want to use what kind
of
function you are using so let's go for
geom pawn
point and that basically helps me in
creating a scatter plot
now you can create a scatter plot by
factors
so here we will say gg plot
so notice in all of these cases
depending on the kind of data you have
depending on the kind of plot you are
interested in you will use the
ggplot and then basically a function
with that
or the inbuilt package so here i am
saying data is
empty cars i am going for mapping which
basically will take the values for your
x
and y what is the color and the coloring
will be done based on the factor values
now if you remember factors will
obviously have some levels
and those levels will basically help you
in differentiating between your
categorical variables
so i am saying as dot factor on cylinder
and then i am using geom point
to basically create this scatter plot so
let's do this
and i can look at the values of this one
so it says
must be there is an error which says
must at least
one color from the hue palette so let's
look at that one
so the error which we were facing when
we gave color
as the factor values was because when
you look at these
factors which were created with some
labels if we look at the values of these
it tells me there are any values in that
particular column
similarly your gear or similarly
you can completely look at the complete
data set it tells me cylinder
you have am you have care now these have
some
we have created some labels but these
have n a values
so what we can do is we can create a
scatter plot
as we did earlier by giving the
aesthetics and that's a symbol
scatter plot wherein i'm also using geom
point
so that i can have these points by
defaults or with defaults
you can also give a color specific
basically if you would want to have
different kind of data in the same plot
or i can create scatter plots
by different sizes by giving a size or
i can give a color and size and that's
again
one way in which you can create your
scatter plots now
let's also see how you can visualize
one more data set which is mpg
so i can also do it in this way where i
set ggplot2
and then pass and look at the data set
what we have here
you can just do a view on this to see
what my data contains if the fields have
any any values
if that's going to affect your plotting
so now
what we can do is we can create a bar
plot or a bar chart
so i am saying gg plot the data would be
as we have given in previous lines that
is ggplot2
mpg then i will say what should be in my
aesthetics and what kind of
chart are you going to create so i'm
saying geom underscore bar
so that's my bar chart and that has
basically your class and count
now you can create a stacked bar chart
where your information is stacked
in the same bars and we are still using
the same data
we are going for aesthetics which is
class
and then when you say geom bar which
creates your stack
bar we will use fill which is drive
and we can always go back and look at
our
data for example you can always look
into this so you have the drive column
here
and you are also working on this
complete data set
so let's go ahead and create a stacked
bar
chart and that basically gives me the
information where you have
the drive information which is stacked
here
now you can do a dodge by giving the
position as
dodge so we are still going to go for a
stack chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful
you can use this by using geom point
where you are mapping and you are
specifying what are your aesthetics
so we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class
and we have different classes and based
on that
my points have been colored now you can
also use a plot
ly or plotly library so let's install
this one
i will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then i can access that package using
library function
and then create a variable to which you
are assigning your plot
underscore l y plot so data is empty
cars
what will be your x axis what will be
your y axis
and details on your marker which we have
given
wherein i will give a list which is size
color which is a combination and then
you have your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where
i'm going to use plot ly
and let's look at this plot so
it basically gives me some information
now we see some warnings which are
getting generated
but there is you don't need to worry
about that
so you can look at the packages what you
have
and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot ly and look at the values of
those
so that's a plot with a trend which
explains me about my
data so this is a simple small tutorial
on
understanding or how you can
have your graphics or visualization used
to understand your data obviously there
are much more examples
much more ways in which you can pass
into your plot functions
or your gg plot and the inbuilt
packages which are available in r for
your
visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis
or explanatory data analysis so try
these graphs
and see if you can change these options
and try or create new visualizations
let's dive into why linear regression
now that we have come this far
i'm planning to take a closer look at
our cells so that we can estimate cells
in the future
how about we hire a data scientist you
can see our two uh
corporate individuals looks more like
they should be agents
or secret agents someplace discussing
how to better forward their company and
so they're going to come in and ask the
data scientist to come in good idea
this will help us to keep a constant
track of our cells so
why do we need linear regression let's
assume that we need to predict the
number of skiers based on snowfall
so this happens to be we've kind of
jumped one business to the next so we're
looking at the
skiing business very popular in a lot of
areas and
it's based on snowfall a lot of times
you figure you don't have snow you don't
have skiers but
can we actually use something more
specific instead of
look at snowing and instead of saying
hey look it's snowing we can actually
start
drawing graphs and the graph shows that
with an increase in snowfall
the frequency of skiers also increases
so
and there's a pretty direct correlation
if you've ever been up to ski areas when
there's a lot of snow
falls the skiers all show up because
they know it's going to be better skiing
right afterward so it's kind of easy to
see why
skiers and snowfall would go together
and usually draws a nice straight line
and you can easily predict
how many skiers and that way you can
also predict how many people you need to
service them
how many lifts they have up and running
and all the stuff that goes with running
a ski area thus we see that the number
of skiers are directly proportional to
the amount of
snowfall regression models a relation
between a dependent
y and an independent x variable this is
real important to understand regression
because when we talk about linear
regression it's the basis of almost all
our machine learning
algorithms out there and it's usually an
underlying part of the math in our deep
learning so it all starts here with
linear regression
and we talk about a dependent y and an
independent x
variable these are numbers we're usually
talking about floats
so we want to have an actual number
value coming out and that's different
than something that's categorical or we
want to know yes or no true false
so regression means we're looking for a
number the independent variable
is known as predictor variable and
dependent variable
is known as the response variable so we
have one predictor variable
the amount of snowfall and one response
variable
how many skewers are going to show up
and then we can take this relationship
and it can be expressed as y equals
beta we're going to use the greek letter
beta and we have beta naught
plus beta 1 x 1 and if you continue out
it'd be plus
beta 2 x 2 and so on till the nth degree
in this case snowfall is an independent
variable and skiers
is a dependent variable so we kind of
have a little quick overview
let's go ahead and talk a little bit
more about what is linear regression
so we're going to go from y predicting a
number of skiers for snowfall
and we've looked at the formula a little
bit but let's look closer at what
exactly is going on with linear
regression
and the question is going to come up in
an interview what is linear regression
linear regression is a type of
statistical analysis that attempts to
show the relationship between
two variables linear regression creates
a predictive model on any data
showing trends in data the model is
found by using the least
square method there are other methods
the least square method happens to be
the most commonly used
out there and we usually start with the
least square method since it's the most
common and usually works the best on
most models
and we're already looking at how linear
regression works but let's dig
deeper into it and let's take a closer
look how linear regression works
i will provide you with a data set which
has rent area
other information in it looks like our
secret agents have
put on their casual wear for this one
you need to predict rent accordingly
we are given area and rent here so you
can do
linear regression with more variables
but we're just going to look at the
area and then from that try to figure
out what the rent should be we plot the
graph
and if you look at it here you can see
that the graph kind of a linear pattern
with a little dip in it so
the area seems the rent seems to be
based on the area in most of our work
as data scientists we usually try to
start with a physical graph if we can so
we can actually look at and say hey does
what i'm fitting to this graph
look right you can solve a lot of
problems that arise by looking at the
graph and saying no that doesn't look
right at
all or oh i should be looking over here
for this then we find the mean
of area and rent so the mean just means
average and if you take one two three
four five and add them all together and
divide by
in this case there's five areas you get
three and the rent is two four six five
and eight if you add them all together
and divide by
five you get five and we plot the mean
on the graph so you can see right here
here's the mean
of the rent and the area it's kind of a
very central point which is what we're
looking for the average of everything in
there the best fit
line passes through the mean this is
real
important when you're eyeballing it as
humans we can do this fairly easy if
it's a straight line through a bunch of
data it gets more complicated
mathematically when you start adding
multiple variables and instead of a line
you have a curve but for basic linear
regression we're going to draw a line
through the data
and the lines should go through the
means that's going to be part of the
best fit for that line
but we see there are multiple lines that
can pass through the means
so depending on how you look at it you
can kind of wiggle the line around back
and forth
so we keep moving the line to ensure
that the best fit line has the least
square distance from the data points and
this is
you can see right here residual we have
our data point and then we look at this
distance between them
and we square that distance and that's
what they mean by the least
squared distance we want all those
distances to add up to the smallest
amount we can
we talk about that distance we call it
the residual it equals the y
actual minus the y predicted very
straightforward just looking at the
distance
you can accidentally switch these and
it'll come out the same because we're
going to square it but when you're
working with
other sets of linear regression you want
to make sure you do the y actual minus
the y predicted
the value of m and c for the best fit
line
y equals mx plus c can be calculated
using the mentioned formula
and you can see here we have m equals
the number of points that's what n
stands for then we have the sigma the
greek symbol is there which is a
summation
of x times y minus the summation of x
times the summation of y
over the number of the summation of x
squared minus the summation of x
squared of x all of it squared that can
be a little confusing trying to say
that and then of course your c value is
going to be the summation of y
times the summation of x squared minus
the summation of
x times the summation of x times y over
the total count
of the summation x squared minus the
summation of x
squared that's a mouthful normally we
don't worry too much about these
formulas other than to know they're
there
now if you're a mathematician you might
go back in there and work on those
and those people who originally started
to put together the different models in
r
of course had to know all this math to
build them and had to test it out
that's one of the nice things about r
what is important is that you know about
these formulas
so that you know where it's coming from
so if you're using one linear regression
model
this is how this one works there's other
linear regression models based on
different math
and so you'd have to be aware when that
math changes and how that changes the
model
we find the corresponding values so in
this case if you're going to break this
up
and you're building your own model
instead of using the one in r
you would have your rent you would have
your area you would find your rent
squared
your area squared and your rent times
area
and if we go back one we can see that
that's all the different
little pieces in this model we have x
times y we have x squared
we have the sum of x which is going to
be squared we have the sum of x the sum
of y
this is the same these are all the
little pieces in here that we see for m
equals and c equals and so once we
compute all these we have 15
25 55 145 88 very easy to do on a
computer thankfully
you could have millions of these points
and it would do it in a very short
period
we can then plug in those values very
easily into this formula
and get a final answer and we'll see
that m equals 1.3
and c equals 1.1 and then when we take
this
for the y predicted equals m of i x of i
plus c
we can take these and actually run the
data we have
so we're going to see how it predicts so
now we find the y
the value of y predicted so we have our
x in and we want to know what y what we
think y will be based on our formula we
generated the linear regression formula
and so we come in here we have our x we
have our actual
y then we have our y predict what we
think it's going to be
and then we have we take y minus y
predict
and we get those values minus 0.4
it's off by 0.3 this one's off by one
this one's on
off by minus 1.3 by 0.4 and we go ahead
and square that
and then we can sum that square and
average it out
and we'll get a value this is just a
summation down here of y minus y
predicted square is 3.1
and we call that the least square value
for this line is
3.1 and we go ahead and divide that by
five so when we plot the y
predict and this is the best fit line
and you can see that it does a pretty
good job
going right through the middle of lines
and in something like
rent versus area if you're trying to
figure out how much rent to charge
or how many people are allowed to be in
the area that's going to work but if
you're looking for the rent value
compared to the area this gives you a
good idea based on the area of what you
should rent the place for
it's close enough that in the business
world this would work
you're not computing something down to
the millimeters or micrometers
or nuclear physics we're just charging
people and so if you're off by a couple
dollars it's not a big deal
you'll be pretty close to what you think
it's worth and get the right value for
your property
use case predicting the revenue using
linear regression
now that you have a good idea of how
linear regression works and we're
kicking back on our lounging sofa today
let's work on a real life scenario where
you have to predict the revenue
so we're going to take a data set and
we'll pull this up in just a minute
we'll have
paid organic social and revenue there
are three attributes we'll be working on
the first one is our paid traffic so all
the traffic through the advertisement
that comes in
the non-paid traffic from search engines
so these are people coming to the
website and are doing so because they
did a search for something specific so
it's pulling it from your website
all the traffic coming from social
networking sites so we want to know
what's coming from twitter and facebook
and somehow they've linked into your
website and coming into
your marketing area to buy something and
we'll use this to predict the revenue so
we want to know how all this traffic
comes together and how it's going to
affect
our cells if the traffic's coming in
we're going to make use of the
multiple linear regression model so
you'll see that this is very similar
that we had before where we had y equals
m times x plus c but instead we have y
equals m1 x1 plus m2 x2 plus
m3 x3 plus c m is the slope
so you have m1 m2 m3 the three different
slopes of three different lines
y is the revenue so we're only looking
for one variable and remember this is
regression so we're looking for a number
x1 is going to be the paid traffic and
of course m1 the corresponding
slope x2 the organic traffic and x3 the
social traffic we will follow these
steps to create the regression model
we'll start by generating inputs using
the csv files
we'll then import the libraries
splitting the data into train and test
very important whenever you're doing any
kind of data science
applying regression on paid traffic
organic traffic social traffic so we're
going to apply a regression model on
them and then we're going to validate
the model that's the whole reason we
split it to a training and testing so we
can now validate to see just how good
our model is
now before we open up r i always like to
just take a quick
look at the data itself and we're using
the rev.csv
file and this is a dot cs file or comma
separated variable file
we'll just open that with wordpad any
kind of text editor would be nice to
show you what's going on
and you can see we have paid organic
social and revenue across the top says
your titles for your
columns and the values going down and
this is the same as what we saw on the
slide just a minute ago
paid organic social and then revenue
from them they probably have it in more
of a
spreadsheet than just a word pad and i'm
using the newer version of our studio
which already has a nice
layout automatically opens up with your
console terminal window down and left
you have your script and we'll run it in
script and then when i run it line by
line in script you'll see it show up on
the console bottom left
i could type it straight into the
console and it would do the same thing
and then on the right we have our
environment and under the environment
we'll see
plots if you're in an older version the
plots will pop up
and you usually are running just in the
console and then you have to open up a
different window to run the script and
you can run the script from there
this opens up everything at the same
time when you use the new rstudio setup
and the first thing we want to do is we
want to go ahead and generate a variable
we'll call it
cells and we want to load this with our
data set
and so in r we use the less than minus
sign that's the same as assigned to it's
like an arrow pointing at cells it says
whatever it goes past here is going to
be assigned to cells
and we want to read in our csv file
and then i went ahead and fixed the csv
file up a little bit
when i say the csv file i mean the path
to it
and we'll go ahead and just paste that
in there and this is my edited version
and you'll see i took wherever we had
the backward slash i switched it for a
forward slash
because a backward slash is an escape
character and whenever you're
programming in just about any scripting
language you want to do the forward
slash
instead so like a good chef i prepped
this
and copied it into my clipboard and we
can see the full path here
and the full path ends in our rev.csv
files that's the path on my machine and
then i'm going to run that
and now we have down here you see it
appear right here oh must have an error
in my path it says
object rev not found let me fix that
real quick
and run it again and this time it does
assign the cells
the data set and then we'll just type in
cells
and this is the same as printing it so
if you work in other languages you'll do
like print
and then cells or maybe print cells dot
head if you're in pandas and python or
something like that but in r you just
type in the variable
we'll run this and you can see it
printed out all those columns so that's
the same thing we just looked at
and it says uh max print so it emitted
750 rows
so it has a total of a thousand rows and
we can scroll up here on our console
where the answer came in
and if i scroll to the top way up to the
top there we go you'll see paid organic
social and revenue so everything looks
good on this
and there's a lot of cool things we can
do with it one of the things we can do
is i can summary it so let's do a
summary of cells
and we'll run that and the summary of
cells comes in it tells you your
min first quarter median mean third
quarter max
for paid organic social breaks it up and
you can actually get kind of a quick
view as to what the data is doing you
can take more time to study this
a lot of people look at this and you can
see from the media and the mean that
tells you a lot
and it's divided into quarters so you
have your first quarter value and your
third quarter
set up on there and max it just gives
you a quick idea what's going on in the
data
summary is a really wonderful tool one
of the reasons i like to jump into
r before i might do a major project in
something else or you can run everything
or not
and let's take a look at the head head
of cells
and let me run this and you can see it
just shows the head of our data the
first
six rows in this case and it starts with
one important to know
other different systems start with zero
and go up r is one that starts with the
first
is one and then if we want to do a plot
i'll go ahead and do a plot cells
another really powerful tool that you
can just jump right into with r once you
have your data in here and you'll see
that the plot
comes over on the right hand side and
what it does is it compares them so if i
look at my
paid and my organic and you cross the
two
you'll see there's a nice line down the
middle big black line where it plots the
two together let me just widen this a
little bit so we can see more of it
there we go same thing with paid and
social
paid and revenue so each one of these
has a clear
connection to each other so that's a
good sign we have a nice correlation
between the data and you can just
eyeball that
that's a good way to jump in and explore
your data rather quickly and see what's
going on
so we'll go ahead and i'll put a pound
sign there
hashtag and uh splitting the data into
training and test data and we want to
split it so that we have something to
work with
to train our data set and when we do our
data set you do this with any data set
because you want to make sure you have a
good model
and then once we've trained it we're
going to take the other set of data we
pulled off to the side and we'll test it
to see how good it is
if you test it with the training data
that's already got that memorized and
should give you a really good answer
in fact when you get into more advanced
machine learning tools
you watch those very closely you watch
your training set
and how it does versus your testing set
and if your training set starts doing
better than your testing set
then you're starting to over train it
now that's more with deep learning
and some other packages that are beyond
what we're working with today but you
know this is important it's very
important to understand that that test
and that training correlate with each
other
gives you an idea what's going on and
make sure that you're set up correctly
and we'll go ahead and set a seed of two
and that's for our random generators
so that when we run them you could see
them with just a red there's a ways to
randomize a number
you could do like date and stuff like
that but that way we always use the same
random numbers
so we'll seat it with two and then we're
going to need a library
in this case we're going to import the
library and we want to import
ca tools and ca tools has
our split function so we're going to be
able to split our data along with many
other tools we're going to need for this
example so they're all built into the ca
tools that's why we need to import that
a lot of times they call them library or
sometimes you can refer to as packages
so let's go ahead and run that line and
that brings the library in so now we can
use all those different tools that are
in there and then i'm going to do a
split
and we're going to assign to the split
that's going to be our variable
sample split okay so that's one of the
tools we just brought in
is to sample as the actual keyword or
the function word sample.split and we're
going to take our cells
and we're going to go ahead and do a
split ratio
equals to 0.7 and let's do 0.7 so we
make sure it knows it's a decimal point
or float and what this is saying is that
we're going to take
our cells data the variable we created
called cells that has the data in there
and i want to split it and i'm going to
split it
so that 70 percent of it goes in one
side we'll use that for training
and 30 will go into the other side which
we'll use then for testing out our
model let me go ahead and run that and
let's hold on one second
got an error there spit is definitely
very different than split
i don't think we want to spit our data
out we which is
actually kind of what we're doing is
spitting it out but we want to split we
want to split the data
let me get that spelled correctly and
then when i type in split
we can just run that because that's now
a variable you'll see that it has true
false false true
so it generates a number of interesting
different statistics going across there
as far as the way it splits the data and
right here if you have not used r in a
while
or if you're new to r completely that
line
one that's what the little one means
down there and then true false
false true that means that's how we're
looking at the data we're splitting all
those different pieces of data in line
one different directions
and so we now want to create our train
set and we're going to assign that
and when we take it and we assign to the
train set a subset
of cells and then the subset of cells
is going to be based on split equal
and put this in brackets true so you can
see the values down here is capital t
capital r capital u capital e so i just
want to reflect that on the train
and this is going to take everything
where our split
variable is equal to true and it's going
to set cells equal to that
and we'll go ahead and run that and then
we're going to set our test variable
as a subset of cells and if we assign
the true to the train set then we want
to assign
the false to our test set
so now we'll have this will have 30 of
the variables in it and train will have
70 percent
we'll go ahead and run that so we've now
created both our training set
and our test set and we can just real
quickly type in train
hit the run on there and you can see our
train set if we scroll way up to the top
i'll have the column names on there
which should match what we had before
paid organic social and revenue and then
we'll type in test
when i hit run on there that's going to
do the same thing it'll spread out all
the
test variables going out so now that we
have the
test and train variables we want to go
ahead and create the model
and you'll see this in any of the
machine learning tutorials i always
refer to them as models
we're modeling a function of some kind
on the data
to fit the data and then we're going to
put the test data through there to see
how well it does
and so we're going to create the
variable called models and i'm going to
assign that
lm that is our linear regression model
i love how simplified r makes it just lm
linear
regression and then model m i guess it
dates back because
the linear regression model is like one
of the first major models used so they
kept it easy on there
and revenue happens to be the
main variable that we want to track so
if you remember correctly from our
formula y is the revenue
and then we have x is our paid traffic
x2 organic traffic and x3 are social
traffic
so y is what we want to predict in here
and then you'll see this
notation where we have our squiggle and
the period
which means we're going to match up the
revenue lines with the lines of the data
we're putting in here
and then i'll put comma and then our
data equals
train and of course that's the training
data that we created so
when i hit the run remember we did all
the discussion about all those different
functions and formulas to compute our
model
and how that's set up when it comes down
to it we spend all our time setting up
our data
and then we hit the run button on the
single line and our model's been trained
so we now have a trained model here and
we can do a summary of the model
summary is such a wonderful command
because you can do that on r that works
on all kinds of different things on
there oops
and of course it does help if i remember
that my model has a capital n
when i run it and you'll see right here
it tells you a little bit about the
model
use a summary on there comes down here
it has our residuals
this is all the information on there as
far as like the minimum
the median the max has all our
coefficients in there
if you remember correctly from our
formula let's just go ahead and switch
back over to that
we have m1 x1 m2 x2 m3 x3 plus c
well that's right here here's our
intercept and then we have our different
values for each of these so we have our
intercept our paid organic and social
and then it also
shows us error and information on the
error and
uh one of the really nice things about
when you're working with r you can come
down here
and you see um where we have our stars
down here and it says
uh three stars really good two stars
maybe one star probably no correlation
and we can see with all of these it has
three stars on them so
out of three stars we get three stars on
all of these there's no four stars
four stars would mean that you have the
exact same data going in as coming out
and then if we're going to do this we
want to actually run a prediction on
here and that's what we saved our test
data for so let's come down here we'll
do our prediction we'll take this
variable and we'll assign it
predict model remember the predict comes
from when we imported that package the
ca
tools that's all part of the ca tools in
there so we're going to predict we're
going to use the model
and then we're going to use our test
data pretty straightforward quick and
easy
we'll run this and then if we go ahead
and type in the predict
it'll print out what's in that variable
and you'll see down here
the predicted values expects to come out
it's going to say our revenue is and it
goes through and it gives it
both the line number and the actual
revenue value
so that's quick and easy boy we've got a
prediction really fast and this is also
how you would do it if you had
new data coming in after this you could
predict the revenue based on
these other factors so now that we have
a training model which or we train the
data with our training data or we
trained
the model with our training data and
we've done a prediction on our model
with our test data we want to look this
up and we took a quick glance
from our training thing our training
said it trained really well but that's
not the final
word on it the final word is going to be
comparing it so we want to go ahead and
do comparing
predicted versus actual values
what i'm going to do is i'm going to do
a plot and i'm going to do our test
and we're going to do test revenue dot
type equals and we can put this in as a
type type one and or l and then we have
lty equals 1.8
and we're going to set up for column
blue that's a lot of stuff in there
let's go ahead and just run that so you
can see what that looks like and what's
that it's doing it's going to generate
this nice graph we see on the right
there's our graph you can see the data
comes up and down
um we're plotting the prediction on
there so this is the values we predicted
and then let's go ahead and do lines and
i actually did this backwards so let me
try that again
and we'll start with the red one we're
going to do the first one in red
and i want to start with the actual test
revenue
so here's our test revenue and we'll go
ahead and run this
and so we have our red plot over here in
red go ahead and take a look at that
pull that over you can see how that
looks goes up and down hard to track
there
and then we're going to do a couple
things here we'll plot our
test revenue and then we'll make it a
little prettier it's kind of hard to say
see the way i have is crunched up here
on the right as far as size and sizing
and everything but we'll go ahead and
have our
columns in blue and run our prediction
on there too
you see they overlap the two graphs so
we have our test revenue
and our prediction and then finally what
i started with is we'll go ahead
and plot the prediction fully on the
bottom and run that
and if you look over here on the graph
we put the blue lines over the red lines
and so you'll see a couple spots where
there's red underneath there but for the
most part our prediction is pretty right
on so it looks
really tight looks like a good set of
predictions for what we're working on
and this is what we were looking at the
slide right before we started diving
into the r studio we can see in the
slide here here's the red that's a
little bit better spread out than
what i have on my screen for my r studio
and the graph shows a predicted revenue
we see that the two lines are very close
so again they're tight it's right on
this is what we're looking for
in our prediction model but it's not
good enough just having a graph
and you always do both and the reason we
do both is you want to have a visual of
it because sometimes you look at these
you get to the graph you're like oh my
gosh what is that
and then sometimes you look at the graph
you go that's right on how come my
accuracy doesn't look right and you
realize that your accuracy
might be off or you're plotting it
incorrectly so let's go ahead and look
up the accuracy
and we'll use rmse that's going to be
the variable name we're going to give it
and sqrt the square root
of the mean and mean just means average
and then we want
prediction minus cells
revenue and then we're going to take
this whole thing and we're going to
square it so what we've got here is
we're going to go through
let's just explain this formula we're
using is i'm going to look at the what i
predicted for to be
and what the actual sales what's our
prediction versus our sales
comparison to the revenue and when we
compare those two we're going to find
the average
and then i'm going or we're going to
square each one of those values
and then we're going to average the
square and then find the square root of
that
and that's quite a mouthful the reason
we do it this way the reason we square
the value and then we find the means
is to generate an answer based on
doesn't matter whether it's plus or
minus
there's a lot of other formulas you can
use there to check your accuracy and all
kinds of other things you can do
but a quick straightforward way of doing
it is just like this and then let's go
ahead and run this
and then we type in the rmse and they'll
give us an actual printed value out
let's just see what that looks like and
so we have 866.6338 for our accuracy
and so we look at the 866.63 and we
compare that to say 50 000 that's pretty
close that's that's actually pretty good
accuracy given this model
takes a little bit more when you're
playing with accuracies and start
dividing out other different
aspects of it to get something you can
communicate better with but you always
start with the square root means that's
always a good place to start
use case we'll start with linear
regression and then we'll jump in and
also do
a decision tree so you can see how they
are same and how they differ in the way
they function and what they're used for
and while we're going through the use
case you can start linking
the theory behind it connected to the
actual
use and as you connect those dots you
can see that by making changes
in the model based on the theory you can
also fine-tune it
we'll talk about that briefly as we go
through this for this analysis we'll use
the default cars
data set to find the correlation between
variables
cars is a standard built-in data set
that makes it convenient to show linear
regression in a simple and easy to
understand fashion and we'll start with
head cars and stream cars now i've gone
ahead and removed the script on here to
make this easier to see
and we don't have to do any kind of
importing of data because it's already
in there
i'm just going to type in head and cars
and hit enter and what you're going to
notice is it's going to display
the first six rows one two three four
five six
and you'll see speed and distance now
this is a little bit like a spreadsheet
so if you're using an excel spreadsheet
it should look the same and this is a
standard data frame kind of setup
in this case whenever you say head it
usually lists the first number of
rows depending on your package in r it
starts with one
and then it does the first six rows
string when we do a string of cars
it's going to break it down and show us
that it's a data frame it has
50 objects that's with the 50 obs of two
variables
and then we have speed the first
variable is going to be a number is what
any um stands for
four four seven seven it just starts
listing the data there and distance now
i'm assuming the speed is the speed of
the engine
otherwise if it's the speed of the car
then the distance should always be the
same and that would need to be kind of
silly
uh but this is the speed of the engine
and based on the speed of the engine
can we correlate that to the distance
let us visualize the data using
scatterplot to understand the
relationship between predictor and
response
and i want you to notice that in this
slide a line has been drawn through the
data now when we first start with data
you don't have that line
so as we plot it i want you to kind of
visualize that line there and just kind
of say hey
does this stuff kind of scatter around a
line or not before we actually create
the model
and we simply do plot and i'm going to
do a shorthand here
cars and i hit enter and it comes over
here to the right and plots our data for
us now because there's only two
variables
i don't have to do anything special i'm
going to expand this over environment so
we can see it and you can see you can
just
visualize a line right through the data
and it's all clumped along that line
which makes it really nice for doing a
linear regression model
now i did something a little tricky here
because i'm very lazy
i typed in plot cars a lot of times you
don't want to do that because you don't
want to plot
all the data we could do plot in this
case cars
dollar sign speed the first variable
cars
dollar sign distance when i do that i
get the same plot
all i'm doing is telling it to use just
these two columns of data
and although the first one is quick and
easy if you only have two columns of
data the second one is what you really
want to do when you're plotting data
like this
you want to control which columns you're
using and then we want to do a
correlation
correlation analysis studies the
strength of relationship between two
continuous variables it involves
computing the correlation coefficient
between the two variables
if one variable consistently increases
with increasing value of the other then
they have a strong positive correlation
a value close
to one and again i can just type in
correlation
cars the short form and we can see we
have a nice correlation going on there
between the two
what we really want to do though is we
want to do we want to correlate
cars and then we're going to do the
speed
comma cars and the distance and so when
you look at this actually hit the enter
key in the middle of that which is fine
you can in r do it line by line so if
you're trying to do a bunch of different
columns you might want to do that to
make it easier to read and you can see
here i get the 0.806894
the closer this is to one the more these
correlate so i'm saying there's a pretty
good correlation
positive correlation between the two
variables and if you look at it when i
did just
cars which did the correlation over all
the variables you'll see that speed
correlates with speed 100 because
they're the same
that's just the nature of that but when
you look at speed versus distance we get
the point
806 849 and if you do distance to
distance you get
also one since they're identical
variables so now it's time to build our
linear regression model on the entire
data set
to build the coefficients let's just
take a look and see what that looks like
back in our console i'm going to type in
linear
mod and in r we want to do
the arrow kind of like an arrow and a
line or in this case the
less than minus sign that's the same as
assigning whatever we're going to put
after it to this variable so we're
creating the linear variable
lm stands for linear module and we're
going to look at speed
and distance so we put the little
squiggly bracket between them
this lets r know we're going to deal
with these two columns
comma data equals cars and when i hit
enter on here
we've generated our linear mod now we
want to go ahead and summarize it
and we simply do a summary and then
brackets
linear mod and it generates all kinds of
information on our model so we can
explore just how well this model is
fitting the data we have right now now
if you've done linear regression in
other packages and scripts
you're going to see that this is so easy
to explore data in r
so even somebody who's working in say
python
or spark hadoop coming back to the r
console to do some basic exploration of
the data is very beneficial uh and if
you use just r goes into all kinds of
different packages
and you can even do cluster computations
through h2or
there's a lot of cool things this is
what makes r so wonderful is how easily
we can summarize
uh something like a linear model and to
explore this data let's go back to the
slide
and we'll see here where it says the
residuals the first one q stands for
first quadrant
median third quadrant max coefficients
and we first want to do is uh look at
the estimate
standard deviation on here and you'll
see the intercept is at minus 17.5791
and speed 3.9324 so we can compute the
distance equals to the intercept
plus the beta times the speed which just
means that we can assign a distance
equal to
minus 17.579 plus the 3.932
times the speed the value of p should be
less than 0.05 for the model to be
statistically significant
and this is one of the things i love
about r you can see right down here
we punched in the numbers and it even
tells you the significant codes
so if you're trying to guess or remember
it tells you right away
uh hey this 1.49 to the minus 12
is way below 0.001 on there and even
puts 3 stars next to it so you can see
that that is a very high correlation
and you can see the 0.0123 gets 1 star
because it is greater than the 0.05 or
it's less than the 0.05
so this shows that there's a very high
correlation statistically is very
significant
so now we're going to go ahead and
create a training and a test
data set and the first thing we want to
do is we want to set the seed so the
sample can be recreated for future
use remember in all these different
regression models they usually have some
randomization going on in the back
to kind of fit it and guess where it's
going to go and if you want everything
to match you want to start with the same
seed in that randomizer that way it
recreates it identical
every time you run it on a different
computer and
just like working with data in any
package we're going to create
indexes for the training data and we're
going to model the training data
and then we're also going to do the test
data and build our model on the training
data
let's walk through that and see what
that looks like in r and
i've actually mistyped that one let's
type in set dot seed
to set our seat for the 100 let's go
training row index and that's our name
we're making up
for our variable and we're going to set
that to
sample now sample is a command in
r so we're going to take a random sample
of some of the data
and then we're going to do one colon
in rows cars so this is the number of
rows and cars and we're going to start
with one
and sample them so row one of the data
we're skipping any of the titles on the
top
and then in the sample there's two
variables that go in the first one is
the in rows of cars
and then we want to do 0.8
times in rows of cars this basically
says that we're going to take 80 percent
of all the rows in the car sample we'll
hit enter to go ahead and run that
and we see here that i had an error and
that is because
it's in row actually put an s on there
that's something i do a lot on we'll
just fix that real quick
brings up a point that if you use your
up down arrow you can quickly paste
through the last things you typed in and
then you can reuse them so
there we go now i have my training row
index which is basically a list of all
the rows
we're going to use and now that we have
a training row index
we'll go ahead and create our training
data variable and we'll assign that
cars and we'll put that as a training
row index and this is supposed to be
brackets because we're dealing with a
array type format we want to do the
training row index
comma so we just need the index of the
row and
as far as the columns we want all the
columns so here we have our training
data and now we set up a training data
we also need our
test data and with our test data we'll
assign
that also to cars and because we use the
training row index
and we use the sample to create it we
can simply do a minus sign
training index comma so it's identical
to the training
data but the test data is going to be
the ones the rows that were not
included in the random sample of 80 so
it's going to be 20
of the data and of course it's very easy
to do mistakes on here so we'll come
back into this
bring back up the error and then we have
training the training index
training row index there we go very easy
correct errors in
r so now we have our training data
and our test data so we have 80 in
training data
and 20 in test data and let's go ahead
and create our model
we'll call it uh lm mod
and this is identical to what we did
earlier here's our linear model
we're going to have our two different
columns if remember above we had to tell
it which columns we wanted
i'm going to do distance and speed
and then the data we're going to set
equal to
training data so as opposed to doing
all of cars we want to use just the
training data on here
and now that we've created a model off
of the training data
we need to go ahead and run our
prediction off of our test
data we want to see how the test data
which has nothing to do with the model
so far
how well it fits and we'll go ahead and
call it distance
predict there's our assignment so we're
going to assign the value to it
and with r we type in predict
and then we called our model we go and
pull up our model lm
mod and so we're going to use that model
and then we want to put in the
test data here's our test data and so
now we're creating the
distance predict variable and we're
going to put all the information as far
as predicting on our tested data
and we'll run that just hit the enter
key and then
if you remember from before we want to
review the model diagnostic
measures and so we're going to go in
here and do a summary
and you'll see in here we have a couple
different things going on but let's go
ahead and take a summary of this and
just
walk through what this means so summary
and then we called it lm mod and we hit
enter
and it pulls it up and we have a nice
summary of our lm mod
and the first thing we're going to note
is that the data that's right now in our
lm mod
that we're summarizing is our training
data
and let's go back to the slide and
highlight this so the data equals the
training data that's where the lm mod
comes in
residuals we have our minimum our first
quarter medium third quarter and the max
or quadrant a quarter you think i was
doing a business analysis as opposed to
end of the year taxes in first quarter
versus quadrant we look at our
coefficient
we can see where our intercept is and
our speed is and we note over here are
significance codes so they all match up
so a simple correlation between the
actuals and the predicted values can be
used as a form of accuracy measurement
so we take a look at the model we
created and now we need to take
our predictions and just see how
accurate it is on the data that we
didn't use to program the linear
model so let's create a variable called
actuals
underscore predicts and assign it
data frame this is how we create a data
frame as we just assign data.frame
and we'll do a c bind and in our c bind
we're going to take our data we're going
to create a column called actuals
so this is our choice the name actuals
this is going to equal
test data and we're going to use a
dollar sign and
distance and we're running out a little
room there so let me pull this over so
we can see it better there we go
distance
and then we also want to take and
compare that to what we predicted for
the
our other data and we'll call this
column predictance
and that's going to equal our distance
predict remember distance predict is set
to
uh the predicted values of our test data
so what this is is we're saying hey
here's our test data
the actual data and the distance and
then we have what we predicted that
distance
to be and we'll go ahead and assign that
and we can do a quick head
actuals predicts there we go and
remember head shows us it's a data frame
so it's going to show us the labels and
the first
set of data in this case you'll notice
that the rows have a different count
they're not one two three four five
six well we randomly picked twenty
percent of the data so this is the first
six rows of that random selection which
comes out as one four eight twenty
twenty six thirty one and we have the
actual so the actual
value is two and the predicted value in
this first one is minus five
so they're way off uh 22 7 26 20 26 37
54 to 42 50 to 50. so one of these is
actually
pretty right on where a lot of them are
really off at the beginning let's just
see what that looks like though because
just eyeballing the first six rows does
not tell us what's really going on
so let's create another variable
correlation accuracy
and we're going to assign this
correlation cor remember we do a cor
and we have our actual predictions so
let's just see how our actual values
versus the prediction correlate with
each other
and we assign that one actuals
underscore
predicts there we go let it auto finish
for me and we can just go ahead and type
in correlation
accuracy and see what that looks like so
we have an actual
one a predicts 0.8 and you can see how
they kind of correlate we have the 0.82
and if you remember from before we're
looking for
either 0.001 0.01 0.05
0.1 that is the p-value which we're not
looking at here
this is not based on the p-value this is
based on we looked at earlier with
correlation that the closer to 1
the closer the values are and so 0.82
gets upwards of one so you see that
there's a normal
pretty much a correlation in here but we
want to dig a little deeper because this
doesn't really tell us
how accurate it is for that we're going
to use another tool
for that we're going to calculate the
min max
accuracy and mape and the min max
accuracy equals the mean
value of the minimal actuals and
predicts
over the max value of the actuals and
predicts and then the mean
absolute percentage error or map as it's
called
equals the mean of the absolutes
predicteds minus actuals
over the actuals that's a lot to follow
as far as
remembering all these different math and
theory behind it cool thing though is
it's all done pretty much for you
so you can compute all the error
matrixes in one go using the
regress eval function in dmwr
package since this is the first time
i've used
this install i'm going to have to
install the dmwr package
so we can actually install it two
different ways if you remember
we talked about installing package
earlier we can go under tools
and install packages and i certainly
could type in
dmwr it even comes up and lets me know
that's one of the main packages
up there well that's a tool of the
rstudio setup
you can also install this using the
console we simply type in
install dot you can even see here it
comes up install packages
and then dm wr and when i hit enter i
should do the same thing as the other
one does
it goes through and installs the dmwr
package
it takes just a moment to zip through
all the different package setup
and then the format for dmwr is dmwr
we're going to go colon colon we're
specifically looking at the
regression.eval
and then we're going to do actuals
underscore predicts
and we'll go ahead and put in the
individual columns on this one
so we have actuals i love the auto
typing
and then again actuals predicts and this
time we want to do it against the
predicteds
i'll go ahead and hit enter on here and
you'll see in here it comes up with our
mae mse rmse and the mape
values today we're going to cover
logistic regression in the r
programming language logistic regression
is kind of a misnomer in that when most
people think of regression
they think of linear regression which is
a machine learning algorithm for
continuous variables
however logistic regression is a
classification algorithm
not a continuous variable prediction
algorithm
logistic regression is also sometimes
called logic
regression in this video we are going to
learn why we would use regression
as a predictive algorithm what is
regression the different types of
regression
as i've already mentioned some
regression algorithms are classification
algorithms
and some are continuous variable
algorithms
why use logistic regression what is
logistic regression
and then we'll look at a use case a
college admission
uh using logistic regression so why
would we use
regression well let's say we had a
website and our revenue
was based on the traffic that we could
drive to that website
whether through r d or marketing and we
wanted to predict the revenue based on
site traffic and the website traffic
would be related to the revenue
we could generate the more traffic
driven to our website then the higher
our revenue or at least that's what we
would intuitively assume
and so we need to predict the revenue
based on our website traffic
here we have the plot of revenue versus
website traffic
traffic would be considered the
independent variable and revenue would
be
the dependent variable often the
independent variable or variables
if we had more than one could be called
the explanatory variables
and the dependent variable would be
called the response variable however
we typically refer to them as
independent and dependent variables
so our intuition tells us that the
independent variable
drives the dependent variable and if
there is some relationship between the
two variables and we would say that
there is a correlation between the two
variables
and then we may be able to use the
independent variable
to make predictions about the dependent
variable if you look at the chart on the
right you'll see there is a clear trend
between website traffic and revenue as
website traffic
increases the revenue increases and we
could draw a line to show that
relationship
and then we could use that line as a
predictor line so for example what will
revenue be
if our traffic is 4.5 k
we see that when the traffic is around 4
500 the revenue
is around 13 000 and if we could draw a
perpendicular line
from 4.5 k on the axis on the x-axis the
traffic
axis up to the orange regression line
sometimes called the line of best fit
then we could draw another line over to
the y-axis
the revenue axis and we could see where
it lands and that would be the
prediction
so in this example when the traffic is
around 45
000 hits the predicted revenue is around
13
000. normally we wouldn't actually draw
those lines we would generate an
equation and we would call that equation
a model
and we could plug the independent
variable into the equation
to generate the dependent variable
output which we would call our
prediction
so what is regression regression is a
statistical relationship between
two or more variables where a change in
the independent variable
is associated with a change in the
dependent variable
it's important to note that all
variables are related to each other
for example a person's favorite color
may not be related to
revenue from a website here the change
in one variable
height is closely associated with the
change in the other variable
age this makes intuitive sense as you
get older
from when you're born you get taller and
it seems to make sense if we plot that
data we would see those green points on
the graph
up to some certain age where growth
would taper off in the plot in the
middle
of the screen we see the clear linear
relationship between
age and height which is indicated by the
solid red line
we sometimes call that line a trend line
or a regression line
or the line of best fit and we see that
the height
is the dependent variable and age is the
independent variable
of course you might ask doesn't height
depend on other factors
of course it does but here we're looking
at the relationship between two
variables
one independent and one dependent age
and height there are various types of
regression linear regression
logistic regression multiple linear
regression polynomial regression
and there are others decision tree
regression random forest regression
but linear regression is probably the
most well known
and by definition when there is a linear
relationship between a dependent
variable
which is continuous and an independent
variable which is continuous or discrete
we would use
linear regression when the y value in
the graph is categorical
such as yes or no true or false they
voted
they did not vote they purchased
something they did not purchase
something
it depends on the x variable
logistic regression is when the y value
in the graph is categorical in nature
for example yes no purchased don't
purchase
voted did not vote and it depends on the
x variable notice the trend line
for linear regression and the line for
logistic regression
they're different more on that later and
there's polynomial regression as well
when the relation between the dependent
variable y
and the independent variable x is in the
nth degree of x
sometimes we say an nth degree
polynomial of x
in this picture you can see that the
relationship is not
linear there's a curve to that best fit
trend line
so why would we use logistic regression
and
we need to understand why we would use
logistic regression and that linear
regression
picking the machine learning algorithm
for
your problem is no small task
and it really behooves us to understand
the difference between
these machine learning algorithms linear
regression
answers the question how much so in our
earlier example if website traffic grows
then how much would revenue grow whereas
logistic regression
would answer what will happen or not
happen
linear regression in general is used to
predict a continuous variable
like height and weight logistic
regression is used when a response
variable only has
two outcomes yes or no two or false
often we refer to logistic regression as
a binary classifier
since there are only two outcomes so
let's try to understand this with an
example
let's say we have a startup company and
we are trying to figure out whether the
startup will be profitable or not that's
binary with two possible outcomes
profitable or not profitable
and let's use initial funding to be the
independent variable
here we have a graph that shows funding
versus profit and it appears linear
once again our intuition tells us the
more funding a startup has
the more profitable it will be but of
course data science doesn't depend on
intuition it depends on data
but this graph does not tell whether the
startup will be profitable
yes or no it only states that with an
increase in funding
the profit also increases that's not
binary if we wanted to predict how much
profit then linear regression would be
useful but that's not what we are being
asked
hence we need to make use of logistic
regression which has
two outcomes in our case profitable and
not profitable
so let's draw a graph again the x-axis
will be our independent variable
funding and the y-axis will no longer be
the dependent variable
profit but it will be the probability of
profit for example if you look at a
company with a funding of say
40 then the probability that that
company will be profitable
is around point eight or eighty percent
based on the best fit line called a
sigmoid curve
in the example we plotted several
companies
some with 10 15 20 some with 50
60 or 70 or 65 and we indicated whether
they were zero
not profitable or a one profitable on
the graph and this is how we should
think of logistic regression
in this example given the amount of
funding we calculate the probability
that a company will be profitable or not
profitable and if we use the threshold
line of 50
then we have our classifier if the
probability is 50
or higher the company is profitable if
the probability is lower than 50
it's not profitable so what is logistic
regression this is a linear regression
graph
so let's compare linear regression to
logistic regression and take a look at
the trendline that describes the model
it's a straight line which is why we
call it linear regression
but using linear regression we can't
really divide the output into two
distinct categories
yes or no to divide our results into two
categories
we would have to clip the line between
zero and one if you recall
probabilities can only be between zero
and one
and if we're going to use probability on
the y-axis
then we can't have anything that is
below zero or above one
thus we would have to clip the line and
once we clip the line we see that the
resulting curve cannot be represented in
a linear equation so for logistic
regression
we will make use of a sigmoid function
and the sigmoid curve as the line of
best fit
notice that it's not linear but it does
satisfy our requirement of using a
single line
that does not need to be clipped for
linear regression
we would use an equation of a straight
line y equals
b sub 0 plus b sub 1 times x x being the
independent variable
y being the dependent variable but as
we've said we cannot
use a linear equation for binary
predictions
so we need to use the sigmoid function
which is represented by the
equation p equals 1 divided by the
quantity 1 plus
e to the minus y e being the base of the
natural logs
then taking the log of both sides and
solving we get our sigmoid function
and graphing it we get our logistic
regression line of best fit the
applications for logistic regression are
endless
here we might have a couple of gardeners
or farmers and one farmer says
i am planning to grow plants in my
backyard and i want to know whether my
trees will get infested with bugs
which i'm sure is a huge problem and
these days the fewer pesticides we use
the better off we are for health reasons
the young lady says
i can use logistic regression in a model
to predict it for you
and the other farmer says well how is
logistic regression going to help
but we know that healthy versus not
healthy is a binary classification
and we can use a binary classifier like
logistic regression to solve this
problem which is what the young lady
has in mind if we have the data we can
model the data and generate a sigmoid
function that best fits our data
and then use the probability of a
healthy tree versus
a not healthy tree or an infested tree
once again
we see our sigmoid line of best fit
and some points that represent healthy
trees
and not healthy trees once again we plot
our sigmoid
curve scratch that and once again once
our sigmoid curve
is plotted and our threshold is set
almost always at 50 percent
we can use the sigmoid curve
and calculate the probabilities and hear
the independent variable of width which
i assume is an application
of pesticides or no pesticides to
determine
whether or not the probability of
healthy is
greater than 50 percent the threshold or
less than 50 percent the threshold and
now
let's take a use case of a college
admission problem of course we can't
solve anything using data science if we
don't know what the problem is
so we need a problem statement and here
the problem statement is simple we are
given a data set and we need to predict
whether a candidate will
get admission in a desired college or
not based on
their gpa and college rank so the very
first thing we need to do
is import the data set and if it's a
small enough data set
and it can fit into our computer memory
then we are golden otherwise we have
some work to do
the data set that we were given is in
csv
format comma separated values csv files
are easily imported
into our environment once we import the
data
we next need to select and import the
libraries that we will need
although r is a great programming
language with a lot of built-in
functions
it is easily and powerfully extended by
the use of libraries and packages
then we need to split the data set into
a training set and a test set
it's important to note that the data set
that we've imported
that we were given has the gpas and
college ranks
for several students but it also has a
column that indicates whether those
students were admitted or not
so what we're saying is that the data
set has the answers and if you think
about it it must
how could we possibly train a model have
a model
learn if we didn't know the answers
already that's why it's called machine
learning so we train
the model and then we test the model
once we split the data into training and
test sets we will apply
our regression on the two independent
variables
gpa and rank generate the model and then
run the test set through the model
once that is complete we will validate
the model to see how well it performed
so now it's demo time so here we have
our studio
my favorite ide or integrated
development
environment and i have a script already
composed
to run our logistic regression on the
problem at hand
which is our college admissions problem
so let's just walk down the script
before i run it
and talk about the various points in the
script
so first define the problem well the
problem was defined and
you really can't do anything in data
science without a clear
problem definition once the problem is
defined you can load your libraries
acquire your data set the working
directory in my case i'm on windows
explore the data munch the data if
necessary and then prepare the data
scale the data if necessary split the
data into train and test data sets
then train the model using the training
data and run the test data through the
model
and then validate the model for accuracy
and precision etc so here we are going
to
load our libraries i'm going to use a
package called ca tools
and now that the library is loaded
i'm going to set my working directory
and if i come over here to the files
tab you'll see that there is my working
directory
in that working directory there's a file
called binary.csv
and that's the csv the comma separated
value file that the college gave me
i'm going to ingest and then look at
that data and as you can see
it has four columns gre gpa rank and
then the answer column
admit whether or not someone was
admitted which would be a one
or not admitted which would be a zero
and if we come over to the right and we
can look and see
some of the first few values of each of
those four columns
now let's split the data we're going to
take this my data frame
and split it into two a training set and
a test set
and the ratio we're going to use is 80
20. so 80
of the data will go into the training
set and 20
will go into the test set now that ratio
could be 60 40
it could be 70 30. typically it really
depends on
the size of your data how much data you
have but this is
for our example and for our purposes 80
20 is perfect
next we'll do a little data munching in
general you munge the data early on
after ingestion and you really have to
be careful in this case we don't have
any missing values
we don't have any real outliers our data
was pretty clean
when we got it and ingested it but in
general that's not the case
and a lot of work and a lot of attention
needs to be
paid to the munging process here we're
just going to
take our data the admission column
and the rank column and convert them to
categorical
variables right now they're integers as
you can see
on the right hand side and once i run
these two lines
they will be converted to factors and
all the fun stuff
we're going to use the glm function the
general linear model function
to train our logistic regression
model and the dependent variable is
admit
and the independent variables are gpa
and rank and the little tilde sign here
says
the dependent variable will be a
function of gpa
and rank the two independent variables
the data will be the training set
and the family will be binomial and
binomial indicates
that it's a binary classifier it's a
logistic regression problem
there it is we ran our model and there's
a summary of our model
you can see that there is some
statistical significance
in gpa and in rank by the coefficients
and output of the model so next let's
run the test
data through the model
and once we have done all that we can
now
set up a confusion matrix and look at
our predictions
versus the actual values again this is
important we had the answers and now we
took and we predicted some answers
so hopefully our predicted answers match
up with the actual answers we'll run a
confusion matrix
as you can see the predicted values
versus the actual values and it's
important here to note that if it was
predicted false and it was actually
false and we see 189 or if it was
predicted true and it was actually true
which is 27
we did well on those but there are few
that were predicted incorrectly some
were predicted true but were actually
false
some were predicted false that were
actually true and now
we'll confirm what our percentage
accuracy is
72 not bad but we could probably do
better
how we'll leave that to another video
we'll be doing part one of a two-part
series
decision tree followed by random forest
because decision tree is part of the
random forest
what's in it for you first we'll cover
what is a decision tree what problems
can be solved using decision trees
how does a decision tree work and then
we'll dive into a use case
survival prediction in r so we'll be
using the r platform on this one
so what is a decision tree and here we
have kind of a new looking front
panel of a car driving down the street
and we have uh left or right so you're
coming to an intersection you gotta
decide which way to go you're gonna go
left or you're gonna go right
wait or go so do you go right away we
have a green light
so probably want to go right away after
you check for cross traffic make sure no
one
is asleep at the wheel or talking on
their cell phone decision tree
is a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision occurrence
or reaction so another example is we
have a
shopkeeper very nondescript shopkeeper
kind of a little spooky without the eyes
so we have a shopkeeper and
he wants to organize his stall so i must
organize my stall just looking around
trying to figure out what the best way
to stack all his goods are
and he has some broccoli some oranges
and some carrots
this is kind of a nice example because
we can see where some of the colors and
shapes overlap
where others don't and so you can create
a tree out of this very easily and say
is it colored orange if it's not well it
goes into one stack well that happens to
be all their broccoli and if it is
colored orange then it goes into another
stack and you're like well that's still
kind of chaotic
you know people are looking at carrots
and oranges a very strange combination
to put in a box
so the next question might be is it
round and if it is then yes you put the
oranges into one box and
no that means it's carrots we put in the
other box and you can see that a lot of
stuff we do
in life easily can fall into like a
decision tree how do you decide
something you know does it go left does
it go right
yes or no and even with this we even
have a number of different
end choices broccoli carrots and oranges
so what kind of problems does this solve
what problems can be solved
by using a decision tree classification
we're dealing with a classification
identifying to which set an object
belongs
and from our example we just looked at a
carrot is orange while broccoli is green
i guess it's nondescript day without the
faces i love it because a lot of times
you're looking at data you really don't
want to know what
exactly the data is but you're sorting
it so you know like this
kind of represents data that you really
don't know exactly where it's coming
from
just kind of a fun thing regression
regression is another
problem the biggest can be solved
regression problems have continuous or
numerical valued
output variables example predicting the
profits of a company
so we have two different primary
problems we solve for we solve for
classification
is it green or is it orange and we solve
for regression
which is a continual number so you know
if you're doing stocks this would be a
dollar value
that ranges anywhere from zero to
thousands of dollars
how does a decision tree work terms you
must know first
so before we dive into the decision tree
let's look at some of the terminology
for the decision tree we have notes each
internal node in a decision tree is a
test which splits the objects into
different categories
and continuing with our vegetable stand
example
we have broccoli no it's not orange and
oranges and carrots are and so on so you
can see right there where it splits
that's a note where the orange is split
and the carrot split into each of their
own groups
and each one of the splits is a node the
very top node of the decision tree is
called the root node
so the very first one we started off
where we split it is a colored orange
and you can see that pointed out nice
and neatly there this is a root note at
the top
each external node in a decision tree is
called the leaf
node the leaf node is the output and you
can see down here we have our broccoli
and we have our carrots and our oranges
each one of those is a leaf node
so to quickly rehash our terms we have
anywhere there is a split
that's a node and if it's at the very
top of the tree that's the root node
and if you're at the very bottom of the
tree where you have a final answer that
is the leaf node so you have a root node
a leaf node
and then everything else is just a
generic node so one of the most
important terms or concepts
that powers a decision tree is entropy
entropy is a measure of the messiness of
your data collection the messier or more
random your data
higher will be the entropy so we can see
here we have broccoli oranges and
carrots are all mixed together and it's
very chaotic
and you could say this collection has
high entropy and if we
sort out the carrots out of here in i
guess just one of the broccoli
i don't know where the other broccoli
went you could say if you have just the
oranges
and the broccoli this is a lower entropy
they say this collection has low entropy
but really it's higher and lower
one is higher or lower than the other
one and from entropy
we get information gain information
is the decrease obtained in entropy by
splitting the data set
u based on some conditioning so we have
our
information 1 which we can actually
there's actual computations
and so we have our e1 which is put in
there for our
entropy value at the base note or root
note
and we have 2 a2 which is a leaf node
and so we can actually calculate those
calculations for entropy
and we actually look at those two values
the entropy and we take that we have e1
is greater than e2
therefore the information gain equals e1
minus e2 so here we have another example
and we're actually going to attach some
values to this one in just a moment so
we're going to move away from the fruit
and we're going to go to
everybody's favorite thing organizing a
child's closet
and here we have a young lady waving at
us hi my cupboard is a mess
i must organize my stuff and we're going
to classify the objects based on their
attribute set
using a decision tree we can look at it
we have a shape
a size and a label and a number
and i'm going to go ahead and look at
the labels because that's really what's
key on this one
is we have a couple balls in here some
books
cards and blocks and if you look at that
when you have
something that's a ball it's round so
it's a very different shape the book
card and blocks are all rectangular but
the books are a different size so the
books have like a size six
i guess they think of them as very large
cards a size four so they're not quite
as big
and the blocks are little lego blocks it
looks like kind of fun to stack on there
and then we can actually quantify this
and we can actually say hey we got
we have different numbers we have two
balls two books
one card four blocks and we split at
each level based on certain conditions
on the attributes
so splitting aims at reducing the
entropy
and we have a formula our first actual
formula that you'll see
happens in the background when we're
running these different modules in r
it looks a little complicated but we can
break that up and simplify that for you
so we see this formula the negative sum
of i of x
equals the probability of 1
value of x times the log of 2
probability
value of x the term probability value of
x
it's probably easiest to understand if
we go ahead and put the numbers in there
so you can actually see what we're
looking at
and so we plug the numbers in there we
look at the probability
of the value of x well if we do the
number of
balls there's two balls and the total
number of items is nine
so we have a probability of any one
object being
two out of nine so that's pretty
straightforward math when you look at
the numbers you can actually see that
very easily and so we can
calculate our entropy of two over nine
times the
squared log of two over nine plus one
ninth the log squared of one over nine
plus
four over nine times the log squared of
four over nine
so our whole group is the sum of all the
entropies
and so when we look at that we have the
entropy of the balls which is the two
over nine
rectangles two over nine our mean books
two over nine
cards one over nine and the blocks four
over nine and we just plug those numbers
in there and we get an actual
a value of 1.8282 so
what the heck does a module do with that
number well now we must find the
conditions for our split
every split must give us the maximum
achievable
information gain and so we have our
first entropy value 1.8282
and it turns out when you compare all
the different individual entropy values
for the balls for the books for the
cards for the blocks
rectangles you find out that the biggest
split is going to be in the shape
and it's going to be our first split
will be on the shape that will directly
segregate the balls out so they'll split
up a huge group
from one from the other and so we
compute that we end up
with e2 which is all of our rectangles
and then we have a leaf node which is
the balls and so with our e2 we see that
1.3784 is much less than the 1.8282
and so our second split will be on the
size as that will directly segregate the
books
and so we do that we can see that if the
size is greater than five
all the books go to one side while the
cards and the blocks go to the other
and again we have our e3 which equals
0.716
which is considerably less than 1.3784
so our entropy
is dropping each time we do a split and
of course our third split we look at
and we'll see that we're left with size
again and
we'd split it with four and two in this
case if it's greater than three
it's going to be a block if it's less
than three it's going to be a
card and at this point each of our
objects is
looped into similarities so they all
look the same and we end up with an
entropy of
zero and so you can see as we go down
the entropy continues to get less
and because it hits zero we can say all
our objects are now classified with a
hundred percent
accuracy if it was only that easy to
clean the kids closets
and you can see we have a nice drawing
that shows you where all the leaf nodes
are on this in which case we have the
balls
the books the blocks and the cards are
part of the leaf note and the root node
is our first split and we have all the
object and we're splitting them by
rectangle by shape
so we're going to dive into the use case
and in this case we're going to get a
little morbid there i am behind my desk
that's
definitely not me i don't have that big
of a chin but
i do usually have a cup of coffee and it
looks kind of like that it's sitting
next to me on my desk
so the use case is going to be survival
prediction in r and let's implement a
classification of data set based on
information gain this is going to use
the id3
algorithm don't let that scare you
that's the most common
algorithm they use to calculate the
decision tree
there's a couple different ways they can
calculate the entropy but the formula is
all the same behind it
so id3 is most common in r and then
we'll be using the rstudio
for our interface for our ide so rstudio
is free to download there's the
free version of course there's an
enterprise version and there's
all kinds of different choices in there
but one of the wonderful things about r
is that it's been an open source for a
very long time
and is very well developed it's also
very quick and easy to use on a lot of
things
so this is going to be in the rstudio
ide there's some other
interfaces but this is i would suggest
using the rstudio it's the most common
one
and if you remember i said this is going
to be a little morbid because we're
talking about how many people
survived and died on these ships so in
this case we have a nice
vacation cruise ship going on there i'm
not sure what that is with the tugboat
so we have a ship and it had 20
lifeboats the lifeboats were distributed
based on the class gender and age of the
passengers
we will develop a model that recognizes
the relationship between these factors
and predicts the survival of a passenger
accordingly so we want to predict
whether the person is going to
survive or die in a shipwreck and we'll
be using a data set which specifies if a
passenger on a ship survived its wreck
or not
so we're going to look at this data and
if you open it up into a
spreadsheet and don't forget you can
always put a note on the youtube video
down below
and we will be monitoring that and you
can request the data set sent to you or
more correspondence you can also go to
www.simplylearn.com
and request this data set too it's just
a simple csv
file we'll send out and you can see
right here we have survived so
one indicates a person survived the
wreck zero they didn't make it
they were under the water and the luxury
class of the cabin
so if they were in you know what what
values like one two three depending on
what luxury class they were
and then we have this is kind of
interesting how many siblings they had
so it's kind of an interesting added
statistic in there number of parents on
board
and disembark location so where the
destination is
so here we've opened up rstudio and if
this is your first time in our studio
you'll notice that it opens up
standardly in three panes
the upper left is for text documents
you're bringing in
and then the bottom left is the actual
uh commands as they're processed
and then on the right hand side you have
your environment set up on there
now i've zoomed in with my font a little
oversized in fact we can even take that
up one more size and see if we can get a
larger
setup view here we go so i've set the
font for 18
probably a lot larger than you need to
work on a project and the first thing
i'm going to do is on the right hand
panel we're going to be working with
plots so i'm going to click on the
little plot tab up there
and i'm just going to collapse that over
to the side for right now and then i'm
going to open up the bottom one
and you'll see on the top i actually
have two different tabs
team in the back was really nice to set
up the whole package for what we're
working on here
and we'll go through this line by line
and then you'll see as we execute the
different lines they're going to appear
down below
so i'll be flipping between these two
left panels
and let me go backwards just for a
second here we're going to do
this part so let's take a look at the
installs
and if you look at the installs and when
i'm not going to actually run the
installs because i've already run them
on my computer so these are already
installed in my r packages and i don't
have to re-run them
we have a number of packages we're
bringing into our because that's how r
functions and the first number of
packages
are all part of our decision tree so our
f selector
our r part our carrot with the
dependencies equal true
and our d p l y r and r part
plot oh that's a mouthful you'll need to
import all of these
in your setup and the first one which is
your f selector
compute your chi squared your
information gain your entropy
all of those formulas are a part of the
f selectors when you bring it in that's
what that package is
the r part is your partitioning of your
decision tree
so these are your primary two decision
tree modules that we're bringing in
the carrot is a part for actually
splitting apart the data
because we always want to do a test set
a train set so they built a package
carrot to kind of handle all those
you'll see carrot used a lot of other
machine learning packages
when you're doing the r the dpl
is for mutating your data so you can sum
it you can classify it you can filter it
that's all part of the dpl yr and then
our part
has another piece called plot and that's
for helping us plot the data
as we sort out the tree because the art
part creates a tree but you still want
to be able to plot it
and then we come down here and we have
some additional tools
we're going to work with a spreadsheet
this is a microsoft access spreadsheet
or we're going to use the xlsx package
to
import it and you might think it's a
little outdated because i know when i'm
doing any new projects i try to save my
data into a comma separated variable
file or something more standardized
but a lot of times you'll end up with
these old databases where they're
exporting data and their export comes in
an excel spreadsheet
and guess what this is a time saver
instead of opening up the spreadsheet
resaving it as a comma separated
variable file
you can just open it right up in r which
is really nice
and then we have our data tree which
goes right along with uh
displaying the data so we have our
rpart.plot and we're going to put that
into the data trees have a nice visual
and finally you need to install the
package ca tools
and ca tools is another package used for
general manipulation of your data and
your vectors
so it also has a split function for
training data i know we have another
package for that but both those packages
fit in there as far as the working with
the data so a lot of times you'll see
these loaded in there together and
you'll see in a moment we'll
import the elementary stat learn package
also which is very generic working with
data setup as far as statistics
and data processing now because
my java setup is a little different
because i use the developer package
well the latest update of the developer
package and the
r are struggling to see each other so i
need to go ahead and add this
in chances are you don't need to worry
about this but if you do get
an r java error you'll need to go ahead
and add an align
to set your environment and i'm just
going to set the java home
i went ahead and looked up the last
solid jre
folder you'll see under program files
java you can look them all up
to make sure it's the jre and not the
jdk the difference between those is one
is a standard executable that's a jre
folder
it is a folder not an actual file and
the jdk
deals more with developer side on things
and i'm going to go ahead and run this
and if you're in r you can run these
lines individually by holding your
control key down and hitting the enter
button
so i've now loaded my workspace and set
my environment here
and we can actually look and just make
sure system dot
get environment is the opposite one and
i can just look real quick and say hey
what's my
java home set to and if i run that
whoops i forgot to put brackets around
it there we go
and if i do that you'll see that it's
set to the
jdk18025
and again we're looking at the split
screen and let me just move this up here
a little bit and let me hit the enter
key a bunch of times it comes up on the
screen
when i run it and i'm running it line by
line the
run text then appears down here and this
is what's actually being executed
so i could just as easily type it in
down here as
putting it up here on the top part
that's just a little bit of r studio and
working with our studio
so i've shown you the installs and again
i've already installed it on my computer
so it takes a minute or two to install
it
we need to go ahead and then bring those
libraries
in to work with so
basically we're going through all the
different libraries we're using
elements.learn
is a standard r library so it should
already be installed you don't have to
install that one
and i can just go right down them and
you'll see as i install them that they
show up on the bottom
and every time you go to run a new setup
you need to go ahead and install these
pull the libraries in you got to tell
your r
studio these are the libraries you're
using
and you can see right down here that as
it executes them
it has all the different things one of
them had like couple different parts to
it so loaded the
lattice and the gg plot to
really nothing to worry too much unless
you see errors down here
so if you start getting error codes then
you might have to go troubleshoot and
find out why it's not installing
correctly or
did it install correctly but it's pretty
straightforward we've covered all the
libraries
and again if you want a copy of this
code simply let
a comment down below on the youtube
video or visit www.simplylearn.com
and they'll be happy to send you a copy
of the base code
the next step is we want to go ahead and
load the excel file
after setting the working directory
so let's go ahead and set the working
directory scwd is a command for that in
r and then this is wherever you have
downloaded your data to and your files
to a lot of times if you get the
zipped framework sent to you it will
unzip all into one location
and then you gotta look that location up
and put that in here a lot of times it
automatically sets that for you if
you're
if you're working in the same directory
in this case you can see i've pasted in
a very lengthy path because i have this
as part of my
documents my business docs and simply
learn and marketing videos and so on
i'll go ahead and do the control enter
and run that so now my working directory
is set
and you can see down below it's executed
this
on the console down here
and if i open up that working directory
you can see i have a ship
xls file that's the data we're going to
look at
and we looked at that on the slide you
could also open this up
and i want to go ahead and open it up
with a
notepad by default it'll open up as a
spreadsheet
oh it is an excel file so i'd have to
open it up as an actual
spreadsheet wasn't thinking that one
through this is one of the problems with
saving stuff as a proprietary ship soft
file even
something as widely used as microsoft
excel spreadsheet but when we open up
the spreadsheet you can see here
the same data we looked at before that's
what's coming up in this file
and so i take this file we can go ahead
and let's um
create a variable we'll call it add
and we're going to assign it
that's what the lesser than dash means
if you've never used r before
and we're just going to assign it a ship
xlsx
and then i'll do my control enter and
you'll see it run down here
ship add is assign ship dot xls
our excel spreadsheet on there and then
let's have a
another variable we'll call it df for
data frame
and we're going to assign this read
xlsx and that's from the library slxxx
that we just
imported and we want to read the file
add
because we just created that variable
with the ship.xls
and i didn't catch this right away but
you'll see when we open it up in a
spreadsheet
it might be hard to see in your video
screen it has a
the first sheet is called ship one so
this data is on
the page ship one in the excel
spreadsheet
and we got to make sure that we tell the
reader to look for that
and so we can simply do that in our
command line
sheet name equals
and it was ship one on there so we go
ahead and hit the control enter and run
this line
and it brings it down below and executes
it it's now reading
in that data from that spreadsheet
that's what's going on and it takes it
just a moment to go ahead and read it in
and then with any data processing
we need to select the meaningful columns
for the prediction
so this is important that we sort
through our data and set it correctly so
that whenever we're feeding it into can
read it correctly
we can do this with df
we're going to reassign it and we're
going to select
and from there we're going to select df
as our main data frame going in
and then list the columns that we want
and if we look at the data we have
survived we have a class we have a name
sex and age and then there's siblings
and parents
we really don't want to know the name
because we don't need the name to run
this on here
and then we got to decide which one of
these we want to work with
and the guys in the back played with the
data a little bit and they came up with
the following columns
survived which we need definitely
because that's what we're actually
trying to figure out is whether we're
going to survive or not
what class they're which which class of
the boat they're writing in whether
first class second class
sex and age we went ahead and dropped
the rest of them
at least for this example and so i can
go ahead and do my control enter and
you'll see it execute down below
and now df equals these three columns or
four columns plus our answer is one of
those so i always think of it as
three columns plus one but it is four
columns
and then for the next step we want to
make sure the data is in the right
format
so again i'm going to resign the df and
we're going to mutate the data
and that means we're going to take each
one of these columns and we're going to
let it know what kind of data that is
so our first one is i'm going to put the
database in or the data frame in there
df and then we want to go ahead and do
survived
equals a factor of survived so this is a
yes no it's letting us know that this is
a
zero or a one on here
and then for the class and the
age those are as numeric
there's other ways to process class
since it is a very restricted number on
there but for this we're just going to
do it as a numeric value
same thing with age and you see we
didn't do anything with sex we're just
going to leave that as male or female
and that's fine for this because it'll
pick up on that when we run the decision
tree
and we'll do our control enter so now
i've assigned the new df and you can see
it comes down below
as we run it on there so this is now
loaded and df now is a mutated
data frame that we started with and
we've set it up with
our specific columns we want to work
with in this case survived class
sex and age and we've formatted three of
those columns
to a new setup so one of them is factor
that's what we use for survive so it
knows it's a zero and one
and then we switch to class and age to
make sure that it knows that those are
numeric values
now that we have our data formatted we
need to go ahead and split the data
into a training and testing data set and
by now if you've done any of our other
machine learning
tutorials you know this is standard you
need to have your
data that we train it with and then you
got to make sure it works on data that
it hasn't trained on
so we'll go ahead and do the splitting
let's take a look and see what that
looks like
and when you're dealing with splitting
the data we're doing a little randomness
so we'll just go ahead and set the seed
to one two three you can set that to
whatever number you want that's just
setting the random variable seed
and we'll go ahead and hit enter on
there and to do this we're going to
create
sample and we're gonna go equals sample
dot
split so we're splitting up the data
this is actually creating a whole new
column
trues and falses it's all stored in
sample
and we want our data frame and we use a
dollar sign
to denote that we're going to be working
with
one of the different columns a nice
thing you can do in
r and it actually shows my survived so
df survived
and then our split ratio
split ratio i want to add a period in
there which it doesn't have
our split ratio is going to be equal to
and we'll do
0.70 so we're going to take 70 of the
data of those that have survived and
we're going to just randomly select
which one of those we're going to use
for training and which one we're going
to use
for testing it out later we'll hit our
enter and load that sample
in there and then we'll go ahead and
create our train and our test
data set so i'm going to set train equal
to and this is where kind of gets
interesting because we're going to do
subset
and then we're going to do a subset of
our df
where sample and then we're going to use
equals since this is a logic gate so
wherever it sets sample equal to true
we're going to use that line in df
and this is of course r so it's all
capitalized for true
so here's our trained data frame we're
creating so when i execute this and it
shows up down below
it goes up and says hey this sample
created a whole bunch of
trues and false and we're going to take
those trues and falses and wherever
we've created a true which is 70
of the data randomly selected that's
what we're going to train the data with
and then we need our test set and that's
a subset just the same thing we just did
and we need our data frame and this is
where the sample equals
false and again when i hit control enter
it goes down this line of code and it
runs it down here in our terminal window
so now we've nicely split our data up we
have our training data set and our test
data set
and this is of course we get to the
point of what we're actually trying to
do
which is create our decision tree and
we're going to do that by training the
decision tree as a classifier
this always gets me you spend all this
work sorting through the data
reformatting it in this case mutating it
and filtering it
and creating a train set and a test set
so we're going to go ahead and create
our tree and we're going to assign to it
the r part that's the module we imported
and for the our part we need to go ahead
and do what's called a survived and this
is kind of a little complicated to look
at so let's just take a quick look at
this i'm going to go backward on it
the first part is we're importing the
data so data equals train
and then we want to know is who survived
so the first part we put in here is the
column we're looking for is survived
and you'll see that we have added the
squiggly mark in the period
because we're looking just for this
prediction we just want to know who
survived from these boats
for programming our decision tree and
i'll go ahead and hit ctrl enter
and we've now created the tree that tree
with all those values is now
in there and if you remember from before
we've taken from when we did the closet
full of clutter
we've done the same thing where we have
our entropy and that one line
computes the entropy and the increase in
information
and it brings entropy down to zero so
it's the same thing but instead of
applying it here as we did visually to
the closet it's now applied it to the
data on the ship
it's now looked at the survival of zero
or one
based on female male what age they are
where the best split of the age is
and what class they were in you can see
we have first class
if we go down there i think there's a
third
yeah third second so i guess it's class
one two and three
but you can see that's how i split it up
says use these different variables to
minimize the entropy and maximize the
information gain
and that's all done in that one line of
code
boy we worked on all that theory and
computer does it for you in one line of
code
it's important to understand the theory
behind it so you know what's happening
because as they make changes to these or
if you had special settings on it
you have to know what they're doing but
in this case you can see that we once we
get it formatted the computer does all
the heavy lifting for us
and it never ceases to amaze me just how
advanced machine learning
has become these days and how easy it is
for people to get into it and learn the
basic setups and be able to compute your
different machine learning models
once we've computed our decision tree
and we built it on there
we want to go ahead and start doing
predictions with it and what are we
going to predict well you remember that
we
created our data with the train and test
so we have our training data which we
programmed the tree for
now we want to see what it does with the
test data so let's see what that looks
like
and we can wrap that into tree dot
survived dot predicted
we'll assign that to our prediction
this is nice because we have the command
predict from one of the modules the
rpart module that we brought in
i can simply put in here that we're
going to use the tree
we have our test data and
type this happens to be classification
or class
and this would also be if you were to
distribute this tree
you could save the tree and set it
someplace else to be used on new data
this would be the command line you would
use to predict on here predict
you have your tree saved you have
whatever data you're putting through
and you let it know it's doing a
classification on the tree
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
that's loaded up
and now that we've gone through we've
trained our tree we've run a prediction
on our
test data remember the tree had never
seen the test data till now
so we've already built the tree and
we're just testing it out
and to do that we're going to use a
confusion matrix for evaluating the
model
and let's see what that looks like and
that is simply confusion
matrix so once we have the confusion
matrix
which came in from our carrot we need to
compare the two different
pieces of data and the first one is
going to be
the value we generated up here we have
tree.survived.predicted
so i'm just going to copy that and paste
it down here
and then the second one is the tree
we're comparing that to
let's see survived it's not the tree
it's easy to get confused sometimes when
you're moving these things around
we're going to compare it to test the
test group of data
specifically the survived
column and let's go ahead and run this
and see what that looks like
and so let's go ahead and scroll up a
little bit here to where it first
executed the confusion matrix
and the most important part of this is
that we have our prediction
and our reference and so zero means they
didn't survive
one means they survived we had our
prediction on
here versus the actual and that's what
these two
columns mean and so when you read this
little
chart we have zero zero so both the
prediction
and the actual reference said we agreed
on 218
values for people who did not survive a
little grim there for data remember i'm
talking this is
morbid data talking about death rates of
people on boats
it says that they both agreed on 93 so
93 of them
where we predicted the value that they
would survive and the reference came up
the same
likewise the predicted were predicted
one
and the reference said no these people
didn't survive
well our prediction got 25 wrong
and where it says they didn't survive
and they actually did it got 57 wrong
and we can come on down with the
confusion matrix
and we can look at the accuracy comes up
with the 0.7913 or 95 percent ci
so you're looking at pretty high
accuracy
information ratio p-value when you're in
statistics the p-value is one of the
things we look at
remember that there are certain values
if it's over 0.95
it's considered highly valuable variable
0.5 means maybe
anything less than that means it's
probably not connected
you have to look up the p-value a little
bit more on that then they just have
more information down here
which you can go through and
which you can go through but the
important part is that we have a very
high accuracy
that's what we're looking at this is a
very accurate model
and again always remember the domain
you're working with certainly this is an
example
and this is a good little piece of data
you can play with but if i was say
betting money and my accuracy came up as
79
or over 95 ci i'd be like yes let's bet
on that that's a good bet
but if i was betting on a life or death
situation i might
kind of rethink that a little bit if
that is if it's going to affect my life
that way
you can also look at this as if you're
trying to figure out where the boats go
in this particular example
and where to put the lifeboats that's
actually pretty good be able to say hey
we can increase the chances of people
surviving this accident
by putting the lifeboats in the
appropriate places
and then this is always fun let's
visualize the decision tree
one of the cool things you can do inside
of r real easily
and if you remember one of the modules
we brought in has a rpart.plot
we're going to take that and we're going
to dump that into the prp
for the tree and let's go ahead and hit
enter
and this is fine let me move this over
so you get a nice view
you can see how it actually split it up
and let me just rerun that again now
they expanded the right
you'll see right here where one of the
biggest splits was
whether the person was male or female
didn't know that was probably one of the
biggest
breaks as far as lowering the entropy
and increasing the information
gain and then once you know sex is male
it came down here and it said you're not
going to survive
i guess the men were throwing themselves
overboard on the boat i don't know
maybe they're being very gallant and
letting the women and children survive
which is what i hope that means
so once you know that it's not a male
and it's a female passenger
if you were in class 3 or above you had
a high chance of surviving
if you were less in class 3 class 1 or 2
then it was based on age and so you can
see where age was greater than 19.
so anybody over 19 had a high chance of
surviving
and then if they were or less than 19
i'm sorry if the age was a little
confusing on that one
but if the age was one sided 19 they
probably survived if not then they said
hey if your age is less than
60 you probably survived and if not
people who are older probably didn't
make it out of the boat in time
so elderly have a much higher risk which
you would expect you'd expect that to be
the case that
elderly would have a hard time getting
off into the lifeboats
and they would probably step aside for
the younger generation i know i would
you know so it might be more of a social
norm statistic as opposed to
survival rate let's go and put this back
on over here
and see what else we can do with this
data you know if you're working with the
shareholders it's good to have a lot of
tools as far as how to display
you know they'll want to see this number
here where you say hey this is what
the confusion matrix looks like and we
got a
0.79 accuracy that would be like the
number one thing you
talk to the shareholders about other
data scientists care about the p
value and the information rate and
information like that
but this is really the core right here
this is how much data and this also
shows them how much data was
looked at so you have a you can actually
just add these numbers together and you
can see how many different people were
in the
this particular data set i mean lines in
the data set
but we go ahead and visualize the 2d
decision boundaries and let's take a
look at that that's kind of fun
it's a little bit more complicated so
i'm not going to go into it
in too much detail today now the guys in
the back put this code together for me
which is great
so i'm just going to paste that in
because like i said we're not going to
go into it into too much detail
i want to show you that there's some
other ways to display the data that is
not just this nice little tree over here
which gives us a little bit more maybe
view of what's going on
as you dig deeper into data that becomes
very important it might not be something
so simple where you can look at
in this case uh one two three four nodes
so they have four major nodes that they
split the data in
so we're looking at this we're going to
go ahead and create a set test
equal to test comma c241
we're just assigning color column to go
with the data
okay that's what that is and then we're
going to
take set and have it equal to test
and we'll do x one and we're going to
set that equal to minimum set
of one minus one max set of one
plus one by equals point
zero one they had to play with these
numbers a little bit
to get this to look right so we're
creating a sequence on here
from our the set we created so our test
set
and then x2 is also creating a sequence
based on
different values and then we're going to
put that all into a grid
so let's go ahead and run that through
all the way down to the grid
and they'll make a little more sense
when we add the column names to the grid
okay
so we'll set our test we'll create our
x1 sequence
and our x2 sequence remember a sequence
is just like in this case starting with
0.1
it's like 0.01 0.02 0.03 0.04
so we're going to create a grid with all
these values separated by 0.01
so that's all we're doing right now
let's go ahead and set that up there's
our grid
and then we want to go ahead and create
some column names and for our grid set
we're going to have our c class and age
so we're just doing the class and the
age on here remember we did
sex also before so it's just class and
age on this chart that we're pulling out
and we're going to create a y grid and
the y grid is going to equal
tree survived predicted okay
so here's our y grid and our predicted
values
on there now we're actually going to do
something we're going to plot
and we're going to plot the y grid oops
hold on let me see what's in here
and let me go ahead and just run the
plot it's got to be the
there we go so let's take a look at this
and see we can make a little sense of
this code and what's going on here
because a couple things going on
what we've done is we've plotted a
decision tree classification data set
we've done our plot and we have our set
so our sets equal to our test
data and then we have our main we went
ahead and give it a name decision tree
and then we have our x lab and our x
limit
and we've set those up as class with our
y lab
equals age and our x limit equals range
x one comma y limit equals range of x
two and when you look over here
you can see that we have age on the left
and class on the bottom
and so based on age and class
and so once we put in this nice graph
here we want to go ahead and add our
contours and our points so let's go
ahead and run that
and i'm going to run all three of these
so we can see all the colors come in on
the graph
and this is actually going to take a
little bit because remember
you can make it go a little faster by
changing a couple of the notes up here
well we did 0.01 from the min to max
by changing that to 0.1 or other values
you can actually it'll run a little
quicker and we're going to create a nice
little
decision tree classification test set
just to see what that looks like
and how that data displays now that was
taking so long to run with 0.01
i went ahead and just did a 0.1 so
instead of filling the whole page with
different colors for a really pretty
view
now i just have these different colored
lines coming across
it gives us another model that we can
show for
whoever you're working with in this case
your shareholders of the company
or the individuals who you're posting to
the web for and you can see where we
have the green and the red
and we've set those up to identify from
the decision
who's going to make it and who's not
based on age and class
now my favorite one on this and i'm
going to go back and just highlight this
really quick
was let me just rerun that go back to
prp tree where we display the tree
and that's where we split it in part
because this information
gives us some keys that we can then use
in other models
so it's good to know that sometimes what
you're taking comes out and maybe you
create a bucket for people under 19
between 19 and 60 and over 60 and
different things like that so you can
actually put people in buckets
in a class age split just a quick note
on there
again you know lots of different things
from which you can display the data
and you can see how we use the decision
tree to figure out
chances of somebody surviving based on
their class and their age
let's go ahead and take a look at the
decision trees so
let's go ahead and talk about another
algorithm decision tree
decision tree is a tree-shaped algorithm
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
there's a tree which helps us by
assisting us in decision making let's
look at the basic terminologies to
understand decision trees
we have a root node we have a splitting
we have decision node decision node and
then those split
into terminal node decision node
terminal node terminal node
and each decision node continues to
split until it ends in a terminal node
note a is the parent node of b and c
also note we call the terminal nodes
leaf nodes you can also see that we have
a branch
or a sub tree so when you have a split
everything under that split
under one side is called a subtree you
cannot build your decision tree without
knowing entropy and information gain
entropy entropy is the measure of
randomness of
impurity in the data set so we have here
a bunch of fruit and you can see we have
it looks like apples oranges and bananas
uh it's very chaotic so it's a very
random data set has a very high
entropy and if we take out one group
let's say we take out the apples
it's a little less random now we only
have bananas and oranges so it's a less
random data set and we have lower
amount of entropy entropy is a measure
of randomness or purity in the data set
so when you have a
homogeneous data set we will have
entropy equals zero and
here you can see it's all oranges an
equal divided data set
will have an entropy equal to one so
here we have
a half or um what is it looks like a
couple bananas a couple oranges and a
couple apples
so everything is equal so we have an
entropy of one on there since there's
two of everything
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy
after the data set is split also known
as entropy reduction
so we look over here we have an entropy
equals e1
and the information gain as we split the
bananas out
uh the size becomes smaller and you'll
see that e1
is going to be greater than e2 or we
measure e2
of the apples and oranges in this case
if you love your fruit it's probably
getting you hungry right about now and
then the information gain
from our level 2 equals e2 minus e1
where e2 is greater than e3
as we come down here we'll see that the
e3 is now the third level we split the
oranges and apples out
and each time that entropy becomes less
and less and less until in this case we
have an entropy of 0
since they're all homogeneous in their
order all oranges
all apples all bananas so let's take a
look at the use case decision tree and
actually put this into code and see what
that looks like as we go from theory
to script and to predict the class of
flower
based on the petal length and width
using r
and you'll see here we have these
beautiful irises probably the most
popular data set for beginning data
analysis and statistics
we have the setosa the virginica and the
versiccolor let's install the packages
that will help us
in the use case so because we're doing
decision tree we have our part our
part.plot
and then we have the library our part
and the library are part
dot plot let's go ahead and take a look
at that and if you remember we have two
ways of installing it we can do the
install packages we did that earlier
here we go install packages
using my up arrow to get to it or we can
go up to tools install packages
and i can do our part and our
part dot plot and then go ahead and hit
the install
badges that will be updated are
currently loaded oh looks like some of
them already loaded that's fine
we'll just go ahead and update those and
once we have those updated let's take a
look and see what we have going on here
hope still loading let's go ahead and
type in library
our part and library
our part dot plot so we want to bring it
into
our console with we're working in so up
and now we just download the packages
and now we want those libraries
available to what we're doing
so the iris although it's built into the
r package download on the basic download
we actually have to
install the data or bring the data in so
we're going to do the data iris
and then we're going to do the string
iris and let's just flip back on over to
our rstudio and set up our data iris
and then we're going to do string before
we do that let's do head
head iris there we go and you can see
the head has sepal length
sepal widths pedal length pedal width
species
in this case the top part's all setosa
and each row gets a number
and then we did the string iris and that
comes up with information
and if we flip back to our slide you can
see here the structure of the database
under string
is it's a data frame as 150 objects
five variables each so each one has five
variables all features are numerical
except species
which is categorical as it is our target
variable which we want to predict so we
want to predict whether it's going to be
a varicosa versus color setosa
so you can see here we want to predict
all the features are numerical except
species which is categorical
it is our target variable which we want
to predict and remember that's the
setosa
the versacolor the virginica the three
different
categories we saw earlier in the
beautiful pictures of the flower
and so we're going to go ahead and use
the set seed
to decide the starting point used in the
generation of sequence of random numbers
remember we set the seed so that if we
ever want to
reproduce what we're doing it will
reproduce the same thing each time
because using the same randomizer seed
bring slightly different results but
depending on what you need it for
and then we're going to generate random
numbers using run
if and the question is why do we want to
create random
numbers on here it's kind of an unusual
thing to do
for in rows iris let's go back and just
take a quick look here
actually we want to go back to our r
studio and you're going to notice when i
did the head of iris what did i have i
had setosa satosis at setosa setosa
setosa
so the data is organized by species and
it's already
grouped them together in the data set
well we want to randomize that so that
doesn't affect our output and then we'll
go ahead and take and create our iris
ran
where we recreate the data frame based
on a random order
instead of setosa all being grouped
together let's go ahead and put that
into our rstudio
and set dot seed and we'll match their
number
9850 this way we'll have identical
results to what they're doing on the
slides
then we're going to set the variable g
equal to
run if and base this on in row
of iris and finally
we're going to create iris underscore
ran
and we're going to assign our variable
we're creating iris underscore ran
and we'll set that equal to we're going
to do that the original database we're
going to set that equal to iris
and we need brackets because we're
assigning the valuables and we want to
change the order
so there's an actual uh command order we
can do
that's going to be order g so this means
all the rows
in the order that g is so we just
randomized all those rows and then
we want to keep all the columns we'll
just put a comma and we'll leave it
blank for the columns
so now iris ran will have some
randomized rows coming in
and if we do head let's just do this
real quick
iris ran we can see this no longer
setosa setosa we now have uh virginica
setosa
versacolor setosa and you can see the
road numbers at the beginning we have
103 20 63
17 so they're randomized on there pretty
well now that we've done a little data
manipulation
we can go ahead and build our model
using our part as follows
and one of the things i want you to
notice here is we're going to build our
model
for our r part on the first hundred
because our data equals iris ran
one to a hundred there's 150 objects so
we're keeping a third of them off to the
side
that way we have our training set and
our test set already pre-built because
we randomized the
rows going in from the beginning and
then once we've done that we want to go
ahead and print our model out and take a
look at it let's go ahead and put this
into
our r studio and take a look and so we
have our model we're going to call it
model that's our variable name
that we're giving it we're going to
assign that our
part and in brackets we'll start with
species
and we want to correlate species to all
the other columns
so how do we do that and the shorthand
is just to put a period there
and then we're going to put a comma and
we want to set our data equal to
iris rand that's the data we put in
there and remember i said we're going to
do just the first 100
rows so we can save the last 50 for
testing
so we can do that simply by doing row 1
to 100 so in r you start with 1 for your
rows
and because we want all the columns we
just put a
comma and that denotes that we're going
to use all the columns in here
and in the our part there's different
methodologies
we're using the method equals
class and you realize that we're doing a
classification between the three
different types of flowers and so this
is what we want to go ahead and set up
our model with and when we run that
we've now created a nice model for us we
can go and just type in
model hit enter and you'll see it'll
print out a bunch of information about
our model
so let us know what's going on in there
and let's just break that down and see
what that looks like
so we have our target our predictors
that species and it's going to relate to
we used a period to denote all the
columns we're going to take the first
100 rows
to train the data and we have the
defining method to be used as
classification that's what the
method equals class is and what we want
to do next is we're going to do a plot
and take a look and see what this
actually looks like a little visual here
which is nice and we simply do that with
our plot
for the model and let's break this down
a little bit and see what that looks
like in the
r setup and we do this our part dot
plot a little bit of a mouthful there
sometimes that's part of the r part
package or module so when you imported
this in it also
included its own plotting format and
we're going to
send it our variable model and there are
actually a number of types of plots
listed for our part but we're just going
to do type equals four
fallen dot leaves equals
t and extra equals
104. let's go ahead and hit enter on
there and you'll see right over here on
the right hand side it goes into our
plots
let me just enlarge it large that we
have our
versa color our setosa versacolor
virginica
and let's go ahead and break that down
as you can see down here it represents
the tree as it splits
it looks at it and says hey if the petal
dot length is less than 2.6 it's going
to be a setosa
so 34 percent of them fall into that
category
and if the pedal length is greater than
2.6
then looks at that and says okay now i
have uh three different
variables we're going to split it again
pedal width is less than 1.7 is going to
be a versa color and if it's greater
than 1.7 it's a virginica and so you can
see here
it's very simple tree it forms it's only
got a couple levels you can see a branch
off to the right very nice depiction of
what's going on
as far as the model now it's created but
once we create the model we need to
figure out is this model any good so let
me go back over here and let's go back
to our slides
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to take our test data
remember we saved 50 rows for the end to
go ahead and run a predict on there so
let's go ahead and run that prediction
so we'll call it model underscore
predict
and we're going to hit a wrong button
there to predict and we're going what
are we going to predict we're going to
predict our initial model
and we need to send the data so data
equals
and we don't actually have to put the
data part and we just put in iris
underscore ran and then we want to do
just the last
50 rows and we denote that by 101
colon 150 and then comma and we'll leave
that part blank since we want all the
columns to show up
and then finally this is a
classification so we need to let it know
that type equals class there we go
and let's just see what that looks like
model predict
and so this is what the data is put out
as is it says whatever this is 131 is a
virginica
number 10 is a setosa line number 95 is
a
versa color and so on all the way
through what we really want to know is
how good our model is
so we're going to go ahead and install a
couple more packages we're going to
install the packages required to use the
confusion matrix
and to do that we're going to install
carrot and e1071
and then of course we want to set them
to our project by using the library
command
and so we can simply install packages
and we want carrot and we'll go ahead
and just do that right there
there's carrot installed and we went
ahead and did the install
for packages e1071
let's see it goes through there it's
really quick install compared to the
carrot and then once we've installed the
packages
we need to load it into our workspace so
there's our library
carrot
and once that's loaded we'll go ahead
and also load the uh
or set the library to the e1071 so that
we have both those libraries available
to us
and here we go library
and now these two libraries are fully
available to us and then we're going to
use
these tools to create the confusion
matrix
and this one confusion matrix
this is the iris ran and then we'll go
ahead and put the
brackets here and we're only going to do
101
to 150 and then we only want the first
five columns of the last five column the
first five columns
so five in there and we'll set that to
our model
predict and then when we hit enter it's
going to head
and just print out all this information
so right here we're looking at our
confusion matrix to
see how everything kind of balances out
let's go over that and see a little
closer what that actually means
so the first part we see is a reference
and in here we have our prediction
because that's what we call the column
if you remember correctly uh and we have
it for
setosa versacolor virginica and then we
have setosa versacolor virginica going
down each side
and the way you read this is if you look
at this we predicted
a 16 out of 16 setosa
and then versa color we predicted 13 of
the verse of color
and then two of those we predicted as
virginica so we were wrong on two of
those
and with the virginica we predicted 17
correct
and we had two wrong that were versa
color so we look at the overall
statistics on here and we have an
accuracy of 0.92 and a 95
ci that's pretty good as we're going
through here
those are good deals on that and there's
a lot more information as you go down
this
the one thing i want to remind you on
this as we're looking at these
predictions and this is also true for
the linear regression model we looked at
earlier when we talk about the accuracy
that is the accuracy on this data and we
say that
as a programmer to make that a very
clear distinction because if you're in
data analysis you should cringe if i say
oh this is a 95
accurate model without that put in there
because
bad data in bad data out we won't go
into detail right now on that but that
is a very important
to note that whenever you quote any of
the accuracies on here or you discuss
any of these values that come up today
we're going to cover the
random forest in r if you remember from
part one we did the decision tree
and no one wants a poor lone standing
tree out in the field we want a forest
and so we're going to cover random
forest it's a little play on wards there
i'm sure the people who designed it also
knew that too when they were thinking
about it
so what's in it for you what is a random
forest
how does a random forest work we're
going to cover applications of a random
forest
some of the terms you need to know when
using a random forest
and then we'll go over the use case in r
predicting the quality of
wine so let's start a little bit with
exploring what is a random forest
and welcome to raphael's vineyard and i
don't even know how to pronounce that in
alsace france the largest wine
production region in the world
so they have centuries of wine
production
and data they've collected on how to
make the best how to make their grapes
and grow them and
how to properly get the right grapes and
ferment them like
raphael winemakers around the world are
facing a grave
problem so let's meet the man himself
and try helping him out
what is a random forest we're going to
come back to the vineyard but we're
going to look at some other examples
along the way too
open up the door and of course uh here
comes rafael
that probably i'd probably look closer
to raphael than i do to the young lad
with the beard
hey raphael so tell us how it's going
not as good as before
not many people work in this profession
anymore so every stage of production has
gone
slower if only we could somehow speed up
the process
well lucky for you i'm a machine
learning engineer how about we automate
the quality prediction process for wine
let me begin by telling you what machine
learning in random forest is
machine learning is the science of
applying algorithms that allow a
computer to predict the outcome without
being explicitly programmed
random force is an ensemble machine
learning algorithm
so we're bringing in different pieces
and then putting those pieces together
it operates by building multiple
decision trees remember i told you we
don't want just a lone tree out there in
the we want a forest
they work for both classification if you
remember from part one we had our vendor
with his
broccoli and oranges i think he also had
carrots and it also
the output given by the majority of its
decision trees is the
forest final output so if you have a
number of decision trees you have five
decision trees and four of them say it's
broccoli
then it's probably broccoli and you can
also use it as a regression model
the output given by the majority of
decision trees is a forest final output
just like you do in classification you
can also come up with
actual values and numbers as a
regression model could you explain how a
random force
works in layman terms it's always a good
thing to
explore the information on something a
little bit easier to understand and see
sure let's consider the case of sam a
high school student
this so reminds me of my own high school
student who's just started his first
year in college
asking all his friends so sam is
confused on which course to take up
so he's trying to figure out what his
next class is going to be at school
should he
take music lessons dance lessons math
science maybe social studies so he
decides to ask a couple of his friends
for suggestions and sam approaches jane
first so he comes up to jane and says
hey which of these classes should i take
and jane asked sam a few questions based
on which she can suggest
theoretical do you like theory no he
doesn't like the theory part
calculative do you like calculative he
goes yes i like doing calculations
and so jane based on a couple question
goes she has a little decision tree
there going she goes mathematics
sounds good so james forms a decision
tree based on sam's response and gives
her suggestion and of course this is
based on jane's views and her history
and the data that she's collected over
her years in high school
next sam approach is bella bella asks
him hey do you like the fill of science
and sam goes yes and then bella goes do
you like
new in industry he like new things
coming up in industry and sam goes yes
and bella goes you know you should
similar to jane
bella also forms a decision tree based
on sam's response
and gives her suggestion and says hey
how about artificial intelligence
sam's like oh artificial intelligence so
sam next asked terry for his suggestion
and uh sam goes do you like scoring
things and he goes yes
and he goes do you like theoretical and
he goes no
and he comes up and says mathematics so
you have
two people saying mathematics and once a
person suggesting artificial
intelligence
since two out of three friends suggested
math sam decides to take
mathematics and there's a lot of
subtleties in this example it's actually
a really good example
some of the things we run into in data
science is when we collect
data and we collect from different
sources we might have
data from one source that measures one
thing
or one set of instruments and we might
have data from another source that
measures something else
we saw that with each of his friends are
measuring different things and asking
different questions
that's a little bit beyond the scope of
this particular tutorial
so let's go back to our wine cellar so
you see
more the number of decision trees more
accurate will be the prediction
random forests have a number of
applications in market already
if you've been watching any of our other
tutorials you'll see that these are very
common
we have in banking it can be used to
predict fraudulent customers
is used to analyze symptoms of patients
detecting the disease
in e-commerce the recommendations are
predicted based on customers activity
stock market trends can be analyzed to
predict profit or loss
most recently i was watching a review on
weather
here in the united states and the data
they pull in for that
and one of the top weather places
actually uses
five different models random forest was
one of them i believe
these five different models to predict
the weather and depending on what the
models come up with and what's going on
some of the models do better than others
i thought that was really interesting
it's important to note so when you see
us repeat the same things over and over
and you're looking at the different
machine learning tools you realize that
we use
multiple tools to solve the same problem
and we can find the best one that fits
for that particular situation
so let's see how that fits back in our
wine production
to help speed up the process of wine
production we will automate the
prediction of wine quality
suppose our random forest builds three
decision trees
we have the first decision tree which is
going to divide everything by chlorides
less than 0.08 and it's either yes or no
and then it's going to look at alcohol
greater than 6
yes or no quality equals high quality
not so good and if the chlorides were
greater than 0.08
quality equals low so there's our first
tree and then our second tree is going
to split it
on sulfates less than 0.6 and ph
ph less than 3.5 and again we have it
coming down here that if the
ph is low and the sulfites are low the
quality equals high
if the ph is a little higher but the
sulfides are low it's not
so good and if the sulfides are greater
than 0.6 we have a quality equals low
and then we'll do a third decision tree
we'll split it based on ph
and we can see below how that tree looks
like with our sugar less than 2.5
if not it's a quad equals low it's real
low quality
and if it is less than 2.5 then the ph
decide whether it's going to be a
quality pie or not so good
and if we track one of our wines down
the list
we'll look at it we'll say oh two out of
three decision trees indicate
the quality of our wine to be five the
forest predicts the same
so this sounds promising so let's go
ahead and dive in and see what that
actually looks like
so this is the data set that holds all
the attribute values
required to predict the wines quality
and i'll pull this up in a spreadsheet
in just a moment
but you can see here we have fixed
acidity volatile acidity citric acid all
the way to quality
and then quality is like a four five six
or seven i believe
and this will be done in r so let's go
ahead and get started on our coding
we'll be using rstudio
before we dive into our studio i always
like to open up
the data in the spreadsheet and look at
the actual data that i have
and they've called it wine quality dash
red.xls
so it's a spreadsheet a microsoft
spreadsheet
and when we open it up we'll see that it
matches what we had before
as far as the slide was showing us with
the we have
12 different columns the first 11 are
our features
our fixed acidity volatile acid citric
acid
things you always want to look at when
you're looking at your data and we've
done this before
in the part one but just a reminder we
want to note that
we have decimal places here float values
and a lot of these things especially the
first
number of columns our free sulfur
dioxide looks to be
an integer but it varies a lot so we
have you know i see some values all the
way up to 51
7 4. so we'd probably keep this as a
linear model kind of thing same thing
with the sulfur dioxides
densities again decimal places sulfides
alcohol
quality i want you to note in the
quality that we only have a few
qualities here
this isn't like a spread between zero
and a hundred
it looks to be three four five six and
seven
and so when we start looking at the
processes we can have the option of
either doing this
as a series of integers or float values
going from
three to seven or we can convert that to
a categorical three four
five six and seven being the categories
but we'll look at that in the coding
here in just a minute
and finally you'd want to go ahead and
scroll down through the data
and just look for missing data or
anything weird
obviously you're working with big data
you wouldn't be able to do that if this
was spread across numerous computers
and you had millions of rows we have
what sixteen hundred and eighty seven
rows here so it's a nice size
spreadsheet still
considered a small data set let's go
ahead and switch over
and let's take a look at this in the r
so here we are in our r
studio and if you remember it's uh comes
up automatically in three panels
i have my font on fairly large to help
out
the upper left panel is a file that's
opening that multiple files and tabs
open as you can see on mine right now
i'll probably close most of those in
just a minute and this is where you can
put in your commands
then you can execute these commands by
either clicking on the run box
or control enter as the hotkeys for that
and all that does is then puts that down
in the console and
executes that line of command you could
just paste these directly in the console
i've certainly been known to do that if
i'm loading up some data and i just want
to take a quick look at it in r because
i'm doing the coding in something else
or if i just want to do a quick explore
before i dive in and figure out what
needs to be done
that's one of the tricks you can do and
then on the right hand side
we have our environment history
connections
we mainly are going to just be sitting
on plots and i'm just going to minimize
this for right now out of the way when
we dive in
if you haven't yet you do need to go
ahead and install
the package random forest i'm not
actually going to do that because i've
already run that we don't need to rerun
that
but i am going to go ahead and import it
into our project with the library
and then random forest and we'll do the
control
enter you can always hit the run button
up there too
and then now the library has been
uploaded in there
and you can see down below it takes us
and just copies it and pastes it down
below
and runs it in our console and then just
a quick
troubleshooting thing my java happens to
be
the developer's job the latest release
of the developers java from last week is
clashing with my r
and rerouting my java files so your
chances are you don't need to
to look this up or find out where your
java is but there's a jre
folder if you do have an error that
comes up next in the next library
you look that up it's usually under
program files java and you'll see
jdk depending on what version you have
on there and then find that jre folder
and i'm just going to set the
environment on there you have to do that
every time you run the script so
with r there is a place in r where you
can set it permanently
but generally it's set to whatever your
system variables are set to so you don't
want to mess with that so you just want
to put this in your code
if you're having problems and you can
always take it out then we need to go
ahead and bring in another library
and we're going to be importing a the
spreadsheet so it's an x
the xlsx since it's a microsoft
spreadsheet
and i'll go ahead and run that
let's go ahead and create a variable
path we're going to assign to variable
path the location of our folder so this
is a very lengthy one you'll have to
copy and paste it off your computer
my name is richard and you can see under
it's under c column users richer's
documents
docs business simply learn marketing
random forest
and then the actual file which is wine
quality dash red.xls
so i put in the whole path in here you
could also set the
computer path to whatever folder you
have it in and then just
use just the name of the file but i went
ahead and did this because it a lot of
times it's good to
be aware where your paths are going
where you're pulling your data from
and again i went the control enter so i
could you'll see that that pushed the
line down below and ran that line so our
path is now set
and then let's create a variable called
data
and we'll assign that to a read and
we're going to be reading
see where is it there it is and
spreadsheet
and before i put in uh we need the path
but we also need one more thing on the
spreadsheet because it is an excel
spreadsheet we need to know which page
we're on so let's go look that up
and in the spreadsheets this might be a
little hard to see because it's a very
tiny font down there
but you'll see the page tabs on the
bottom this actually has two different
pages
and we want page one for this project so
let's flip back over and put that in our
code
and the term they use is sheet index
i always have to look that stuff up and
it was sheet index of one
we'll go ahead and execute this so at
this point we've now
loaded the data into the variable data
and it's reading those and i think there
was like a couple thousand
rows of data in there so it takes it
just a moment to pull it in
once i have my data in there i always
like to do something like this
data and in always forgetting r
it's head data and we can run that
and you'll see it prints out that what
we looked at in the spreadsheet so we
have our fixed
acidity volatile acidity citric acid
residual sugar chlorides free sulfur all
the different things
we're actually looking for quality so
you want to keep that in mind that
quality is the final
setting is it a three four five six what
is the quality on there
and the first thing we need to do is
we're actually going to take the data
quality
and let me see quality there it is
in r the dollar sign means that you're
looking at one of the
columns in here or features as it is so
we see data dollar sign quality and r
that means that's what we're going to be
editing and what we want to do is we
want to change the quality just a little
bit
and so we're going to set it equal to
now we're not assigning a variable we're
altering it so
data dollar sign quality equals and we
want to do
as is one of the functions in r we're
going to do as a factor
and then data quality because that's
what we're actually editing on there
and this stop just for a second to look
at this
factor takes this and looks at the data
as a categorically
so instead of it being on a continual
scale of you know
0 to 100 or something like that it
actually looks at it as category of five
category of six category of a
category of cat category of dog there
are yes or no categories
versus a continual now there's a lot of
different
things in here that we could do the same
thing with but all of these
really are linear numbers 7.4 0.70
sulfur dioxide 3467. so we really don't
need to mess with any of the other
variables in there but we do want to go
ahead and set this up and we'll come up
here and do our control enter
and it'll run it down below and you'll
see data quality equals as
factor data quality so we've now turned
that into a factor or into a categorical
data
and so let me just bring this down a
little bit the guys in the back did the
rest of this next piece of code
there are so many different ways and if
you have been looking at any of our
tutorials
this should look kind of familiar this
is one way to do it
you'll see we have our training data and
our testing data and so we've done here
is we've got it we have a data set
size equals and we're just going to do
by the row and so we want point eight or
eighty percent of the data is going to
be
our training set to train our forest and
if you train a
forest or any machine learning model
of course want to test it so we're going
to save 20 of the data for testing
and when you look at this we have the
index
which we set at 80 percent comma and
then a negative
index so that's the remaining setup so
it goes from that index on
this is our notation for sorting out
that data
and then we create the index and we use
the term
sample and this is just going to go in
there and set
our different samples for our in row
size data set size and everything so we
have an index now
so the data is indexed and we're just
going to pull off the first set of index
and the end of the index for our data
and we can run all of this in one shot
we'll go under code
and we'll run selected lines
and so now we have our data in here we
have our training set and our testing
set that's what we wanted to get to
so once we've formatted all the data
then we get to the next real easy step
which is a single line
to bring in our random forest
so let's go ahead and we'll use a
variable rf standing for random forest
and we're going to assign if you
remember correctly we brought in
our library random if you wonder why i
go up here all the time it's because
i'll forget which letters are
capitalized in some of these because i
switch between packages so much
but it's random with a capital f for
forest random forest so the rf is going
to equal
random forest and of course the
we start by telling it which column
we're trying to predict
and of course we can always go down here
and double check we're running this on
the
quality there we go quality and we're
using just that column all the way to
the end
and then we've added our team in the
back has gone in and played with this a
little bit and we'll go a little bit
over
what they did but i'm going to put in
the values
that they have set for the different
options in the random forest
before i do that it would help if i tell
it what data to use data is going to
equal
our training set and then we have the
variables that they put together and
let's just
talk a little bit about what these
different variables mean
so m try and entry these are some of the
variables you play with with the random
forest
the m try not so much when they first
put it out
i think m try was very common four is a
good value
i can't remember what the default is but
it's probably three four or five or
something like that depending
i think it depends on how many features
you have going in there so you could
even just leave this as a default
without too much troubles the end tree
this is where it gets important and i'm
going to make this 2001.
one of the suggestions is to always make
this odd like a tie breaker just in case
the default is like 500 or 501
and then finally we have importance
equals true
i can't remember what it defaults to but
generally
you want to set the importance equals to
true it actually looks at the
correlation
between the different features to make
sure that there is some kind of
correlation as it's doing its
calculations
so our one line of code is going to
assign our random
forest and go ahead and train our random
force all in one execution
so this whole thing has been centered
around getting to rf
set to the random forest and let's go
ahead and execute this variable
or this line of code and you'll see it
takes a little bit down here to execute
as it goes through
and sets it up and you'll see it
probably takes a minute or so
to execute the code depending on the
size of the data and how good your
machine is
and then with all of our data we can
start looking at the answers
we'll just do rf we'll execute that
and you'll see that the random forest
does a nice job
you can see right here it has our data
equals training it basically goes over
everything we talked about
and you come down here and it has a
confusion matrix which is nice we always
like our confusion matrix when we're
talking to our shareholders and
explaining
what the data comes out with and how it
trains
and we can go ahead and plot our rf
let's see what that looks like
and as the number of force grows you
remember we set it to 2001 forest
you can also see how the error comes in
how the different
error on the different variables this
kind of a nice graph that gives you an
idea might help you adjust
whether you really want to do 2000
different forests
you might actually truncate this off at
around maybe 800
because you notice the lines kind of
continue on again this is just still on
the plot
and of course the next step is we need
to go ahead and predict remember we
split our data into two groups
so let's go ahead and get a result we'll
call it result and we'll assign
this one there we go
we'll set this to a data frame there we
go there's our data frame
and then oh let's call this we have our
test
our test quality because that's what
we're
we're setting up on our test group with
the quality on there
then we wanted to have a predict nice
little
keyword there to go and run our random
for us
and then we tell it that we're going to
predict using our rf
our random forest our testing group
1 to 11 is what we're using type equals
response
so let's go ahead and execute it that's
a mouthful on there
somewhere i left out a comma in there so
it gave me an error
but you can see right here we've set in
there now we have a result
and just real quick we could do the head
of the result
result comma five and just take a look
at the first five lines
and you'll see we have the actual value
and what we predicted over here
and we could also just do all of the
results and just see what that looks
like
oops and print that out
and so it has all the different data
we're going through on there
and finally let's just go ahead and plot
there we go we'll put plot up here
plot and let's plot the result
and just see what that looks like maybe
not the best one to show to the
shareholders
but it does give you an idea on the left
on the y-axis you'll see that it
predicted eight
and this tells you that a lot of the
eight
and the eight scale was pretty probably
gave us
about fifty percent came up there at
eight
really maybe fifty percent it didn't
guess right
but it did come up there and say that it
was at least a four five or six
even where it was considered an eight
and so on you can see these different
blocks coming in so that if you line up
the
three with the three four with the four
and you kind of cross
them a heat map would probably do better
but for this example we'll just do a
quick
plot of the data as far as how it works
and you can again see the results that
we predicted over here and you can look
those over
of course back in the wine cellar we're
talking to
our vineyard owner and if you remember
from before we looked at this
chart right here the error rate is 29.05
percent
therefore our accuracy is 70.95
if you're doing a vineyard that's
probably pretty good accuracy and always
check your domain when you're sharing
this stuff
because if you're doing something that's
life or death maybe 70
accuracy might not be so good but if
you're looking at
where you're going to distribute the
bottles to for the wine and who's going
to drink it
you know 70 accuracy is pretty good for
that that's probably a lot better than
having no accuracy whatsoever and not
even knowing what wines going out to who
so we have automated the process of
predicting the quality of wine
i myself prefer to predict it by
sampling it
that's great thank you i'd like to visit
this guy and sample his wine and find
out just how good his different
vineyards are
so now let's understand what an svm is
and if you want to understand support
vector machine you really need a good
example
and i know that cricket is a wonderful
game i don't know a lot about it but i
know it's
very popular around the world and we're
going to use
qriket as an example of svm so we'll
classify qriket players into batsmen
or bowlers using the runs to wicket
ratio
so a player with more runs would be
considered a batsman
and a player with more wickets would be
considered a bowler
and if we could take a data set say of
people cricket players with runs and
wickets
in columns next to their names we could
create
a plot a two-dimensional plot in this
example
clear separation between qriket players
considered bowlers and those cricket
players considered batsmen
and you don't always have a data set
this clean where
there is a clear segregation of data
bowlers versus batsman but for the sake
of understanding
svm this example does well so
before we do any separation before we
apply any
high-level mathematics let's just take a
look at an unknown value
a new data coming into our data set and
that datum
we don't know what class it belongs to
that datum
is a bowler or a batsman we know that
much
but we don't know should we consider
that cricket player a batsman or a
bowler
and so we want to draw a decision
boundary
some type of line separating the two
classes
so that we can use that decision
boundary to classify the new
data point of course we could draw lines
there's a yellow line a green line a
blue line
there's actually not just three lines
but an infinite number of lines that we
could draw
between those two classes so which one
do we pick
and this is kind of reminiscent of
simple linear regression where we
find the line of best fit we want the
line of best
separation we want a line that clearly
separates those two groups as much as
possible once we have the correct line
we would be able to classify the new
data point but in this example
you can see if we pick yellow the new
data point would be a bowler
but if we picked green or blue the new
data point would be a batsman so we need
the one that best separates the data
what line best separates the data we'll
find the best line by computing the
maximum margin
from equidistant support vectors now
support vectors
in this context simply means the two
points
one from each class that are closest
together but that maximize the distance
between them
or the margin so the word vector here
you may think well he really means
points data points
well in two-dimensional space yes and
maybe even in three-dimensional space
but once you get into higher dimensional
spaces
when you get more and more features in
your data set
you have to consider these as vectors
you can no longer really describe them
as
points so we call them vectors and the
reason they're support vectors is
because
the two vectors that are closest
together that maximize the distance
between the two groups
support the algorithm so that's why we
call them support vectors
so if you look at our example there are
a couple of points at the top
that are pretty close to one another and
a couple of points at the bottom of that
graph that are pretty close to each
other
and i'm not really sure looking at the
graph which two
are closest but clearly those
points are the ones we need to consider
the rest of the other
points are too far away from the rest of
the other points in other words the
bowler points
are far to the right and the batsman
data points are far to the left so we'll
look at these
four points to begin with mathematically
we would calculate the distance
among all of these points and we would
minimize that distance
once we pick the support vectors we'll
draw a dividing line
and then measure the distance from each
support vector
to the line the best line will always
have the greatest margin
or distance between the support vectors
if we consider
the yellow line as a decision boundary
the player with
the new data point would be considered a
bowler the margins don't
appear to be maximum though so maybe we
can come up with a better
line so let's take two other support
vectors
and we'll draw the decision boundary
between those
and then we will calculate the margin
and
notice now that the unknown data point
the new value
would be considered a batsman we would
continue doing this and obviously a
computer does it much quicker than a
human being
over and over and over again until we
found the correct
decision boundary with a greatest margin
and in this case if you look at the
green
decision boundary the green line appears
to have the maximum margin compared to
the other two
and so let's consider this the boundary
of
greatest margin and now classify our
unknown data value and now
clearly it belongs in the batsman's
class
the green line divides the data
perfectly because it has the greatest
margin or the maximum margin between the
support vectors
and now we can have confidence in our
classification that the new data point
is indeed
a batsman technically this dividing line
is called a hyperplane and the reason
it's called a hyperplane will become a
little bit more evident
in a few minutes generally in
two-dimensional space we consider
those lines but in three-dimensional
space and higher dimensional spaces
they're considered planes or hyperplanes
so
we always tend to refer to them as
hyperplanes and the hyperplane that has
the maximum distance
from the support vectors is the one we
want
so sometimes called the positive
hyperplane d
plus is the shortest distance to the
closest positive point
and d minus sometimes called a negative
hyperplane
has the closest shortest distance to the
closest negative point
and the sum of d positive and d negative
is
called the distance margin so if you
calculate those two distances and add
them up that's the distance
margin and we always want to maximize
that if we don't maximize it we can have
a misclassification
and you can see the yellow margin is
much smaller than the green margin
so this problem set is two-dimensional
because the classification is only
between two classes
and so we would call this a linear svm
now we're going to take a look at
kernel svm and if you notice in this
picture
this is a great depiction of a plane
not a line this is three-dimensional
space so that's the
plane that separates those two
classes so what if our two-dimensional
data looks like this what if there's no
clear linear separation between the two
classes
and machine learning parlance we would
say that these are not
linearly separable how could we get
support vector machine
to work on data that looks like this
since we can't
separate it into two classes using
a line what we're going to do and
clearly there's no line i mean convince
yourself there's no line that goes
and separates those two classes so what
we would do is we would apply
some type of transformation to a higher
dimension we would apply a function
called a kernel function
to the data set such that the data set
would be
transformed into a higher dimension a
dimension high enough where we could
clearly separate the two groups the two
classes
in this case with a plane much the same
way you saw the picture
a few slides ago where the plane was
separating the two classes here we
clearly could draw some planes between
the green
dots and the red dots and of course we
could draw an infinite number of planes
separating those two classes but we
would draw the one that would maximize
the margin
so if we let r be the number of
dimensions then
the kernel function would convert a
given two-dimensional space
to a three-dimensional space and as i
said once the data is separated in three
dimensions
we can apply svm and separate the two
groups
using a two-dimensional plane and this
is analogous
in the higher dimensions and that last
picture on the right hand side
would be some type of depiction of a
higher
dimension hyperplane and there are more
than one type of kernel function there's
gaussian rbf
kernel sigmoid kernel polynomial kernel
depending on
the dimension and how you want to
transform the data
there are more than one choice for
kernel functions so now let's go through
a use case
let's take a look at horses and mules
and see
if we can use svm to classify some new
data so the problem statement is
classifying horses and mules and we're
going to use height and weight as
the two features and obviously horses
and mules
typically in general tend to weigh
differently and tend to
stand taller so we'll take a data set
we'll import the data set we'll make
sure we have our libraries
the e1071 library
has support vector machine algorithms
built in
we'll compute the support vectors using
the library once
the data is used to train the algorithm
we'll plot the hyperplane get a visual
sense of
how the data is separated and if it's
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
that's great remember if it's higher
dimensional it's tough to plot those
and then we'll use the new model the
trained
model to classify new values in general
we would have a training
set a test set and then ingest the new
data but for our example we're just
going to use
the whole data set to train the
algorithm and then see how it performs
and once we see how it performs we'll
see did we get a horse
did we predict a horse when we had a
horse did we predict a mule when we had
a mule
so here's the r code of course if you
want to run this r code you'll have to
install r and then
rstudio then you'll have to ingest the
data and then you'll have to
create an indicator variable to help us
with our plots we'll install our
libraries
install the package if you don't already
have it installed i do
and then call the library up into the r
session that you're working we'll create
the data frame from
the data that was ingested we will then
view the data frame
and of course we have to explore the
data frame hoping
that we don't have missing values or we
don't have outliers
if we do have missing values or outliers
we'll have to either impute those values
or
delete those values but in this case
let's hope we don't have any and now for
a quick
demo on support vector machines so
we have a working directory where my
data is stored and i'm going to set the
working directory
to that data source and read the data
file
into r and now i'm going to create a
vector
that really is just an indicator
variable it's the
negative ones and the ones that indicate
whether it's a mule or a horse negative
one for a mule
positive one for a horse so i'll create
that vector and
svm there's a great package e1071
great library that has the support
vector machine
functions that we're going to use and
now i'm going to create the data frame
i'm going to take my data and i'm going
to add to it the
is horse vector and now let's just take
a peek and as you can see
there's the height weight and whether or
not the animal was a
mule or a horse so remember machine
learning we take a data source with
known outcomes
and we apply our algorithm to that data
source in this case a data frame of
heights weights
and the indicator variable and then we
use the
machine learning algorithm to learn from
that data
with those known results so now let's
plot the data
the height versus weight and as you can
see the
horses tend to be a lot taller and weigh
a lot more than
the mules so now let's run our algorithm
our svm model against the data and
the key here is that it's a linear model
and we've run it and great now we have a
model let's look at the summary of the
model and as you can see
there's the formula that it ran and some
of the
information about the vectors and the
classes and there are two support
vectors
so now let's find those two support
vectors on our graph
and this might be a little hard to see
the
orange outline around this point and
this point
indicate that those are the two vectors
that will support this model and thus we
call them the
support vectors now let's get the
parameters of the hyperplane
from the model and let's plot a line
that will be our hyperplane
there's our hyperplane line and
therefore
to the left and below our mules
and to the right and above our horses
above that line let's take a few new
observations
and i've encoded these so that it would
be
illustrative we'll take these new
observations
and we'll plot them and i'm going to
generate a new plot
red being the horses black dots being
the mules i'll create an x and y
axis i'm going to plot three dots
and you can see one of them the green
dot the first one
kind of falls near the mules the blue
one kind of falls near the horses
and visually we might conclude hey one's
a mule one's a horse but what about the
orange dot well for the orange dot we
really need our
hyperplane we really need something to
clearly indicate
which side it's on and of course by
looking at this data visualization you
can tell that the
orange dot is probably a mule and let's
verify those results
by sticking those observations into our
model and predict some outcomes
and down below you can see that for the
three data points one two and three the
first one the green one
was negative one that's a mule the
second one was a positive one
that's blue that's the blue point which
was a horse and the third one which we
weren't sure about
but clearly the svm model correctly
predicted that that third point would be
a negative one would be a mule
and we can visually see that by the
hyper plane on the graph
so that's a quick example of svm
in general support vector machines are
binary classifiers we don't use them for
higher level classification
if you had three or more classes you
might want to use something like
random forest what applications you can
use it for
face detection text categorization image
classification
and bioinformatics really anywhere that
you have
the need to classify things into two
groups
so let's dive into what is clustering
what is clustering
so we'll have a group of people here
hanging out at a table or local coffee
shop i'm guessing coffee shops since
they all have the same mugs
and one of them is trying to figure out
what they're going to do i have 20
places to cover in
four days i guess he's going traveling
that sounds fun one of those
breeze through costa rica or visiting
the us or going to
to europe to go visit all the highlights
he's got 20 places he wants to go and he
wants to hit him in four days
very ambitious and how will i manage to
cover
all of them that's the question that
he's coming up how am i going to get to
all these different places in the short
time
i have maybe he's a sales team so he has
20 places he's got to do
demos for you can make use of clustering
by grouping the places into
four clusters each of these clusters
will have places which are close by
so we're going to cluster them together
by what is closest to the other one
then each day you can visit one cluster
and cover all the places in the cluster
great that's a great idea you know if
you're going to hit four different
places
maybe you're going to cluster whatever
streets are closest together so you
don't have to travel spend all your time
traveling
the method of dividing the objects into
clusters which are similar between them
and are dissimilar to the objects
belonging to another cluster
so this is a formal definition of
clustering and we have here
what we call hierarchical clustering and
partial clustering
and we're going to go more into detail
on hierarchical clustering
and you'll see the difference between
the two where partial clustering doesn't
have
the descending graph it just has groups
of things
and under hierarchical clustering we're
going to go over agglomerative and
divisive
and you can think of agglomerative of
bringing things together
and divisive as dividing them apart and
then partial clustering
the two most common ones are k-means
that's probably the most common use for
partial clustering and there's also
fuzzy c means and there's other ways of
clustering and other
algorithms out there but these are the
two big ones k-means
really being the most common one used
but we're not going to dig too deep into
partial clustering because we're
studying hierarchical clustering today
so what is clustering well the
applications of clustering
are pretty numerous we have things like
customer segmentation
what people kind of belong together how
do we group them together
we have social network analysis so
social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something
what group of people don't like
something and then we can use that
sentiments to suggest
new cells for them you know this whole
group is into harley-davidson
motorcycles
so we cater to them to sell them
harley-davidson motorcycle parts and we
find out that people in that group also
like leather jackets they also like
motorcycle boots
and they like bandanas my brother's into
harley-davidson so
that's why i picked that kind of funny
example but you can kind of see we look
for similarities between these people
and then we group them together
accordingly
and that's a good sentimental clustering
is very common
in so many things today we want to know
the sentiments on stocks
who is interested in stocks who's not
sentimental analysis
we talked about customer segmentation in
cells
well we want to know what kind of
sentimental view people have on
different restaurants if we're going to
open up a new restaurant or a new
putting stores in and of course city
planning a lot of this i just kind of
aimed at the city planning side
sitting planning is big with clustering
we want to cluster things together
so that they work we don't want to put a
industrial zone
in the middle of somebody's neighborhood
where they're not going to enjoy it
or have a commercial zone right in the
middle of the industrial zone where no
one's going to want to go
next to a factory to go eat a high-end
meal or dinner
so it's very big in city planning it's
also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models
so when we're exploring data being able
to cluster things together
reveal things in the data we never
thought about and then once we have it
clustered we can put
that into another model to help us
figure out what it is we want for our
solution
so let's go a little deeper into
hierarchical clustering
let's consider we have a set of cars and
we have a group similar
we want to group similar ones together
so below we have
you'll see four different cars down
there and we get two clusters of car
types sedan and suv so if you're just
looking at it you can probably think oh
yeah we'll put the sedans together and
the suvs together
and then at last we can group everything
into one cluster so we just have just
cars
so you can see as we have this we make a
nice little tree this is very
common when you see anybody talks about
hierarchical clustering this is usually
what you see
and what comes out of it we terminate
when we are left with only one
cluster so we have as you can see we
bring them all together we have one
cluster we can't bring it together
anymore because they're all together
hierarchical clustering is separating
data into different groups based on some
measure of similarity so we have to find
a way to measure
what makes them alike and what makes
them different agglomerative clustering
is known as a bottom up approach
remember i said think of that as
bringing things together
you see i think the latin term aglow is
together because you have your glomerate
rocks where all the different pieces of
rocks are in there
so we want to bring everything together
that's the bottom up
and then divisive is we're going to go
from the top down
so we take one huge cluster and we start
dividing it up into two clusters into
three
four five and so on digging even deeper
into how
hierarchical clustering works let's
consider we have a few points on a plane
so this plane is 2d so we have an x y
coordinates kind of makes it easy
we're going to start with measure the
distance so we want to figure a way to
compute the distance between each point
each data point is a cluster of its own
remember if we're going from the bottom
up
agglomerative then we have each point
being its own
cluster we try to find the least
distance between two
data points to form a cluster and then
once we find those with the least
distance between them we start grouping
them together so we start forming
clusters of multiple points this is
represented in a tree-like structure
called
dendogram so this is another key word
dendogram and you can see it is
it's just a branch we've looked at
before and we do the second group the
same so it gets its own
dendogram and the third gets its own
dendogram
and then we might group two groups
together so now those two groups are all
under one dendogram because they're
closer together than the
p1 and p2 and then we terminate when we
are left with one cluster so we finally
bring it all together
you can see on the right how we've come
up all the way up to the top
whoops and we have the gray hierarchical
box coming in there and connecting them
so we have just one cluster and that's a
good place to terminate because there is
no way we can bring them together any
further
so how do we measure the distance
between the data points
i mean this is really where it starts
getting interesting up until now
you can kind of eyeball and say hey
these look together but when you have
thousands of data points how are we
going to measure those distances
and there is a lot of ways to get the
distance measure
so let's go and take a look at that
distance measures will determine the
similarity between two elements and it
will
influence the shape of the clusters and
we have euclidean distance measure
we have squared euclidean distance
measure which is almost the same thing
but with less computations
and we have the manhattan distance
measure which will give you slightly
different results
and we have the cosine distance measure
which again is very similar to the
euclidean playing with triangles
and sometimes it can compute faster
depending on what kind of data you're
looking at
so let's start with euclidean distance
measure the most common is we want to
know the distance between the two points
so if we have point p
and point q the euclidean distance is
the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in euclidean space
and you should recognize d equals in
this case we're going to sum all the
points
so if there was more than one point we
could figure out the distance to the
not more than one points this is the sum
of more than
two dimensions so we can have the
distance between
each of the different dimensions squared
and that will give us
and then take the square root of that
and that gives us the actual distance
between them
and they should look familiar from
euclidean geometry maybe you haven't
played too much with multiple dimensions
so the summation
symbol might not look familiar to you
but it's pretty straightforward is you
add the distance
between each of the two different points
squared so if your y
difference was 2 minus 1 squared would
be 2 and then you take the
difference between the x again squared
and if there was a z
coordinates it would be you know z1
minus z2
squared and then take the square root of
that and sum it all or sum it all
together
and then take the square root of it so
to make it compute faster
since the difference in distances
whether one is farther apart or closer
together than the other
we can do what's called the squared
euclidean distance measurement
this is identical to the euclidean
measurement but we don't take the square
root at the end
there's no reason to it certainly gives
us the exact distance but as far as
doing calculations as to which one's
bigger or smaller than the other one
it won't make a difference so we'll just
go with the so we just get rid of that
that final square root computes faster
and it gives us the
pretty much the euclidean squared
distance on there now
the manhattan distance measurement is a
simple
sum of horizontal and vertical
components or the distance between two
points measured along axes at right
angles
now this is different because you're not
looking at the
direct line between them and in certain
cases
the individual distances measured will
give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with the euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the manhattan distance is you
measure just the y
value and you take the absolute value of
it and you measure just the x difference
you take the absolute value
of it and just the z and if you had more
you know
different dimensions in there a b c d e
f however many dimensions
you would just take the absolute value
of the difference of those dimensions
and then we have the cosine distance
similarity
measures the angle between the two
vectors and as you can see
as the two vectors get further and
further apart the cosine distance
gets larger so it's another way to
measure the distance
very similar to the euclidean so you're
still looking at the same kind of
measurement so should have a similar
result as the first two
but keep in mind the manhattan will have
a very different result
and you can end up with a bias with the
manhattan if your data
is very skewed if one set of values is
very
large and another set of values is very
small but that's a little bit beyond the
scope of this it's just important to
know that about the manhattan distance
so let's dig into the agglomerative
clustering and agglometric clustering
begins with each element as a separate
cluster
and then we merge them into a larger
cluster how do we represent a cluster
of more than one point so we're going to
kind of mix the
distance together with the actual
agglomerative
and see what that looks like and we're
actually going to have three
key questions that are going to be
answered here so how do we represent a
cluster more than one point
so we want to look at the math what it
looks like mathematically and
geometrically
how do we determine the nearness of
clusters
when to stop combining clusters always
important to have your
computer script or your whatever you're
working on have a termination point so
it's not in
going on internally we've all done that
if you do any kind of computer
programming or writing a script
let's assume that we have six data
points in a euclidean space
so again we're dealing with x y and z in
this case just
x and y so how do we represent a cluster
more than one point
let's take a look at that and first
we're going to make use of centroids
very common terminology in a lot of
machine learning languages when we're
grouping things together
so we're going to make use of centroids
which is the average of its points
and you can see here we're going to take
the 1 2 and the 2
1 and we're going to group them together
because they're close
and if we were looking at all the points
we look for those that are closest
and start with those and we're going to
take those two we're going to compute a
point
in the middle and we'll give that point
1 5 1.5
1.5 and that's going to be the centroid
of those two points
and next we start measuring like another
group of points we got four one five
zero when they're pretty close together
so we'll go ahead and set up a centroid
of those two points in this case it
would be the
4.5 and 0.5
would be the measurements on those two
points and once we have the centroid of
the two groups we find out that the next
closest point to a centroid is over on
the left
and so we're going to take this and say
oh 0 0 is closest to
the 1.5 1.5 centroid so let's go ahead
and group that together and we compute a
new centroid based on those three points
so now we have a centroid of 1.1
or 1 comma 1. and then we also do this
again with the last point the 5
3 and it computes into the first group
and you can see our dendrogram on the
right is growing
so we have each of these points are
become connected and we start grouping
them together
and finally we get a centroid of that
group two and then finally the last
thing we want to do is
combine the two groups by their
centroids and you can see here we end up
with one large group and it'll have its
own centroid although usually they don't
compute the last centroid we just put
them all together
so when do we stop combining clusters
well hopefully it's pretty obvious to
you
in this case when they all got to be one
but there are actually many
approaches to it so first pick a number
of clusters
k up front and this is done in the fact
that we don't want to look at
200 in clusters we only want to look at
the top five clusters or something like
that
so we decide the number of clusters
required in the beginning and we
terminate when we reach the value
k so if you looked back on our
clustering let me just go back a couple
screens
you'll see how we clustered these all
together and we might
want just the two clusters and so we
look at just the top two
or maybe we only want three clusters and
so we would compute
which one of these has a wider spread to
it or something like that there's other
computations to know
how to connect them and we'll look at
that in just a minute but to note that
when we pick
the k value we want to limit the
information that's coming in
so that can be very important especially
if you're feeding it into another
algorithm
that requires three values or you set it
to four values and you need to know that
value coming in
so we might take the clustering and say
okay only
three clusters that's all we want for k
so the possible challenges
this only makes sense when we know the
data well so when you're clustering with
k
clusters you might already know that
domain and know that that makes sense
but if you're exploring brand new data
you might have no idea how many clusters
you really need to explore that data
with
let's consider the value of k to be 2.
so in this case in our previous example
we stop and we are left with
two clusters and you can see here that
this is where they came together the
best
while still keeping separate the data
the second approach is stop when the
next merge would create a cluster
with low cohesion so we keep
clustering until the next merge of
clusters creates a bad cluster low
cohesion
setup on there that means the point is
so close to being between two clusters
it doesn't make sense to bring them
together
but how is cohesion defined oh let's dig
a little deeper into cohesion the
diameter of a cluster
so we're looking at the actual diameter
of our cluster and the diameter
is the maximum distance between any pair
of points
in the cluster we terminate when the
diameter of a new cluster
exceeds the threshold so as that
diameter gets bigger and bigger
we don't want the two circles or
clusters to overlap
and we have radius of a cluster radius
is the maximum distance of a point from
centroid
we terminate when the radius of a new
cluster exceeds the threshold
again we're not we don't want things to
overlap so when it crosses that
threshold and is overlapping with other
data
we stop so let's look at divisive
clustering remember we went from the
bottom
up now we want to go from the top down
divisive clustering approach begins with
a whole set and proceeds to divide it
into smaller clusters
so we start with a single cluster
composed of all the data points
we split it into different clusters this
can be done using
monotheistic divisive methods what is a
monothetic divisive method
and we'll go backwards and let's
consider the example we took
in the agglomerative clustering to
understand this
so we consider a space with six points
in it just like we did before same
points we had before
and we name each point in the cluster so
we have in this case we just gave it a
letter value a
b c d e f since we follow
top down approach and divisive
clustering
obtain all possible splits into two
columns
so we want to know where you could split
it here and we could do like a
a b split and a c d e f split we could
do b
c e a d f and you can see this starts
generating a huge amount of data
a b c d e f and so for each split
we can compute cluster sum of squares
and we can see here the actually have
the formula out for us b
j 12 equals n1 of absolute value of x
minus absolute value of x
squared so again we're computing all the
different distances in their squared
back to your kind of euclidean distances
on that and so we can actually compute b
and j between clusters one and two
and we have the mean of the cluster and
the grand mean
depending on the number of members in
the cluster and we select the cluster
with the largest
sum of squares let's assume that the sum
of squared
distance is largest for the third split
we had up above
and that's where we split the abc out
and if we split the abc out we're left
with the def on the other side
we again find the sum of square
distances and split it into clusters so
we go from abc we might find that the a
splits into bc and d into e f
and again you start to see that
hierarchical dendrogram coming down as
we start splitting everything apart
and finally we might have a splits in b
and c
and then each one gets their own def and
it continues to divide until we get
little nodes at the end and every data
has its own point or
until we get to k if we have set a k
value
so we've kind of learned a little bit
about the background and some of the
math
in hierarchical clustering let's go
ahead and dive into a demo
and our demo today is going to be for
the problem statement we're going to
look at u.s
oil so a u.s oil organization needs to
know it cells
in various states in u.s and cluster the
states based on the cells
so what are the steps involved in
setting this problem up
so the steps we're going to look at and
this is really useful for just about
any processing of data although i
believe we're going to be doing this in
r today
we're going to import the data set so
we'll explore our data a little bit
there
create a scatter plot it's always good
to have a visual if you can
once you have a visual you can know if
you're really far off in the model you
choose to
cluster the data in or how many splits
you need and then we're going to
normalize the data so we're going to fix
the data so it processes correctly we'll
talk more detail about normalization
when we get there
and then calculate the euclidean
distance and finally we'll create our
dendogram so it looks nice and pretty
and we have something we can
show to our shareholders so that they
have something to go on
and know why they gave us all that money
and salary for the year
so we go ahead and open up r and we're
actually using our
studio which is the really it has some
nice features in it
it automatically sets up the three
windows where we have our script file on
the upper left
and then we can execute that script and
it'll come down and put it into the
console
bottom left and execute it and then we
have our
plots off to the right and i've got it
zoomed in
hopefully not too large a font but large
enough that you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it my data
and we're going to assign it in r this
is a symbol for assigning
and we're going to go read csv
read csv file and
put that in brackets and let's before we
go any further let's just look at the
data
outside of r it's always nice to do if
you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv
this would also be the time to get the
full path so you have the right path to
your file
and remember that you can always post in
the comments down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you
this file so you can get the same file
we're working on and you can repeat it
and see how this works this is
utilities.csv it's a comma separated
variable file so it's pretty
straightforward
and you can see here they have the city
fixed charge and
a number of different features to the
data and so we have our ror
cost load demand cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have u.s cities
arizona boston they have central u.s so
i guess they're grouping a number of
areas together
the commonwealth area you can see down
here nevada new england
northern us oklahoma the pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so i'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way
upside an extra set of brackets here
somehow maybe i missed a set of brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or
in this case i got double brackets on
each side
there we go and then the magic hot keys
in this case
are your control enter which will let me
go ahead and run the script
and so i've now loaded the data and as
you can see i went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the
window down below and we can simply
convert the data to a string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey just put it all
out as a string
and then we get this huge mess of stuff
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so
when you can see here they have you can
probably kind of
pull it together as looking at it but
let's go ahead and just do the head
and we'll do the head of my data there
we go
and ctrl enter on that and the head
shows the first
five rows you'll see this in a lot of
different scripts
in r it's you type in head and then in
brackets you put your data
and it comes through in this the first
five rows as you can see below
and it shows arizona boston central and
it has the same columns we
just looked at so we have the fixed
charge the ror
the cost the load the d demand
i'm not an expert in oil so i'm not even
sure what d demand is
cells i'm guessing nuclear how much of
it supplied by nuclear
and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in are different areas
and one of the wonders of r is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs and
pairs creates a nice graph let me go
ahead and run this
whoops the reason it gave me an error is
because i forgot to resize it so let me
bring my plot way out
so we can see it and let's run that
again and
you'll see here that we have a nice
graph
of the different data and how it plots
together how the different points kind
of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
i would look at this and say hey this is
a great
candidate for some kind of clustering
and the reason is is when i look at any
two pairs
let's go down to say sales and fuel
costs towards the bottom
right and when you look at them where
they cross over
you sort of see things how they group
together but it's a little confusing you
can't really
pinpoint how they group together you
could probably look at these two and say
yeah there's pretty good commonalities
there
and if you look at any of the other
pairs you'll start seeing some patterns
there
also and so we really want to know what
are the patterns on all of them put
together
not just any two of them but the whole
setup
let me go ahead and shrink my um this
down for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a scatter plot
and this is simply just use the term
plot in brackets
and then which values do we want to plot
and if we remember
when we looked at the data earlier let
me just go back this way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
now we'll do fuel cost and cells
and it's in my data so we'll let it know
which two columns we're looking at next
to each other
and it will open up our plot thing and
then go ahead and execute that
and we can see on those close up of what
we were just looking at in the pairs
and if i was eyeballing this i would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of
five items and this one it's hard to
tell which cluster to be with but maybe
it's six you go in the top one
and you have a middle cluster and a
bottom cluster maybe two different
clusters
so you can sort of group them together
fuel cost and the cells and see how they
connect with each other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all of them
and then the people in the back they
sent me the script so we can go ahead
and add labels so with my data text
fuel cost cells the labels equal city
position four these are numbers you can
kind of play with till they look nice
and oops again i forgot to resize my
plot it doesn't like having it too small
and we'll run that
i mistyped something in here
oh i did a lowercase d and they did a
capital d there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see
a little hard to see on my screen with
all the different things in there
it plots the actual cities so we can now
see where all the cities are in
connection with in this case fuel cost
and cells
so you have a nice label to go with the
graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's
do oh the r o r
oops and we'll do that
also with the cells and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two we'll come over
here and it's gonna
i'm surprised it didn't give me an error
and then we'll also add in the with
statement so we put some nice labels in
there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the fuel cost
cells we want the r
cells and we'll execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because i shrunk it down
so let's redo those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the ror
with cells and we'd probably get a
slightly different clustering here if i
was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say these kind of go together
and those kind of go together but again
we're gonna be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step
we're going to start looking at a little
bit of coding or scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization and
if you've done any
of the other machine learning skills and
setup
this should start to look very normal in
your pre-processing of data
whether you're in r or python or any of
these scripts
we really want to make sure you
normalize your data so it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if i have let's say the
rors even look at this graph here on the
right
you can see where my ror varies between
8 and fourteen
that's a very small variable and our
cells varies between four thousand and
sixteen thousand so you can imagine the
distance between four thousand and eight
thousand which is a distance of four
thousand
versus 8 to 10 versus 2 the cells is
going to dominate
so if we do any kind of special work on
this
it's going to look at cells and it's
going to cluster them just by the cells
alone
and then ror might have a little tiny
effect of two
versus four thousand we want to level
the playing field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script
to normalize so i'm just going to put in
the code that they put together in the
back for me and let's talk about it a
little bit
so we have z we're going to assign it to
my data
and it's go ahead and we're going to do
a little reshaping across all rows
or i mean across all columns so each of
the rows are going to have a little
reshaping there
and then we're going to get m which
stands for means
and we're going to apply it to my data
so again we want to go ahead and create
a
the most common variable in there
and then s is going to be sd stands for
standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with
normalization of data is we just reshape
the data everything between zero and one
so that if the lower end is eight that
now becomes zero and the upper end is
fourteen that now becomes
one that doesn't
help if it is not a linear set of data
so with this we're going to look for the
means and the standard deviation
for reshaping the data and that way the
most common values
now become the kind of like the center
point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation
to be equal amongst all of them and then
finally we go ahead and take
z and with the z we're going to reassign
it and we're going to scale
the original my data which we re shaped
based on m and based on the standard
deviation
and the 2 in here that just means we're
looking at everything
in kind of a x y kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter
control enter control enter so now we
have z
which is a scaled version of my data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu there we go
and in r this is so easy once you've
gotten to here we've done all that pre
data processing we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist so d-i-s-t
is the computation for getting the
euclidean distance
and we can just put z in there because
we've already reformatted and scaled z
to fit what we want let me go ahead and
just hit enter on that
and i'm going to widen my left hand side
again
i'm always curious what does this data
look like so let's just type in
distance which will print the variable
down below
oops you have to hit ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and i don't know about you but when i
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot
to me other than i see two three four
five six
and then you kind of have the top part 6
17 18.
so i imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
[Applause]
equal three and let's run that
oops i keep forgetting that it has to go
through the
graph on the right and we see a
different slightly different output in
here let me just open this up so we can
see we're looking at
and by cutting down the distance you can
start to see the patterns here if it's
looking at the different distances
so if i go to the top we have the
distance between one and two
one and three one and four one and five
one and six and then
two and three and so on obviously
distance between itself is zero
and it doesn't repeat the data so we
don't care to see two versus one again
because we already know the distance
between one and two
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here
and it's a little easier to read that's
why we did the print statement up here
to do digits equals three make it a
little bit smaller we could even just do
digits
oh let's just do two see what that looks
like we might lose some data on this one
if it's uh
if something's way off but we have a
nice setup and we can see the different
distances and that's what we were
computed here between each of the points
and then the whole reason we're doing
this is to get ourselves a nice
dendogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
h cluster and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances
so the age clustering does all the work
for us and then we hit enter on there
so now we have our hcl which is assigned
the h
clustering computation based on
distances and apart
and then i'm going to expand my graph
because we would like to go ahead and
see what this looks like
and we can simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs and
look at that we have a really nice
clustering
dendogram except when i look at it
the first thing i notice is it really
shows like numbers down below
now if you were a shareholder and some
data
scientist came up to you and said look
at this this is what it means
you'd be looking at that going what the
heck does 3 9 14 19
1 18 mean so let's give it some words
there
so let's do the same plot with our hcl
hc there we go and let's add in
labels and this is just one of the
commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that oops i accidentally
ran just hang my one let me
try that again there we go okay
so now you can see what it's done and
the hang my one turns it sideways that
way we can see
uh central which is central us and
kentucky
and we start to actually get some
information off our clustering setup
and the information you start looking at
is that
when we put all the information together
you probably want to look at central
america and kentucky together
oklahoma and texas has a lot of
commonality as does arizona and southern
u.s
and you can even group all five of those
florida oklahoma texas arizona
and southern u.s these regions
for some reason share a lot of
similarities
and so we want to start asking what
those similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do
is there's also we can do the dendogram
average
and this changes how we do the
clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before those are hcl we're going to
assign it
we're going to do an h cluster we're
still doing it on distance
oops distance and this time we're going
to set the method to
average so we can change the methodology
in which it computes
the values and before if you remember
correctly we did
median median's a little bit different
than means we did the most common one
and then we want the
average of the median and let's go ahead
and run that
and then we can plot and here's our hcl
oops there we go here's our hcl and i
can run that plot
and you can see this changed a little
bit so our way it
computes and groups things looks a
little different than it did before
and let's go and put the cities back in
there and do the hang
control copy let me just real quickly
copy that down here
because we want the same labels
and again you can see nevada idaho pujet
i remember we were looking at southern
u.s and arizona
texas and oklahoma florida so the
grouping really hasn't changed too much
so we still have a very similar grouping
it's almost kind of flipped it
as far as the distance based on average
has
but this is something you could actually
take to the shareholders and say hey
look these things
are connected and at which point you
want to explore a little deeper as to
why they're connected because they're
going to ask you
okay how are they connected and why do
we care
that's a little bit beyond the actual
scope of what we're working on today
but we are going to cover membership
what's called a clustering membership on
there
and let's create a member we'll just
call it number one
oops the member dot one and we're going
to assign to this
we're going to do cut tree
and cut tree
it limits it so what that means is i
take my
hc dot l in here
oops there we go dot l and so i'm taking
the cluster i just built
and we want to take that cluster and we
want to limit it to
just a depth of three so we go ahead and
do that
and run that one oops let me go run
there we go so now i've created my
member one
and then oops let me just move this out
of the way we're going to do
an aggregate and we're going to use z
remember z from above
and we're going to turn member 1 into a
list
and then we're going to aggregate that
together based on the mean let me go
ahead and
enter run that
so i did member l it's actually number
one
there we go
and if we take a look at this we now
have our group one
fixed charge and then all your different
columns listed there and most of them
should come up
kind of looking between zero and one but
you'll see a lot of variation because
we're
varying it based on the means so it's a
means the standard deviation
not just forcing it in between zero and
one
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one
setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values and
the same chart we just did oops
i made a mistake on there with my data
there we go
okay and again
we now have our actual data instead of
looking at just the
if you looked up here it's all between
zero and one and when we look down
here we now have some actual connections
and how
far distance this different data is
again
because more of a domain issue and
understanding the oil company what these
different values means
and you can look at these as being the
distances between
different items so a little bit
different
view and you have to really dig deep
into this data
we really want you to take away from
this is the
dendogram and the charts that we did
earlier
and that is the cluster output and our
nice dendogram
so this would be stage one in data
analysis of the sales
again you'd have to have a lot more
domain experience to find out what all
the individual numbers we looked at mean
and what the distance is and what's
difference between central
america and kentucky and why they're
similar and
why it groups all of central kentucky
florida oklahoma texas arizona and
southern us together into one
larger group so i'd be way beyond the
scope of this but you can see how
we start to explore data and we start to
see things in here where things are
grouped together
in ways we might not have seen before
and this is a good start
for understanding and giving advice for
sales
and marketing maybe logistics city
development there's all kinds of things
that kind of come together in the
hierarchical clustering as you begin to
explore data
and we just want to point out that we
get three clusters of regions with the
highest cells
region with average cells region with
the lowest cells
again those are some of the things that
they clustered it around and you could
actually see where things are going on
or
lacking you know it's this case if
you're the lowest cells no one wants to
be in the region of the lowest sales
welcome to this session where we will
learn
on time series analysis using our
programming language so this is
basically
a mini project where we will look at
time series data
and how we can analyze it visualize it
to basically find some important
information or gather
insights from the data now when you talk
about time series analysis
time series is basically any data set
where your values are measured
at different points in time so
when you talk about time series data
data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example
hourly weather measurements you have
daily counts of website visits monthly
sales total
and so on so when you talk about time
series
that can also be irregularly spaced and
sporadic
for example time stamped data in
computer systems
event log or history of 9 11 emergency
calls
now when we work with time series data
for example here i am taking a energy
data set
we can see how techniques such as time
based indexing
resampling rolling windows can help us
explore variations
in electricity demand and renewable
energy
supply over time now here we will look
at some aspects
of this data set which i am considering
so there is this is open power systems
data
set and here is the data set i have
we can look at the data set now this is
in a simple format it has
time it basically has values for
consumption
and then you have data for wind and
solar and wind plus solar so
in certain cases you have only the
date and the consumption but then if we
scroll down
we will also find data for wind
solar wind plus solar and so on so this
is a time series data set
which we would want to work on sometimes
you may also have the data collected
which just
does not have the time but it may also
have
time stamp that is it would have say
hour minutes and seconds and that can
also be worked upon
so let's consider this data set and
let's work on this
project where we will analyze this time
series
data set now here we can work
on this time series data we can
basically create some data structures
out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data
look at some frequencies and also do
some trend detection
now when you talk about this data set it
has electricity production and
consumption
which is reported as daily totals in
gigawatt
hours and here are the columns of the
data which i was just showing you so you
have data
you have consumption you have wind you
have solar
and wind plus solar so this is the data
we have
and we will basically explore say
electricity consumption
and production in germany which has
varied over time
so some of the questions which we can
answer
here is when is electricity consumption
typically highest and lowest
how do wind and solar power production
vary with seasons of the year
what are the long-term trends in
electricity consumption
solar power and wind power how do wind
and solar power production compare with
electricity
consumption and how has this ratio
changed over time
we can also do wrangling or cleaning of
this data or pre-processing of data
and create a data frame and then we can
visualize this
now let's see how do we do that so i
will open up my r
studio and let's look at the data set
so here is the data set now i'm picking
it up from my machine
you can also pick it up from github so
all the data sets or similar data sets
can be find in my github
repository and here i can look
in the data sets you will find
a lot of different data sets here there
are some time series data sets such as
power i can search for power or you
have basically coal
or you have this
opsd germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on
now to get the documentation on this
project
you can also look in my github
repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and
r and here there is a project folder
where i have given the documentation
sample data set
and also your time series analysis
related
document this is also the code which you
can directly import in your r studio and
you can
practice or work on this project so
let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame
from this data set now here if you see i
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading
of each column i am also giving
row.names and i am specifying
date so there is this date column in the
data set
as i showed you earlier let's look at it
again so you have date
consumption wind solar wind plus solar
so you can suggest that date should
become the
index column which can be useful so you
can do this
now let's just create this
let's look at what does this data frame
contain
and here if you see it shows me some
data which has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure
it starts with consumption wind solar
wind
plus solar and if you see this one is
becoming my
index column so i can always do a head
and look at part of the data frame using
head or tail so look at the first
records so let's see this now that shows
me the head data
i can also do a tail and look at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we
have wind solar wind
dot solar and that basically has
n a values so there are missing values
but let's look at the tail
and that tells me that there is some
data available for wind and solar and
wind solar now we can always look in a
tabular format using
view and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are
values in these columns we see any
values but if i really scroll
down i can see some values which would
be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so
i can just use view now i can look at
the dimensions
of this particular object and that tells
me
there are 400 4384
rows and four columns you can always
look at the structure that is check the
data type of
each column which can be very useful so
if i see here
i don't see the date column because date
column was considered
as an index which can be useful but i
also look at my other columns
they are of the num types so that's the
data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if i try to
do this
this will show me that this is null
because date
as a column does not exist because we
created it as an index
so if i look at row names and then
i search for my data show me the index
column or row.names
it tells me these are the values that's
the date column
which we are seeing here now we can
access a specific row
by just doing a my data and give the
index
value or row name value so let's look at
that
and that shows me based on this index
you're looking at the value
you can obviously search for a different
date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector
and you can give range of values so that
is
0 1 2006 to 4
of january and we can look at this one
so it shows me
these are the values so here actually
i'm not giving a range but i am just
selecting
multiple values from row.names now
we already know that in r you have a
summary function
so you can always do a summary and that
gives you
for each column it gives you minimum
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values
so we are looking at consumption we are
looking at
wind solar and wind dot solar
now this is good but then if i would
want to really visualize the data
access the data do some analysis then it
would be good to
take all the columns and then we can
later decide to change the data type
of say date column if we want to use it
so earlier i was using date as
row.names or the name of the rows or
index what you call in any other
programming language so here
i will just use my data set and i'll say
header is true
i'm calling it mydata2 let's look at the
data
and this one shows me five
columns where in my first column is the
date consumption wind solar and so on
now looking at the structure so let's
look at
the data type so it tells me that
if now i'm interested in looking at the
date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor
with four 384 levels and these are the
values
so it is not in a date time format it is
a factor
now what we can do is we can convert
this into a date format how do we do
that
so let's have a variable x and i'm going
to use as dot date function
and i'm going to pass in my date column
so that's
assigned to x now let's look at the head
of x
and it shows me the values we will also
see what kind of class it is
and we will look at the structure of x
so class already says it is date
type and look at the structure so it
shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into x now how do i
basically extract values out of it or
make it a part of data frame so first
i will use so all once it has been
converted
in date format i will go for as dot
numeric
and here i will create a variable called
year and i will just do a format on x
which is basically of date type and then
i am saying
percentage y so that will get me the
year component out of this let's look at
the values
that shows me year component now
similarly
we can get the month out of this and
then basically look at the month values
we can get the day out of it and we can
get the
day component now if i look at my data
2 which we had created earlier this
basically had
date consumption wind solar wind solar
so what i can do is i can add these
extracted columns such as year
month day to my data frame
using a c byte that is column bind and i
will assign it to my data to again
so let's do this and now if you look at
head
it shows me date so that should be date
format
consumption now this one might not be
date format but we'll see
you have consumption wind solar and we
have extracted the year month and day
which can help us
for group by we can do some aggregations
we can do a plotting
and we can do various things by these
additional columns
now let's look at first three rows here
so i'll say one is to three
for my data two and that shows me some
data here
you can always go ahead and look at the
sample of data
so that basically shows me month day
your columns and then you have your date
now
what we can do is we would want to
visualize this data
we would want to basically understand
the consumption
now as i said if we want to visualize
the data
say for example i want this which is
consumption of data
over years and this one is in terms of
gigawatts per hour as we were mentioning
here
gigawatt hours so if i would want to
create this visual
to basically understand the pattern of
the data
how do we do it so we can you create a
line plot
of full time series of germany's
electricity consumption
using the plot method now how do we do
that
so here one of the option is i can
straight away use the plot method
i can then say what would be in my
x-axis
what would be on my y-axis what would be
the type
of graph i would want to plot
what is my name on x-axis y-axis
and this is the simplest way so i am
saying my data 2
i am extracting the year column and here
i am taking the consumption so let's
create a plot
and here if you see we are looking at a
plot
we do see some tick times and we see
that the data has been divided with
every two years so from 2006 onwards to
2016
but then really this data does not give
me
uh you know a very useful way of looking
at the rate or understanding it
might be what i can do is i can use the
same way
but i can give apart from x-axis and
y-axis
i can say that limits
that is x limit is 2006 to 2018
and y-limit is from 800 to 1700
so we can do this and let's look at this
again
this is a plot but it really does not
help me in visualizing and understanding
the data so what are the better options
i can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window
so if you would want to have multiple
plots you can always change the value
here
and make it two or three that will say
how many rows and how many columns so as
of now we will just keep it as it is
bar mfro now
if i would want to plot i can straight
away give the column name
so i am interested in getting the
consumption
now i can just do a plot i'll say
mydata2
and i will choose the second column
which is consumption
which we saw here from our data so
consumption was the second column so i
can just do a plot in a straight away
way without mentioning
your x-axis y-axis limits and so on
and if you look at this this one is
giving me
a pattern now here i am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph
and we are looking at the data it does
show me some kind of pattern but
might be we can make it more meaningful
so i can do it this way
where i say my data second column let's
give
access as year x axis y axis is
consumption
now that has changed the x axis
and y axis now i can also give some more
details i can say
type should be line i have the line
width
i'm saying color is blue and let's do
this
so this looks more meaningful might be
shows a wavering pattern
of consumption over years i can also
give a limit of x
that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that
and we can be more specific and saying x
limit should be 2006 to 2018
and let's look at this now this one once
you have given a proper limit
it shows the line graph and it shows
what was the consumption
in 2006 and over a period till 2018
i can then use any of these options are
fine but it depends on what
and whom you are presenting the data or
what kind of analysis you are doing
so i can do a plot i can choose column
second
x lab which is x axis y axis
type is line width giving x limit y
limit
and then i'm giving a title to this
which is consumption graph
and then basically you are looking at
the line graph now
those are the options which you can do
either you could
be very specific or you could just
give your column which you want to plot
or obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details
now what we can do is if we would want
to look at
this data and understand it better
rather than just looking at a simple
line
i can take the log values so here i am
saying log
of my data to second column so i'm
taking log values of consumption
and i'm taking the difference of logs so
i can say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it
by some number so rest remains the same
i'm changing the color and let's look at
this plot
and you see this basically is giving me
a better pattern which makes meaning
here we see the log values
so this is you are using a simple plot
function
in r you can also use ggplot
now for that we can install the ggplot
package it's already there in my machine
so i'll say no
i will access this by using the library
gg plot
2 and now i can use gg plot to plot
so the way you specify here
you can say mydata2 that's the data
frame
i am saying type as o and when i am
saying line
i am basically going to use x axis
which is here y is consumption and let's
look at this plot
so again we are back to the one which we
were doing earlier really does not make
any sense
gives us some data but then really does
not give me
enough information i can
in my aesthetics i can say x as year y
is consumption
i can do a grouping and then i can give
line
and plot so again we have some
information but
really does not help me right now let's
look at
other example so i'm just doing the same
thing
here and i am looking at line type being
dashed
i'm using the gg plots other methods
such as geom line and gm
point to give me more information and if
i look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but
i would still prefer the way we were
doing with plot
now we can change the color and
obviously
add details to it so what we see is when
you use the plot method
which i did earlier it was choosing
pretty good
tick locations that is every two years
and labels the years for the x axis
which was helpful right but with these
data points which we were seeing here
or say for example this one
or say this one or say
this one we are looking at some data but
then
that really is quite crowded
and it is hard to read you can look at
the values but then
it really does not give you enough
information so
we can go for plot method but then we
will
see how we can consider different data
now
if i would want to plot the solar and
wind
time series so let's see how do we do
that
so wind column is what i'm interested in
so first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum
and the maximum values in every column
so i am saying minimum
i'm saying let's put in here my data
2 and then let's look at
the values so we are looking at the
columns
we know consumption is the second column
wind is the third column
and you have solar as the fourth and
this one is the fifth
so let's say let's find out the minimum
of each of these columns which we would
want to plot
so let's say minimum of data third
column
and here i'm also saying remove the
n a values because we do not want to
consider the any values
so let's let look at the minimum that
shows me 5.7757
what is the maximum value it is 826 so
that also helps me in giving a limit
if i want to plot wind on y axis i can
give a y limit from
5 to 850 consumption wise let's find out
the minimum from second column
and maximum and similarly for solar find
the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot
multiple graphs or give some limits
so that's fine now for multiple plots as
i said
instead of having one plot let's plot
consumption and
wind and solar and try to see a pattern
so i can say par function and i will say
three rows and one column so now
when i start plotting you will see you
will have multiple plots in one single
window so let's see how we do it
so here let's look at
plot one so this one is consumption
as we did earlier and let's look at the
data
so that gives me some data you can
always do a zoom
and you can look at the data you can
basically expand this graph
or you can reduce this graph to see
what kind of pattern we have in
consumption similarly
we can basically choose date
being x-axis my consumption being y-axis
right so this is being more specific
because here we have a
range but it really does not give me
enough information
so i will basically give x axis
y axis i will give the name that is
daily totals
and then i will basically give
consumption color
and y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits
so let's do this and now we can
look at the data here so let's see this
data
makes a little more meaning because we
are looking at the dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates
it shows me the data points it shows me
how the data
pattern is changing for consumption
now this is for consumption so what we
can do is
we can also extract specific data
so if you see here i have done some
testing
where i am saying okay i would want to
get a date specifically
i would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but
if you remember we did not change the
data type
we just changed the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it
it would be good if we can convert a
column into date time format and put
that in our data frame
now let's look at the plot2
this is mainly for your
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so
here i see it is solar data and i can
plot this one
to see how it looks like and that tells
me from 2006
onwards we have some pattern i can
be more specific where i say i would be
giving date
and then the column for solar
x-axis y-axis what is the type what is
the
y limit and what is the color it is
always good to specify your x and y-axis
given name
rather than let it automatically pick up
now this makes more meaning
because it shows me some dates similarly
we can do for
wind so either you do it just by giving
the column
or you give your x and y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose
plot three this one we can choose plot
two
we can choose plot one and we can put
all that data
in one graph so that's when you are
putting in multi
plots in one particular graph you can
always do a zoom
you can always look at the data right
and this is usually
useful to look at the pattern what kind
of pattern we see
what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window
and let's basically plot time series in
a single year
so what we have seen is that when you
look at the plot method it was quite
crowded
then we looked at solar and wind and if
you compare that
you will see your consumption pattern
your solar pattern your wind pattern
and basically we can see from this
particular data some kind of pattern
so electricity consumption is highest in
the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in winter or is it in
summer we can see that
by breaking a year further into
months we can see that but we see a
pattern
which goes for every year or every two
years being highest at a particular
point of time and then it drops down so
electricity consumption is highest in
winter and that might be due to
electrical
heating and increased lighting usage
and lowest in summer now when you look
at electricity consumption
appears to split into two clusters we
can always look at the consumption
one with oscillation centered roundly
around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at 1400 gigawatts
and you see
all the values here which are in that
particular
consumption another with fewer and more
scattered data points sentry
roughed around one one five zero so if
you really expand this you can see
you will have lot of data points at this
point
now we might guess that these clusters
correspond with
weekdays and weekends which we can see
if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production
that is highest in summer when sunlight
is most evident
and lowest in winter so obviously when
you are making or gathering some
insights when you're looking at the data
you are also using your domain knowledge
your business knowledge
your you know knowledge of business to
understand how this goes
if you look at wind power production
that's again highest in winters
and drops down in summer so due to
stronger winds
and more frequent storms and lowest in
summer
so there is some kind of increasing
trend in wind power production over
years which we can see here over the
years
and all the time series data what we are
looking at
is referring or showing us some kind of
seasonality
that is we are looking at seasonality in
which a pattern is repeating again and
again at regular times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption
solar and wind time series that
oscillates between
high and low values on a yearly time
scale which we can break down and see
i'll show you that
it corresponds with the seasonal changes
in weather over the year
so seasonality does not have to
correspond with meteorological reasons
for example if you look at retail sales
sales data
that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in
particular months so seasonality when we
say
can occur on other time scales so the
plots what we are seeing
here they are fine but if you look at
those plots they might
show some kind of weekly seasonality
also
so in your consumption corresponding to
weekdays and weekend so
let's plot for one single year
now how do i do that so first is i will
look at my data two
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is factor
other columns which are all numerics now
like we did earlier i'll repeat this
step where i'm going to convert the date
column
into date type look at head of it
look at class of it look at the
structure of
it right and then what i want to do is i
want to
add this and to my
data frame so i will create a variable
called mod data
and this one will have as data and i'm
formatting
the value of x which is date time into
month
day and year so let's do that and now
you look at the mod data which i created
like modified data
so this is the format i have it is in
date type
if you carefully see here and then i can
look at the head of it
so it saves me more data now
we are what we did here is when i said
mydata3
so mydata3 we did a
c bind and i did a mod data which is
going to add this
column to my other columns of my data
too so my new data frame
is my data 3 let's look at the structure
of it
and you see there is this date column i
can delete it i can remove it i can let
it be right so that depends on our
choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular
year now how do you do that so this is
some wrangling
so i will say mydata4 let's call it
mydata4
and i will use subset function so subset
will work on mydata3
that's the data and what i'll do is i
will do a subset
how does how is the subset found so i'll
say
take the mod data column the value
should be
greater than or equal to 2017
and should be less than 2017 december
31st so i'm getting data for one year
and i'm storing it as my data
four let's get the head of it
and you see we are specifically looking
at 2017
related data now let's do a plotting of
this
where i will only create a plot for one
year
so i'm saying my data for that's my new
data what we got so
here i am going to take the first column
which is mod data i am going to take the
third column which is consumption so i
am looking at the date format for one
year
consumption values for it and then rest
of the things as we have done earlier
let's look at the plot and this makes
more meaning
right so when you look at this plot it
tells me
jan to jan it shows me some kind of
pattern
where i have divided the year into
months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so jan and march and may
and july and so on but we still see a
pattern and that gives me
good understanding of pattern where i've
broken it down
into months so this is
where you have taken time series in a
single year to investigate further and
this is what we see
right now we can clearly see there are
some weekly
oscillations what one more interesting
feature
is that at this level of granularity
that is when you're looking at yearly
data
there is a drastic decrease in
electricity consumption
in early january and late december
during the holidays so probably we can
assume that this is holidays
now i can zoom in further and look at
just
jan and feb data let's see how we do
that
and let's see how we work by zooming in
the data further
so to zoom in the data further let's see
how we do it
now here we have this my data 4
which is basically having a subset right
so let's work on this one so i will say
my data 4 which
earlier i was taking data 3 i was doing
a subset and i was giving the
date but this time i will make it more
narrower so i'll say mydata4 i will say
subset from mydata3 and i will choose
mod data column which we have
modified with the date format i will
choose the starting date as
1701 that is jan
and then let's go till feb and let's
create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me
we have the data which is jan and then
you you can basically look at more on
this
now again as i said earlier let's find
out the minimum
of this from the first
column so that is basically your mod
data so let's look into this one
and that basically will give me minimum
and maximum let's look at the values so
this one tells me jan
17 january 1 and maximum
is your
feb 28 second month 2017. so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the y minimum so this is i
will look at
column three now what is column three
consumption so let's look at the minimum
value for consumption maximum value of
consumption
let's look at the values which can be
given as our limits
now this is the minimum and maximum now
let's do a plotting
for this data which has been narrowed
down
for consumption based on my data so i'm
saying
my first column which is mod data and
then third column which is consumption
i'm giving some naming convention for
sorry namings for your x-axis y-axis
what is my consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then
you see i'm using x limit to give the
minimum and maximum limit
and y limit so let's look at this data
and if you
look at this data it is specifically for
two months and again i can look at the
pattern here
what i can also do is i can add some
grid here
so i can basically look at this data and
make
more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see
now i can add a line here using ab line
and then i can basically choose what
lines i would want to add
horizontally so that basically allows me
to dissect the data and look at data in
a more meaningful way
i can also add vertical lines
so vertical lines is i'm saying sequence
will be minimum
maximum and i'm saying an interval of
seven
so let's do this and this basically has
added some lines
every week and you can see at the end of
week it is dropping
and then it is starting again it peaks
somewhere in the
middle of the week and again it drops
down
so this is you're looking at your
consumption data
right now what we can also do is we can
create some box plots so when we looked
at
zooming in data for jan and feb you can
add some data points like this
so consumption is highest on the
weekdays as i
showed you here and lowest on the
weekends so this is what we are seeing
when we are breaking the data or zooming
it further for a couple of months
so we have vertical grid lines and we
have
nicely formatted tick labels that is jan
first and 15th
feb first and so on so we can easily
tell which days are weekdays and
weekends
with use of these grid lines and
basically breaking it down
so there are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns
you're trying to explore you can use
scatter plots you can use heat maps you
can just use histograms and so on
now moving further we would want to
explore the seasonality
right so when you further explore the
seasonality of our data
we can use box plots basically to group
the data by different time periods
and display the distribution for each
group
now how do we do that let's come here
and let's see how box plot works so i
can just do a simple box plot
and i can choose my consumption column
and that gives me
just the consumption data but this
really does not give me any meaning i
can look at solar data
i can look at the wind data and we can
also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if
we would want to do a box plot what is
box plot it is basically a visual
display of your phi
number summary that is you want to look
at your mean
median you want to look at your 25th
percentile 50 percentile
or 75th percentile so we can use a
quantile
function use the consumption column and
then
you basically give a vector which shows
you find number summary
so that's your quantile and then let's
do
a box plot so if you are looking at
quantile it tells me what is the minimum
what is 25th percentile 50 75th and 100
that's from my consumption column
so let's create a box plot for
consumption
let's give it a name as consumption
let's give y axis as consumption and a
limit
for y-axis now that's my consumption
graph
so i can look at yearly data now that
will make more meaning
rather than just looking at the complete
consumption data
so how do we do it early so we will say
consumption
and then i will say the year column so
it is
consumption but grouped based on year
so here i can give x axis y axis
and i can give y limit so let's create
this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here
but now i'm looking at 2006 2007
8 9 and so on and we can look at the
data what is the range
right it gives me five percentile or
sorry
five number summary of the data per year
and it basically allows me to look at
the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot
by just giving consumption yearly group
and here i am giving the title as
consumption
y-axis x-axis
and y-limit wherein i can also use
less so this is one more feature which
you can do
and that basically will give me the tick
points
if you compare this one to the previous
graph
so when i created this previous graph i
had 2006 2008
and i had from 600 to 1800
and if i go for the next one i am
basically seeing more
useful information now let's look at
monthly data
so i would want to group it based on
months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data
where i'm looking at months and i could
select
a particular year or i can just do a
grouping based on months
so i can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this
now let's create a box plot for
consumption
which is monthly data and let's give it
a color
let's look at the wind data which is
again grouped monthly
and let's look at the solar data which
is grouped monthly
now if i zoom in it basically
gives me the seasonality of the data
for your wind for your consumption for
your solar
so what we are doing is we are creating
these box plots
which are giving us values
now what i can also do is i could look
at
the day wise also but before we look
into this
how do i infer some information from
these box plots which are being
created so this is what we have done
where we are looking at
the data for month and these box plots
give me ear seasonality which we were
seeing in earlier plots but
give some additional insights so if i
look at
the data here it tells me the
electricity consumption
is generally higher in winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in winters and
lower in summer so we can obviously look
at
our plot we can see where it is lower
where it is higher
and then we can look at
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in december
and january compared to november and
february so that is
you look at the quartiles and you will
see
that the median and lower two quartiles
are lower in december
and january here jan
and december so you can look it from my
plot
now this is giving you some idea on
seasonality
now that might be due to business being
closed over holidays
now this one we were also seeing when we
looked at time series for 2017
only and box plot basically confirms
that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at your solar and wind
power production
both will give you a year seasonality
what we are seeing here and
if basically i look at the data so
it depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar
it will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme
wind speeds associated with storms and
other transient and
since we are grouping it based on months
we can see
this pattern is quite evident every year
now what we can do is we can group the
data
day wise so here let me again reset this
to one plot per graph now i'll say box
plot
i'll say consumption which is group
based on day now we know that there is a
day column
and let's give a while limit and let's
look at the data
so this is where i'm grouping the data
day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot
so this is where you are plotting it on
a
daily basis so you can look at the data
you can break it down to
a particular week so here i have given
a day and i have chosen all the 31 days
but i can break it down to
a week and i can look at the data so if
we look at the data per week
or per day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption where i'm doing
a consumption group by day
is higher on weekdays than on weekends
so time series with strong seasonality
can often be represented with models
that can decompose
signal into seasonality and long trend
now this is an easy way now how do we
look at the frequency of the data that
could be interesting to see
so let me look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here
we have looked at data so what we will
do is we look at the frequency now when
you look at the frequency
when you talk about frequency in your
data so we have the modified date column
which gives me a frequency and if we
really look into the data that will tell
me
that the data is on a daily basis
so for that let's look at my data 3
again
which gives me data and you can just see
all the data's
data or dates are in sequence so you're
22 23 24 25
26 and so on i can look at i can access
a d player package
that is basically allowing me to work
in a better way now i can look at the
summary of this
and for all my columns i am seeing
what is the minimum phi number summary
date and consumption so date does not
show me anything because this is not in
a date format it is just a factor
but other things have the fine number
summary so we are looking at win plus
solar
we are looking at year and month and day
and all these columns
now what we will do is we will
want to find out the sum of each
column how many entries does it have and
we will say the value should
any value should not be considered so
let's look at this one
so it tells me for my particular columns
so let me run this again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have
and these counts
do not include the n a values now
similarly i can find out specifically
for consumption
i can find out is there any n a value so
i'm
saying is dot n a and let's find out if
there is any
n a value or missing value in
consumption
it says zero okay that's good if you
look in wind
it tells me there are 1463 entries which
are
any similarly solar similarly
wind dot solar or wind plus solar so it
gives me a count of n a values
that is missing values and also
values which are not missing so to
understand frequency what we can do is
we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the first column and
i am saying
that rm na dot r m
is true that is get rid of n a values
and find out the minimum
and let's look at the minimum value this
is the minimum from my modified date
now if i would want to get the frequency
i can basically use sequence function
so i can say from x minimum that is the
minimum value
i want to look at the frequency that is
day wise
and let's just look at five entries
and see if there is a day by day
frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me
there is device frequency so that allows
me to look at the frequency look at the
type of it it is an integer
class is a date so similarly
we can say from x minimum we can
basically
look at the frequency month-wise and
i can again look at five records so that
shows me
monthly data right so i can
extract the data for frequency similarly
yearly data
and that's also very useful now
we can select data which has n a values
for
wind so how do i do it i would want to
find out
the wind column and i want to find out
where the values are in a so
i will create a variable and here i will
say
my data 3 and then i give a conditional
where i say
is na in the column
so let's do this now once i've done this
once i've done this i have said that my
selected wind data from my data 3 where
we said
n a values and i will give the names
to this so name should be in my data 3 i
am interested in mod data
consumption wind and solar so these are
the four columns i'm interested in
let's look at first 10 records here or
first 10 rows
so that tells me these are the values
where wind
has n a or missing values
i can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data
so it basically shows me 1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at
all the way to the end and it shows me
wind has n a
solar does have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have a difference so you
have 1 4 six one and then you have two
one seven
four so there is a difference so there
is some data
in between where wind has some values
so we have found out n a values now what
we will do is we will select data which
does
not have any values so i will call it
cell
selected wind2 i'll again use mydata3
i will say which but now i'm saying not
any from this column and i will select
the data
for the columns so i am interested in
looking at
10 records and this shows me not any
value so
no more missing values so if i really
look
at this data as i saw earlier which has
n a
and if i look at these values which are
not any for the wind column
so looking at these two result we will
know that
in year 2011 wind column
has some missing values so let's
focus on year 2011. so how do i do that
let's call it a different variable i'll
say mydata3
i will say here when i say which where
we were saying
na here i will say the year should have
a value of 2011
and i want all these columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
we are not seeing all the values so
there are some values
but then there are some missing values
also for 2011 based on whatever analysis
we have done
so let's look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame
do a view and this one will help me in
finding out where
are the n a values so if you just scroll
down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column
has a n a or a missing value
and i will see if there is any missing
value in which column or which
row it is for the wind column so we have
all the values which are existing i
could
select and search for one specific value
and i'll show you how we can do that
so here let's scroll all the way down so
it's like you're exploring your data
and seeing is wind column
having n a or missing value for a
particular row and
let's scroll here and here you see there
is a missing value for one particular
row so
13th december 2011
has wind value 15 december has wind
value but
your 14th december does not have right
similarly we can search
so there was only one entry which was
missing
now that could be for some reason might
be it was not calculated might be it was
not tabulated
so we have a missing value and that can
affect my plotting that can affect my
analysis so
let's look at the number of rows in this
which will tell me how many rows we have
for 2011. so it tells me 365 so that is
basically the number of days in a year
now we will find out if
there were any values so we earlier
checked total number of na values
per column that is
in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269.
so this is where we were seeing are
there any n a values
right so let's go back here
and we want to find out the number of n
a values for a particular year how do i
do it
so i can just do a sum i will say is n a
now i am interested in my data 3 wind
column
and i am saying my year has to be 2011
but i am finding out the
n a values so let's do this
and it tells me 1 and that's right
that's
what we saw when we did a view let's see
how many
non-na values you have and that is 364.
so that
basically satisfies my logic so it's 364
plus 1 missing so there are 365
let's look at the structure of this it
tells me you have modified date and date
format
you have consumption wind and solar
now let's create a variable
selected wind four i will save in 3
that is which was having all my n a and
non n a values for 2011 i will say
let's find out the n a value
because i'm interested in finding out
that particular row
so i'm saying find out where the value
is n a
and i want all the columns let's look at
this one
and this is my specific
row which has a n a value
now we know that data follows a device
frequency
which we have clearly seen now let's
select data which has
n a and non-na values so
let's say let's call it test 1 i will
use win3 which
has any non na values but now
i will say i want the modified date
which should be greater than 12 12
2001. now remember we had when we were
doing a view we saw that one particular
day
or what we see here 14th of december
there is no date so i will select a
subset of data
which includes this n a and non n a
that is might be i can take 13th of
december and 15th of december so let's
start from 12
12 so the date should be greater than 12
12 that means 13th
and it should be less than 16 so that is
15th and
the columns right so now we have some
data let's look at this
so i have a i've selected a subset of
data i could have done this using subset
also
so i have any and non-any values
now why are we doing this so sometimes
you might have some data for a
particular column
and you may want to find out if there
are any missing values might be you want
to fill them up or replace them with
something
so that is usually useful when you are
doing a trend detection
so say for example you have data for
every month
and might be in one one of the months
you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly
and then in one of the years for couple
of months you don't have the data
like i can say 2016 i have data for all
12 months
2017 all 12 months 2018
might be i don't have data from march
and june
2019 i don't have data for same months
so i can forward fill or backward fill
them
using the previous year's same month
data
so we can do that so here i have test
data where i've extracted a subset of
data
i can look at the class of this it is a
data frame
structure of this it has the columns now
let's
use the library and function and use the
tidy
r package and what we will do is we will
fill it up so i will use test one i will
fill the wind
column which has a missing value now
once you do this
if you notice it has done a forward
fill so it has taken the previous value
and it has just filled up that so
you can fill up the data using different
directions such as
up and down left and right and so on
so we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at
some more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward filled
so filling values can be done in
different directions as i said
and you may want to first convert your
time series
to specified frequency if your data does
not have a frequency but we had
now if you do not have a frequency might
be you can convert it into a frequency
such as weekly
daily monthly as i showed you and then
basically
you can do a forward fill
for the value so for example if i have
my data i can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data i
can use a forward fill
so that can take care of my frequency
data
then let's look at the trends
of the data which is the last part of
this project
so basically let's look at the trend so
when you say trend what does that mean
so in time series data you always have
some kind of trend
so that will exhibit some slow gradual
variability in addition to higher
frequency variability such as
seasonality and noise
now to visualize these trends
what we do is we use what we call as
rolling means
so we know how our data is spread
over year or month or day but how about
looking at a rolling average
and see what is the difference so a
rolling mean
will tend to smooth a time series by
averaging out the variations and
frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called those
windowing
where you can choose a set of time frame
you can also average out any seasonality
on a time scale equal to window size so
this will allow you to look at lower
frequency variation in the data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series
we already saw there is a weekly pattern
there is a yearly seasonality which we
saw
using box plots so we can also look at
the rolling means
of the time scales how do we do that so
for this
you can use some package like zoo
and then you can basically use a rolling
mean
using this zoo package and you can say
what
is the frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean
now how do we do this let's look at this
data
so here i'm going to my look at my data
3
which we have been using so far now
let's call it a 3 day test
you can give it any name i'm going to
use my data 3
i'm using the pipe in function now
i will use d plier and i will arrange
the data
descending in here now you can always
break it down step by step and you can
see the result of this
so i'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top
you want to group the data by year so it
depends on how many years we have we'll
see
so you can group the data by year now
this data
is then used to basically mutate so
mutate function is going to
allow me to use this rolling mean so i
will call it as
says 0 3 day so i'm going to calculate a
rolling mean
every three days for my consumption
column
and basically let's ungroup this so
let's see
how this works sorry
yeah let's look at this and here when
i'm doing a three-day test
let's look at the result of this and
then i'll explain this
so if you see here we have the test
three-day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean
so first value here what we see is 1367
is the average consumption in 2017
from the first date with the data point
on either side of it
that is you can look at this
date so 1 1 3 0 then you look at
you are looking at the value 1 3 6 7
here so you look at 1 1
3 0 1 4 4 1 1 5 3
0 if i take a mean of these so for
example if i would just do this part
and that is giving me
mean okay because i have a comment so
let's basically add
anything as comment and then let's do
this so it saves me one three six seven
that's what we are seeing here right so
you've got getting a rolling average
every three days
similarly if you want every five days it
takes the five values
and it gets the mid value right so you
can always find out the mean
rolling mean for a particular frequency
now let's do that for seven days that is
weekly data and yearly data that is 365
days
so how do i do it same logic my data
test
now i'm using my data 3 i'm arranging it
in a descending order
i'm grouping by year so when you do a
group by year so earlier when we did a
grouping by and when we looked at the
data it was telling me
how many rows we had right so let's do a
grouping by year
and let's say test 0 7 so that's a
rolling
average every 7 days and i'm also saying
take care of the n a values similarly
i'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly
might be you can do half yearly and
let's do this so let's
create this my data test and let's look
at the result of this
so i will use my data test i will say
arrange
based on modified date now we know there
is a column called modified date
i want to just look at 2017 data so i am
doing a filter
right and then i will choose what are
the columns i'm interested in
so i will look at the 7 and 365 day
and let's look at say first 7 records
so let's do this and
that basically gives me the consumption
value modified date
year and my rolling seven day average
order of seven day mean
which is for first seven days and then
365 you will not see the data here but
if i do a view on this i can basically
see the values
so you can always select a particular
column
to see the values these are the values
for every 7 day
rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days
so you see all the values are missing
but every 365
entry you will have basically some data
now let's do a plotting of this
and basically visualize this data which
we are seeing
rolling average so let me first do a
plotting
one plot per graph and let's do a
plotting
i will take consumption data
x-axis y-axis color
and give a title to this so let's create
this
and that's my consumption data which is
spread over a period of time and that's
fair enough
but now let's add some more plot to this
so i will add the seven day rolling
average to this
so for second plot to be added in the
same one
in r you can use points so i will say
points
i will choose seven data column type is
line
width x limit y limit
and color so let's do this and that's my
pattern seven day rolling average which
basically gives me some kind of trend
similarly
i can add one more here and this time i
will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern
lines so now you see some dots here well
you could do it in a different way
so i can just add legend to this and i
can say
legend will be aware in x-axis and
y-axis so i'm saying it will be 2500
and y is 1800 so my legend will come in
somewhere
here i am saying my legend will have
consumption
test and this one i can give some names
i can give what is the color
i can say what kind of
legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's
add a legend to this and i've added a
legend
now you can do a zoom and look at the
data
and here i see that
my x-axis is fine but y-axis is going a
little
out of my plotting area so i can
actually change that so here i have 1800
how about making it 1600 and let's look
at this one
so we can basically
go for this one and start again here
plot
and points and line and then add a
legend
right and you can basically place your
legend anywhere in the plot
so this basically is giving me the trend
what i'm looking at my rolling average
so similarly you can look at the trend
for wind
and solar data so what we are seeing
here
is when you look at trend this is one
more way of looking at it
you can always create plots in different
ways
so seven day rolling mean has smoothed
out
all weekly seasonality which we were
seeing here
in my graph where you look at every
seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality
so seven day will tell that electricity
consumption is typically higher in
winter
and lower in summer so better is you
break it down
yearly so here if you look at every year
you can see when is winter when is
summer
what is the seasonality what your trend
what you are seeing here
and if there is a decrease or increase
for a few weeks every winter so
similarly if you look at 365 now as you
said as i said rolling average basically
reduces the variation so if i look at
365 rolling mean
we can see long term trend in
electricity consumption is pretty flat
now that's what we are seeing it's kind
of pretty flat there is not
much variation over the years if you
really join these dots
so we can basically see
some highs and lows and that gives me a
trend
now this is how you can do a trend
detection and similarly
we can do plotting for wind and solar so
this is a
small project which i demonstrated using
r now all this code which you have here
in the form of a project dot r file you
can find here in my
github page this is a document which
explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it
this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder
so continue learning and continue
practicing
r so who is a data science
engineer are you a data science engineer
or are you going to be looking for a
different field
what exactly is a data science engineer
well a data science engineer is someone
who has
programming experience in python and r
expert level knowledge
ability to write proficient codes and
they
we have python and our i'm going to say
python or
r once you become really proficient at
one language
transferring those skills into another
one is usually fairly
easy now r is a little different because
it is an
analytics platform so going from python
to r
if you already know the data analytics
and python moving to r is pretty easy
uh now r doesn't have all the other code
that
you can access with python there's so
many things you can do with python that
are not data analytics
so it's important to keep in mind that
you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in python and really have a
solid foundation in
r or have a solid foundation in r and be
well-rounded in another programming
language where you really get the
programming side of it
strong sql and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands-on
big data experience and of course we're
showing sql here
most commonly used whether you're using
a microsoft sql server or mysql server
you can also start thinking hadoop and
spark
in big data access hadoop file system
is not a huge jump if you've already
learned your sql and you've already
learned your basics in coding
hadoop sits on top of all that and does
a wonderful job creating huge clusters
of data
but you really need to know your sql
because that is so common in most
of the large companies now accessing
their data
and an ability to visualize models and
troubleshoot code of the models
this is a kind of an interesting one
because these models
are can get very complicated so you
gotta be able to break them down
into something that you can put the
pieces together and digest each of the
pieces
so being able to visualize these models
is very important and then being able to
drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models
they need to be a versatile problem
solver equipped with strong analytical
and quantitative skills
a self-starter with a strong sense of
personal responsibility and technical
orientation
this is an interesting one because when
you talk about data science engineer
it's such a new field that most
companies don't have it well defined
they don't know what they're looking for
you might not even know what you're
looking for you might have an idea and
you're looking for patterns but where do
those patterns lead you
so you really need that self-starter
side to jump in there and figure out
where to go
and be able to communicate that back to
the team and there we go we have a
strong
product intuition data analysis skills
and
business presentation skills and this
was talking about is
you gotta bring that back to the team so
if you don't have a strong product
intuition if you don't know what's going
on with the company
what they need and where you're going
with your analysis it's gonna be a dead
end
and you gotta be able to present that to
the shareholders to
your co-workers which leads us to great
teammate with excellent interpersonal
skills
and this is kind of a strange one
because you spend so much time behind
your desk so you have to be able to kind
of float between
you're studying all the data and being
able to explain this to people
in simple terms that they can understand
no one wants somebody to come up and say
yeah the p score and the f score is this
that and the other thing
and you might have two people in the
room understand you you have to be able
to sit down and explain
what that means and why so let's take a
look at the data science skill set
we talk about data science engineer
skill set we're talking about
database knowledge statistics
programming tools
data wrangling probably the least
favorite and most used
machine learning data visualization and
then the touch on big data
and so we'll start with database
knowledge the most
common database is of course your sql
structured query language
think rows and columns it's an essential
language for extracting a large amount
of data
from data sets so knowledge of the sql
is mandatory for data science engineers
and you can see there's tools required
there's the oracle database
i mentioned my sql server microsoft sql
server
teradata there are so many different
forms of sql
and it'll just keep coming back and
coming back so if you don't have a solid
basic understanding of sql go get it
very important because it will come up
you know it's if you don't know it it's
going to bite you in statistics of
course we are you know that's what this
is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics
statistics is a subset of mathematics
that deals with collecting
analyzing and interpreting data
therefore data scientist needs to know
statistics so you need to understand
your probabilities and what that means
and what the p-score means in the
f-score and means and
mode and median all that information
standard deviation all of those you need
to
be aware of and then we get into the
programming tools
and i mentioned this earlier a little
bit but you need to master any one of
these specific
programming languages programming tools
such as r python
sas are essential to perform analytics
in
data and again you know you can move in
there and you can be an expert in just r
you can be an expert in just sas and a
little bit you can be an expert in
python
because most of these when we're talking
about data science and data wrangling
you really kind of get down to the point
where you really need to have a full
programming language
at least the basics and if you're going
to be working in
data science python right now is the
main one but you know there's also java
c
plus so you need to know a solid
language at least the basics of it so
you can understand
how to do basic iterations and things
like that i always find that interesting
that uh
my sister who runs a university data
analytics center that's the first
question she asks her
people candidate to come and work for is
how do you iterate through data you'd be
amazed at how many people don't
understand that very basic concept
in programming so when we look at r r is
a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression
association clustering and etc python
python is an open source general purpose
programming language and there's our
general purpose i was just talking about
you need to know a little bit about
python libraries like numpy and scipy
are used in data science
scipy yeah numpy and scipy are very
central to python and i'd throw pandas
in there also
that module those are very central to
working with python
and data analytics and then sas sas can
mine
alter manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources
it can perform statistical analysis on
the data
so where r is the open source platform
sas is more like the paid for
platform and so it has some things more
automated because people
are paying for it developing it but it's
also if you really start using it as a
company you're going to have to pay for
it where rs freestore
is a free software python is also open
source and free to use
so we're going to talk a little bit
about data wrangling and i mentioned
earlier that is
both the probably people's least
favorite
aspects of data science and also
probably one of the places
you spend the most time so we talk about
data wrangling it is a process of
transforming
raw data into an appropriate format to
make it useful for analytics
and it involves cleaning raw data
structuring raw data
and enriching raw data and this gets
interesting because you'll get stuck
on something like in python you might
get stuck on something that
is a date time based on an integer 64
numpy set you might not know what all
those terms mean because you work in r
or something like that but you get the
point that it's all one particular
format and then you have to figure out
how to switch it so that the computer
can see it correctly in whatever format
you're using or whatever analytics
platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression knn etc
is useful for
few job roles so this is kind of
interesting because sometimes that's the
center of the job role of a data
scientist and sometimes you just have to
be able to apply
the programming skills to it so you can
get the answer and let somebody else
fine-tune your machine learning
techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have
our nearest neighbor set up where it
groups things together that look alike
linear regression you're drawing a line
through the data or curve
so you can predict what the next value
is going to be
and then our nice decision tree which
starts splitting things up and says you
know it's sunny out yes let's go
swimming
no it's raining we're not going to go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim
it's raining we'll stay indoors yes
we'll walk the dog no so you have a
decision tree that helps
figure out how you get to the end result
so decision trees can be pretty powerful
and data visualization data
visualization is the study and creation
of visual representation of data
data visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs
plots information graphics and other
tools to communicate
information clearly and effectively this
one
you really have to master as a data
science this one you really have to
master as a data scientist
and there certainly are so many
different tools to use to visualize it
but when you're communicating a picture
is worth a thousand words
when you can put a picture up and and
people can look at and go oh
i see what's going on that's worth a lot
more than saying yeah yeah this is good
people hear that and they just kind of
go okay it's good but why
and you might say you know okay these
numbers make it look good no people want
something they can see
and there certainly is uh tabloo is
probably um
one of the most popular ones out there
caleb view
power bi google data studio
in python there's the pi kit
and seaborn there's all kinds of
different options for visualization
you need to master probably at least one
or two of them
so you understand how they work and how
they're different
and then big data big data is a massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
and processed using traditional methods
big data has various benefits like
access to social data can enable
organizations to
tune their business strategies big data
can improve customer experience
uh and so we're usually when you say big
data we're almost
always talking about hadoop and apache
spark it used to be hadoop
as your file system so that's how you
store all your data going across the
nodes and there certainly are other ways
to store it
when we talk about hadoop we're usually
talking about at least 10 terabytes of
data when you're dealing
with a hadoop file structure and then
you can use spark
where hadoop processes on and off the
hard drive so it's continually
reading and writing to the hard drive
spark is running in your ram
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process
you'll run a spark setup which will
spread those processes over multiple
computers
and of course now the two combine and
spark sits on top of hadoop and you get
your big data there's also
talent uh tabloo has its own server set
up
there's splunk uh cassandra you'll hear
the cassandra database pentaho i'm not
even sure how to pronounce that one
it's not one i've worked with certainly
there's a lot of options for big data
the two big players are of course hadoop
and spark and even your sql servers and
mysql servers will spread across
five different servers and you can be
talking about big data across five
servers with those pulling them into say
apache spark to do your high-end
processing and then there's
non-technical
skills probably the most important one
in data science and any of our data
analytics
is intellectual curiosity updating
knowledge by reading contents and
relevant books on trends in data science
this is such there's so much going on in
this field and it's exploding now
that it's hard to keep track of it all
uh so you really need to have that
curiosity
in the data science probably even more
so than a lot of other fields
but i would say in just today's world
you need intellectual curiosity
because things are changing so rapidly
in today's world the way that it's going
with our technology
understanding how the problem solved can
impact
the business business acumen this is the
one where a lot of people kind of skip
over you have to have a little business
sense
if you don't know how it's going to
impact the business you're going to be
in trouble why do they want to even pay
you to be there
unless they know what's going on and
they're getting something in return
so this is your bottom line for your
paycheck is
what's going on with the business how is
this going to impact the business what
are you doing for them
and communication skills companies look
for someone who can clearly and fluently
translate technical findings to a
non-technical team
and i've talked about this a bunch and i
i can't even iterate this enough
if you are struggling with your
communication skills
work on building them they don't have to
be you know this isn't rocket science
where you have to know all these
complicated terms what you need to do is
take the complicated terms you know from
data science
and reduce that down to something that
anybody can understand
so when you come up and you have uh you
know knn
no one knows what k n is you know unless
they're in data science
nearest neighbor looking for things that
match together you got to explain that
to people who do not have the technical
skill
in the data science arena and a data
science engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers
uh so it's teamwork and that's always
one that throws people for a loop
but ultimately you are analyzing your
customers information
and so sometimes getting in there and
rolling up your sleeves
if you're let's say you're doing data
analysis for the sales team and you're
backing a sales team
you might have to get in there and go
start making some sales and making some
phone calls and see what it's like what
is that team doing
when they call 15 people in cold calls
and then they do a follow-up two weeks
later or three weeks later which one
works better
two or three does it work better to call
and send a fax
call and send an email you know when
should you show up in person if it's
that kind of business
so working with everybody including the
customer is very important with the data
and
with this kind of setup and
non-technical skills for a data
scientist
so let's take a look at some of the
roles a data science plays in the job
market
let's drill in there just a little bit
here so when you have a data scientist
they're going to perform predictive
analysis and identify trend and patterns
that can help in better decision making
companies hiring data scientists include
apple adobe
google microsoft i would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only 100
employees
or something like that they're starting
to look at data scientists because they
need them to come in
and be a part of that team and the role
is understanding challenges of a system
and offer
best solutions this should always be the
goal of a data scientist
is to be looking at the whole system and
then trying to find those patterns that
are going to best
enhance the company or the business or
the
whatever group maybe working with the
sales team or the marketing team and you
can see languages
pretty important to have a these are a
number of different languages and again
it depends on your own specialty
there's all kinds of different
variations but we have r
sas python matlab sql hive pig
spark you should have at least a
knowledge of all of these maybe a python
programmer never used r
download it go through the basics so at
least you know what's going on in r
versus python because r is pretty
powerful for doing a very quick
display and then of course a lot of
things you can do in python you have to
be able to do queries on database from
time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce information from large
databases
and usually this is one of those things
you do at the beginning you set it up
and then you
kind of let it go until it breaks and
you have to go back and fix it because
your query isn't working that certainly
is a very common thing to
to have happen especially if you're
pulling data off the web and the
internet
and then we have some more companies
that are hiring data analysis like ibm
dhl hp and so we're talking about data
analyst
the role is responsible for a variety of
tasks such as visualization
optimization and processing large amount
of data
and so we're talking about a data
analyst we're also we're still talking a
lot of the same stuff but you'll see
we've now thrown in javascript and html
in here because that's pretty common
with the data analyst versus a data
scientist
and you can see that sql is still pretty
solid and also
cc plus is pretty big so some companies
also use
java so i'd put java in the languages
also on that for a data analyst
and then you have a data architect
ensuring that data engineers have best
tools and systems to work with and so
companies hiring a data architect are
like visa logitech coca-cola
they create blueprints for data
management with the best
security measures i cannot highlight
that a data architect really spends a
lot of time with security measures
that's big how many hacks have we seen
in the last year on large
companies have lost data for millions of
their customers and how badly that
affects them
and we're looking at languages as you
see that sql
is pretty solid across all of these
under a data architect
xml that's one that a lot of the data
science jobs don't really
you don't see as much but you're going
to see more xml with a data architect
because there's a lot of xml files that
are that have your security measures
embedded in them and of course your hive
pig those are hadoop systems we're doing
some basic queries
so instead of doing the high end queries
you know how these simplified query
systems built into hadoop
and spark so if you're using big data
you're going to want to know your spark
also
and then we have our data engineer the
data engineer
updates the existing systems with better
version of the current technologies to
improve the efficiency of the databases
think admin here a lot of work tracking
down what version you're in
of the different programs what version
of python are you using what version of
r are using what version of c plus plus
so companies hiring data engineers are
like amazon spotify
facebook and they develop construct test
and maintain
architectures such as databases and long
scale processing systems
and here we have our languages our sql
our matlab
sas spss python java ruby c plus plus
pearl hive
pig you pretty much as a data engineer
at this level when you talk about admin
and updating all these databases need to
know all the different stuff that's
being used
in the company and you're testing out
these structures to make sure they work
and so you really are talking admin
level
uh kind of setup so if you like spinning
up an admin onto
a google cloud service or amazon cloud
service
now you start to get an idea what we're
talking about because then you can test
it out up there and then you can bring
it back and update it to the company
statition creates new methodologies for
engineers to apply
and so when we look at this this is
where we're digging into the math of
which models to use
what setup's going to work what kind of
activation do we have on our neural
network
these little tweaks are going to make a
big difference
and we look for methodologies at a large
level what kind of data are we going to
be looking
at how we're going to pull it together
companies hiring a data engineer
or we're talking about stations we're
talking about linkedin pepsico
johnson and johnson and of course these
companies probably
hire a little bit of everything but they
have a lot of stations working for them
um and so we look at the role extract
and offer valuable reports from the data
clusters
through statistical theories and data
organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing sql
r matlab sas spss
data that's a new one that i've seen in
some of the other roles
python perl an older version and that
shouldn't be a surprise because a lot of
these companies probably built a lot of
the original packages on pearl if you go
look at johnson and johnson and of
course your big data
hive pig and spark and then our database
administrator
i mentioned the other one is an admin
they're more an admin level for the
software itself
so administrator is another level some
of the tasks involved are monitoring
operating and maintaining databases
installation configuration defining
schemas training users etc
and this is interesting training users
because when you build a database and
you
define all the different tables that are
embedded in that database and how
they're all connected
the end users got to have that
information otherwise you're in trouble
when we have companies hiring data
engineers
of course tabloo twitter reddit the role
ensures that all the databases are
available to all relevant
users again a little security in there
what role do they have
is allowed in and not and is performing
correctly and is being kept
safe and you better be ready to spend
some time in security
because again that's a very big thing
nowadays with the number of people who
hack into these databases
and the languages are going to be
covered you have your
c sharp your java sql ruby on rails
xml again there's that xml because a lot
of your security is embedded in xml
files
um python all the main players depending
on what the company's using
data and analytics manager so when you
see manager that means that somebody's
going to sit on top
and organize the people underneath so
they're going to improve the business
process
as an intermediary between business and
i t
oh you better have some really good
communication skills for this one
uh some of the companies hiring a data
engineers are coursera
motorola slack and of course these
companies are hiring data scientists in
almost all of these fields
so the role oversees the data science
operations
and assigns the duties to the team
according to skills and expertise
so that's a big one you better be able
to communicate what's going on help your
team members
come out and be able to communicate with
other people so sometimes your job is
just being able to get people to talk to
each other the big thing on that
is is the whole communication line going
from one end to the other
because you can't communicate all the
information that everybody's working on
you have to pretty much come in there
and help people communicate what there's
going on
and also know what they're up to without
being micromanagement
because that will crash a company if you
micromanage everybody but if you just
let them do whatever they want and they
never talk to each other that will also
destroy the company you got to find that
nice middle ground and you really have
to have an overview
of everything as a data and analytics
manager
one of the things i mean you know it's
good to have at least one or two
solid bases of programming under your
belt for a data analytics manager
but you do need to have a very general
understanding of all the different tools
being used so that you know what's going
on with your different team members
of course sqlr sas java python matlab
all of those are big
business analytics so this is when
you're talking about your
bi or your business intelligence and
your business analytics
very important to know this is kind of a
subdivision of a lot of the other stuff
we've talked about a lot of the other
roles we've looked at
so you possess specialized knowledge of
their business domain
and apply that knowledge and analysis
specifically to the operation
of the business so you might be a
specialist in banking
you might be a genetics engineer
so you know about genetics you might
just be general business
um helping the marketing so a lot of
companies hiring data engineer
oracle uber dell and the role act is a
link between the data engineers and the
management
executives so it's very similar to when
you go back up here we look at data
analytics manager a business and
analytics is going to also kind of fill
that role in between
but they're more specialized in business
and you better know sql because we're
talking about a business specifically
most of the large companies are storing
their data that's
up and running right now that people are
accessing to purchase something on the
home depot website or
the uber they're logging in you better
know your sql it's very central to
business analytics so let's go ahead and
take a look at the data science engineer
salary trends and you'll see that our
source is glass door as we're pulling a
lot of our data from
average base pay is around 117 000
in the u.s the average salary and we
look at india we're talking about
950 000 a year and those are based on
some of them you need to go ahead and
dig deeper to find out what education
level versus entry level
but those are pretty solid base once
you're in the industry and once you
created your career in there and we look
at the job titles the most common
job title is data scientist business
intelligence manager is the second
greatest one that's kind of good to note
that's why they put that up there as
being its own little subcategory of data
science managers a business intelligence
manager because it's such a high
level of jobs and then we looked at some
of the other ones data architect
business intelligence architect again
your bi
your business intelligence gets its own
ranking because it's such
a high level you know it's a business
people want their businesses to make
money so that's who's hiring
of course data engineer business
intelligence developer
business intelligence consultant
business intelligence analyst
business analyst and data analyst so you
can look at the data analysis being the
general one that doesn't go specific to
business
so if you're looking just for your
career as far as getting a job
probably should have some kind of
business understanding in the background
and again
you know your companies want to make
money so they're going to hire someone
who knows business if
banking business if you specialize in
banking or retail if you specialize in
retail and marketing and you can see
here on the data science salary trends
and the growth and data science job
listings it's continually going up it's
um
since 2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400
to 600
that's a pretty big increase so you know
a huge growth in this market it's one of
the biggest growing markets
right now for jobs and careers so let's
go ahead and take a look at uh
building a resume always exciting
putting ourselves out selling ourselves
and if you looked at some of our other
videos dealing with
resumes you'll see a trend here uh the
top part
is so different than what resumes were
in the 90s
uh in the 2000 to 2010
they've evolved they've really evolved
it used to be
two 2000 2010 maybe linkedin
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references
this is a sales tactic which now has
come into resumes
used to be that if you're a real estate
agent every real estate agent i knew i
used to deal with real estate software
for
the real estate industry back in the 90s
every real estate agent won their
picture
on their business card they wanted them
their picture if they could
put on their contracts they want people
to see the face
so that's really a big change is to make
sure that it stands out
you stand out here's a picture of
somebody so you're more than just a
couple letters and a name but of course
you need your contact information should
always be at the top
uh you have your summary what are you
focusing on
be a little careful with your summary
because if you have
everything in your summary and then they
scroll down to experience and education
and skills
they're going to stop the second you
repeat yourself in your resume
that usually means to the reader hey
this person doesn't have anything more
to offer me i'm done
so be a little careful how you word your
summary most
companies appreciate when you come in
here
and you've adjusted this summary to be
both about you
and how you're going to serve that
company so it's worth
researching that company to find out how
those connect
and put that in the summary take some
time to do that that's actually a pretty
big deal
and the references are huge also
especially in data science
when you're talking about any of the
programming or data science data
analytics
having a place to go where they can look
it up and scroll down and see different
things you're doing whether it's
linkedin in this case which is the
business profile most commonly used
github where you have stuff published
facebook
i'm always hesitant because that tends
to push more towards
uh social media type jobs and other jobs
uh but certainly
there's people who have facebook who do
marketing and stuff like that but these
links
having these basic links here is
important people are starting to look
for that for
some other setup maybe you have a
personal website
this is a good place to put that so that
they now have a multitude of links
that go back to you and highlight who
you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts
we have a combination of experience
education
skills certifications and you can see
they're organized
if you have you know a lot of people
like to see
what kind of degree you have they want
to know where it came from and if you
just got out of college you're going to
put education at the top
and then maybe you'll put skills after
that and then your experience at the
bottom
if you've been in the field for years
you know my degree
just to give you my age goes back to the
night early 90s so i
usually put education at the very bottom
and then because a lot of the stuff i'm
trying to sell myself on right now
is my skills i actually put that at the
top and i'll put my education my
certifications at the bottom my skills
and then my experience is since it's a
huge part of my resume
goes next you can organize these in
whatever order you want that's going to
work best for you
and sell you so remember you're selling
yourself this is your image
probably don't wear an old tie-dye
t-shirt with holes in it
you know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your
and then what do you have to offer the
company and again when i put out
resumes and i haven't done a resume in a
while you go in there and you can take
this and reorganize this so if the
company's looking for something specific
you might put the experiences specific
to that company
you might even take experience if you
have like a long job
history like i do i've gone into a lot
of different things you might leave out
those companies
or those experiences that had nothing to
do with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about
30 seconds to glance over maybe a minute
tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have linkedin
and they can now take this and they come
back to it and they go okay let's look
at this person a little closer
so quick overview this is your sell
sheet selling you
to the company so always tie it to the
company so that
you have that what am i going to give
this company what are they going to get
from me we've covered a lot on data
science engineer in general and we've
gone over a basic
resume remember keep it simple short and
direct
that is so important with that resume
thank you all for watching this video
tutorial on r for data science full
course
i hope you liked it if you have any
questions then please put them in the
comments section of the video
our team will help you solve your
queries thank you for watching
stay tuned for more from simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here